COMMITTEE ON HEALTH.
BUT A WELCOME EVERYONE HERE
TODAY HAVE A FEW ANNOUNCEMENTS
BEFORE WE BEGIN WE HAD TO HAVE
NINE ITEMS ON THE AGENDA. ONE OF
THE ITEMS -- ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
SB FOUR FORTY BY MYSELF IS
ACTUALLY ON CONSENT -- WE'RE
GOING O ALSO TAKE UP -- ITEM
NUMBER FIVE SP ONE SIXTY FIVE BY --
PRO TEM ATKINS FIRST AND SEE
SHE'S HERE SO THANK YOU WELL
COME AND SO -- AND ACTUALLY DO
SOME FISH MY NOTES WITH IF YOU
WISH TO COME UP -- AND YOU
WITNESSES THAT BE WONDERFUL -- I
ALSO WANT TO MAKE NOTE THAT JUST --
REMIND PEOPLE FOR THE RULES --
US THIS IS ONE OF OUR FIRST
HEARINGS -- THIS YEAR IS THAT --
JOE WE'RE GOING TO ASK THAT --
IT EACH THE PRO AND THE CON IF
THERE ARE WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY THAT -- THAT -- THEY
HAVE A MAXIMUM OF SIX MINUTES.
SOMETIMES YOU HAVE TO YOU GOT
THREE MINUTES APIECE YES THREE
YOU CAN THE TWO MINUTES A PIECE --
AGAIN KAMALA THE SIX MINUTES AND
YOU NOT TO USE UP ALL SIX
MINUTES -- AND THEN AFTER THAT
WE TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT PUBLIC
COMMENT IS BASICALLY NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION IF YOU REPRESENT AN
ORGANIZATION WHETHER YOU'RE FOR
OR AGAINST THE BILL.
SO WE'RE NOT -- SO THAT'S TO
EXPRESS YOUR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION SO THAT'S HOW WE'RE
GOING TO DO THAT AND WE'RE GONNA
GO AHEAD.
AND ACTUALLY IF YOU DON'T MIND
AND PRETEND LET'S FIRST
ESTABLISH A QUORUM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FOR THE
CORN.
HAND HERE AND HERE STONE STONE
HERE DRAWS SO YES HEROES I WAS
HERE GROW [inaudible]
HER TADO.
LEYVA MITCHELL MONNING HERE
MONNING IS HERE RUBIO.
RUBIO IS HERE OKAY WE HAVE A
QUORUM OKAY -- META PRO TEM WILL
COME IN THE FOR YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND COLLEAGUES I ALSO
WANT.
TO THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME GO
FIRST MISTER CHAIRMAN I'M HERE%
TODAY TO PRESENT SB.
ONE SIXTY FIVE SB ONE SIXTY FIVE
IS ANOTHER STEP IN OUR EFFORT TO
DEVELOP A MECHANISM THAT WILL
ENSURE THAT LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENT ARE ELLIE PEAS.
OF MEDI CAL ENROLLEES HAVE
QUALIFIED IN PERSON LANGUAGE
INTERPRETER SERVICES WHEN THEY
VISIT THEIR MEDICAL PROVIDER.
I TOOK OVER THIS ISSUE FROM
FORMER SPEAKER OPERAS EMERITUS
PER AS WHEN I BECAME SPEAKER IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND TWENTY FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN THE ORIGINAL PROPOSAL
ESTABLISHED A FRAMEWORK FOR
QUALIFIED WORKFORCE THAT WOULD
BE AVAILABLE WHENEVER AN
INTERPRETER.
WAS NEEDED IN A MEDICAL SETTING
AFTER THREE UNSUCCESSFUL
ATTEMPTS INCLUDING TWO VETOES WE
TRIED A NEW APPROACH.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN BUDGET THE
BROWN ADMINISTRATION AGREED TO A
THREE MILLION DOLLAR
AUGMENTATION FOR THE SUPPORT.
OF ACTIVITIES RELATED TO A
MEDICAL INTERPRETER PILOT
PROJECT STUDY OR BOTH.
THE ACCOMPANYING BILL AB SIX
THIRTY FIVE AT THAT TIME A
TWENTY SIXTEEN HAS SINCE BEEN
INTERPRETED.
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES MAYBE WE NEED
INTERPRETERS THEIR GOAL I DIDN'T
SAY THAT ON THE RECORD.
HI TO ME THAT THE STUDY MUST BE
UNDERTAKEN AND COMPLETED PRIOR
TO THE IMPLEMENTATION OF ANY
PILOT PROJECTS.
AFTER MUCH DELAY OF VENDOR WAS
SELECTED A CONTRACT SIGNED AND
THE STUDY FINALLY BEGIN IN
JANUARY OF THIS YEAR.
AS THE AUTHOR I'M HERE TO TELL
YOU AND I HAD MULTIPLE
CONVERSATIONS WITH -- MOST OF
YOU OVER THE YEARS -- THAT WAS
NOT CONSISTENT WITH OUR INTENT
THE PURPOSE OF SB ONE SIXTY FIVE
IS TO CLARIFY OUR VIEW OF THAT
AGREEMENT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN COLLEAGUES I
KNOW THAT BASED ON YOUR OWN
PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCES OR FROM
YOUR EXPERIENCE IN THE
LEGISLATURE ALL OF YOU ARE AWARE
OF THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF OUR MEDI
CAL POPULATION.
AND THE LANGUAGE DIVERSITY THAT
IS CALIFORNIA.
SO JUST A FEW FACTS ACCORDING TO
DH CS RESEARCH AND ANALYTICAL
STUDIES DIVISION THE REPORT
ROUGHLY SAYS IT 38%.
OF ALL MEDICARE ELIGIBLE
ENROLLEES REPORT A LANGUAGE
OTHER THAN ENGLISH AS THEIR
PRIMARY SPOKEN LANGUAGE SPANISH
VIETNAMESE CANTONESE MANDARIN
ARMENIAN MOST FREQUENTLY
REPORTED LANGUAGES AMONG MEDI
CAL IS NON ENGLISH SPEAKERS.
WHEN THE NUMBER OF MEDI CAL
ENROLLEES WHOSE PRIMARY
LANGUAGES OTHER THAN ENGLISH?
AND IT GEOGRAPHIC REGION REACHES
A CERTAIN NUMBER OR PERCENTAGE
KNOWN AS A THRESHOLD THE MEDI
CAL MANAGED CARE PLANS ARE
REQUIRED TO TRANSLATE IMPORTANT
WRITTEN DOCUMENTS.
IN ADDITION THERE'S A GENERAL
REQUIREMENT THAT ALL ELLIE P.
ENROLLEES BE PROVIDED ORAL
INTERPRETATION SERVICES.
HOWEVER THE ACTUAL DELIVERY OF
INTERPRETATION SERVICES IS NOT
SYSTEMATICALLY PROVIDED OR
MONITORED.
IT IS GENERALLY LOOK GENERALLY
LEFT UP TO EACH PROVIDER AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS HAS RESULTED
IN THE USE OF ON QUALIFIED
INTERPRETERS.
WHICH COULD INCLUDE FAMILY
MEMBERS IN SOME CASES ARE THE
KIDS OR FRIENDS AND THAT HAS AN
IMPACT ON THE ABILITY -- TO IT
HERE TOO MEDICAL DIRECTIONS OF
MEDICAL PERFECTION YOU
PROFESSIONALS TO GET -- THE
QUALITY OF CARE THAT YOU NEED SO
THE CLARIFICATION IN THIS BILL
WILL ENSURE THAT NO FURTHER TIME
IS WASTED AND THE DH CS CAN BE
IN ESTABLISHING PILOT PROJECTS%
WITH THE ULTIMATE GOAL.
OF DEVELOPING A SYSTEM TO INSURE
QUALIFIED INTERPRETERS SO I
WOULD YET AGAIN ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AS WE CONTINUE TO TRY TO
GET THIS PROGRAM A PILOT'S
RUNNING -- UP AND RUNNING -- IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA I HAVE
TWO PEOPLE TO TESTIFY THEY WILL
FOLLOW THE TIME LIMIT -- AND
CERTAINLY I'M THRILLED TO HAVE
BOTH OF THEM HERE HERE MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
MARKETS CASTER HOME WHO IS A
POLICY ADVOCATE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK AND OF COURSE BRIAN
ALISON THE POLITICAL AND
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR OF ASKED ME --
IS HERE TO TESTIFY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBER THEM
A WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
SENATORS MARKETS GOT THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK.
STEPHEN WAS A SUPPORTER OF THE
ORIGINAL A. B. SIX THIRTY FIVE
FROM TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN JUST I
WISH IT THE THE FUNDING FOR THE
STUDY IN THE PILOT PROJECT -- WE
HAVE LONG BEEN A VOICE FOR
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AND HAVE
A HISTORY OF ADVOCATING FOR
CULTURALLY AND CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY APPROPRIATE
SERVICES.
IN THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM -- OUR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS OF SHARED
PERSONAL STORIES THAT DESCRIBE
THEIR FEAR NAVIGATING THE HEALTH
SYSTEM.
DESCRIBING THE INAPPROPRIATE
CARE THE RECEIVE WHEN THE
TEMPERATURES ARE NOT USED AND
HAVE EXPRESSED THE NEED FOR
QUALIFIED AND CULTURALLY.
COMPETENT INTERPRETERS.
AS ONE OF OUR PARTNERS PUT IT
IT'S CLEAR NO CHILD OR ANYONE
SHOULD BE FORCED TO INTERPRET.
FOR ONE'S OWN FAMILY MEMBERS
THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE IN THE
INTRICATE SYSTEM -- OF HEALTH.
SB ONE SIXTY FIVE INSURERS
CALIFORNIA'S MOVING FLOOR WITH
THE GOAL OF PROVIDING LINGUISTIC
APPROPRIATE INTERPRETATION
SERVICES BY EXTENDING THE SUNSET
DATE OF ITERPRETATION STUDY AND
ALLOWING PILOT PROJECTS TO BEGIN
IMPLEMENTING -- STRATEGIES FROM
THAT STUDY THESE IS MORE PROUD
TO SUPPORT THE SP ONE SIXTY FIVE
I THINK THE PROPER TIME FOR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AND
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
WITH THE CHAIR MEMBERS BRIAN
OFTEN ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES -- PLEASED
TO BE HERE -- S. -- IN SUPPORT
OF THE PRO TERMS ARE.
SENATE BILL ONE SIXTY FIVE A WE
WORK WITH US IN IRAQ IS NOW --
FOR MANY YEARS SHE REFERENCE TO
LAUNCH A PILOT PROGRAM IN
CALIFORNIA TO COMPREHENSIVELY
ASSESS -- HOW TO ADDRESS WELL
KNOWN DEFICIENCIES AND LIVER
AMERICA A MEDICAL INTERPRETATION
SERVICES AND MEDICAL SYSTEM -- A
REVIEW OF ACADEMIC LITERATURE --
CONDUCTED BY OUR INTERNATIONAL
UNION SUGGEST WHAT COMMONSENSE
SUGGEST -- THE IN PERSON MEDICAL
INTERPRETATION SERVICES ARE THE
MOST EFFECTIVE WAY TO PROVIDE
HEALTHCARE SERVICES TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO SPEAK ENGLISH
LESSON WELL ON THAT LITERATURE
CLEARLY DEMONSTRATES THE NEED
FOR IN VALUE OF A TRAINED IN
PERSON MEDICAL INTERPRETATIONS
WORK FORCE -- AND CLEAR
ADVANTAGES.
SUCH AS HIGHER QUALITY OF CARE
PATIENT SATISFACTION CULTURAL
COMPETENCE AND THE CAPTURE OF
CRITICAL NONVERBAL CUES OVER
REMOTE.
INTERPRETATION SERVICES WITHOUT
IN PERSON INTERPRETERS HEALTH
CARE HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS
WHETHER IT'S A POSITION -- LIKE
DOCTOR PAN -- WAR PHARMACISTS --
LIKE CENTER STONE ARE FORCED TO
RELY ON LANGUAGE LINES OVER THE
PHONE FOR THE FAMILY MEMBERS OF
PATIENTS AS HAS BEEN REFERENCED --
FOR IN SOME INSTANCES EVEN MORE
INFORMALLY -- HOUSEKEEPERS AND
JANITORS START TO PROVIDE
TRANSLATIONS ALL OF THESE
ALTERNATIVES ARE MORE LIKELY. TO
RESULT MISS COMMUNICATIONS A
VITAL INFORMATION -- EITHER BY
THE PATIENT TO THE POSITION OR
THE HEALTH PROFESSIONAL TO THE
PATIENT -- THEN INTERPRET IN
PERSON INTERPRETATION BY SOMEONE
WHO IS TRYING TO PROVIDE THAT
SERVICE -- SO S. WAS MENTION SP
ONE SIXTY FIVE PROPOSES TO
CONDUCT A PILOT PROJECT
CONCURRENTLY WITH THE STUDY
THAT'S NOW ON THE WAY --
REGARDING THE VALUE TRAINED
PERSON INTERPRETATION SERVICES
AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST BUT NOT
BOTH.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
TO COME TO THE BACK MICROPHONE.
IN THE WAY.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY HERE TO REGISTER
OUR LEAD SUPPORT THANKS THANK
YOU.
LEE BY MOLLY BYNUM UW ASKING
LOCAL THEIR NINE THIRTY AND WILL
SUPPORT.
I SEE NO ONE ELSE AT THE
MICROPHONE AREN'T ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
A SCENE NO AND COMING UP -- TO
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
A CENTER MONEY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST
WANT TO THANK THE PRO TEM.
FOR HER PERSISTENCE IN MOVING
THIS FORWARD I KNOW.
MY DISTRICT WE HAVE MULTIPLE
LANGUAGE WORK FORCE -- THE
COUNTY HOSPITAL.
HIS.
CHARLES HAD BILINGUAL ENGLISH
SPANISH.
INTERPRETATION BUT NOW THEY'VE
HAD TO DEVELOP THEIR OWN
TRAINING OF INDIGENOUS LANGUAGE
INTERPRETERS.
AGAIN TO PROVIDE QUALITY
HEALTHCARE TO WORK FORCE MEMBERS
PEOPLE THAT ARE CONTRIBUTING O
OUR ECONOMY.
A AND WHO DESERVE.
QUALITY HEALTH CARE SO AGAIN
THANK YOU -- MAYOR PRO TEM THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS YES ETCETERA.
YOU ALMOST BY EUROPEAN.
BETTER YOU KNOW BOULEVARD IN SIX
YOU IN THIS IN THIS FUN YOUR ON
THIS THE CAPTAIN.
THE INSTRUCTION AS MEDICAL.
SO I BELIEVE I COULD SPEAK
PRETTY GOOD SPANISH BUT I
WOULDN'T DARE.
GIVE INSTRUCTIONS ON MEDICAL
ISSUES IN SPITE OF THE FACT THAT
I KNOW IT SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
MASON RUBIO.
I JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD OF AS
THE ON ALL SPANISH IN MY FIRST
LANGUAGE AND DATA.
I STILL SPEAK 90% OF IT IN
SPANISH AND I THINK THAT.
MOST OF OUR COMMUNITIES WILL
BENEFIT FOR SOMETHING LIKE THIS
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU TAKING
THE LEAD ON THIS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THE OTHER
SO I JUST I JUST WANT -- TO ALSO --
I THINK THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
CONTINUED EFFORTS I'M PROUD TO
BE A CO AUTHOR ON THIS BILL.
AS A PHYSICIAN I CERTAINLY IF
THE WITNESS STAND AND JUST
WITNESS -- ACTUALLY EXPERIENCE
FIRST HAND THE FRUSTRATION OF
TRYING TO COMMUNICATE WITH A
PATIENT OR FAMILY -- WIN WITHOUT
INTERPRETER AND I KEEP AND IF
I'M FRUSTRATED I CAN'T IMAGINE
WHAT IT MEANS FOR THE FAMILY.
SO WHEN THAT HAPPENS -- SO WHAT
HAPPENS IS SO BASICALLY THEY
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY I'M ASKING
ABOUT AND IF YOU'RE USING A
FAMILY MEMBER.
YOUR ASSN SORT OF QUESTIONS AND
THAT THEY MAY NOT FEEL
FAMILY MEMBER IS INTERPRETING AS
WELL FAMILY MEMBER WHO HAS TO
ANSWER THE QUESTION AND
CERTAINLY ANY TREATMENT PLANS.
THIS IS REALLY AN ISSUE OF
ACCESS TO CARE AND ALSO
CERTAINLY DOES A BIG ISSUE FOR
THE API COMMUNITY PARTICULAR --
BECAUSE THERE'S SO MANY
DIFFERENT LANGUAGES AND SO FORTH
SO AGAIN I WANT TO THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH FOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD.
AND REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
CONTINUED PERSISTENCE IN THIS
ISSUE AND ACTUALLY SHARE YOUR
FRUSTRATION WITH DCS AS WELL AND
THE DELAYS THAT HAPPENED I WILL
SAY THAT.
SO THANK YOU.
THIS IS THEIR MOTION.
NOT A MOTION OKAY SIR IS A RUBIO.
IMPORT AND DOES GOES BACK TO MY
CHILDHOOD AND IT'S REALLY
DIFFICULT TO UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW
THE LANGUAGE BARRIERS BUT JUST
TO SHARE WHEN I WAS YOUNGER.
THERE IS A FAMILY THAT I KNEW --
MEDICATION WOULD SAY ONCE A DAY
AND PEOPLE DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT
ONCE IN SPANISH IS ELEVEN SO
SOMEONE TAKING HAPPENED PILLS.
BECAUSE IT'S AT ONCE A DAY STILL
THESE ARE THE KIND OF THINGS
THAT COULD CAUSE.
EXTREME HARM AND DAMAGE TO OUR-FAMILY SO JUST WANT TO GET A
SENSE OF HOW IMPORTANT IT IS. TO
TO BE CLEAR ON ON YOU KNOW
INSTRUCTIONS AND DIRECTIONS
THANK YOU DOCTOR PAN.
OKAY -- MOVED OKAY -- ACRE
CENTER STONE -- MOVE THE BILL --
THANK YOU SO THERE'S A MOTION --
BENEFITING YOU WISH TO CLOSE
ONLY TO SAY WE REALLY NEED TO
GET THIS MOVING -- IN THIS IT IT
YOU HEAR THE HUMAN STORIES BUT
THERE'S A PRACTICALITY TO OUR
SYSTEM IN TERMS OF NOT BEING
ABLE TO BE MORE EFFICIENT AND
HOW WE PROVIDE CARE.
IT ISN'T JUST COMPLIANCE IT IS A
WELL RUN EFFICIENT SYSTEM SO I
HOPE WE CAN GET MOVING ON THIS
AND I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COURTESY.
THANK YOU CAN I VOTE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OKAY US IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY CENTER STONE THE MOTION
IS DO PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
ASPECT FOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AM I AND II STONE.
STONE I DORADO.
DRAWS -- I'D GROW.
GROW I HER TOTAL.
LEYVA.
LEYVA I MITCHELL.
MONNING.
MONNING I RUBIO.
RUBIO HI.
THE BILL HAS SEVEN VOTES WHICH
IS ENOUGH TO GET IT OUT WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THANKS FOR MUCH.
OKAY AND I THINK I SAW CENTER
BELL HERE -- CENTER BILL INTO
YOU.
OKAY -- SO ACTUALLY I JUST
REMIND YOU FOR THE RULES.
WE DO NOT LOUD DEMONSTRATIONS
THAT INCLUDES CLAPPING HOWEVER
IF YOU WISH TO EXPRESS YOUR
SUPPORT AND POSITIVE YOU CAN DO
THIS THAT'S FINE.
OKAY THERE YOU GO I'M GOOD ALL
RIGHT.
EXCELLENT.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SO -- SIR
BALANCE YOU HAVE TO BILLS. THREE
BILLS YES THREE BILLS.
SO YOU JUST TAKE THEM IN THE
FOLLOWERS -- OKAY SO WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND START WITH ITEM NUMBER
ONE SB [inaudible]
TEN GIVE.
THE THREE THE THREE BACK.
TO FIVE PROVIDING.
OKAY NINE YEAH [inaudible]
OKAY.
IRMA MEMBERS TODAY PERCENT SB.
TEN THIS IS A BILL WHICH
ESTABLISHES A CERTIFICATION
PROGRAM FOR PEER SUPPORT
SPECIALIST.
NOW APPEARS PROVIDER IS A PERSON
WHO HAS LIVED EXPERIENCE WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS OR SUBSTANCE
ABUSE DISORDERS.
WHO DRAWS ON THAT EXPERIENCE
ALONG WITH THE SKILLS LEARNED IN
TRAINING PROGRAMS TO PROVIDE
CRITICAL SUPPORT TO CLIENTS AND
TREATMENT PROGRAMS?
OTHER OFTEN PEERS SHARED NOT
LIVE NOT JUST LIVING EXPERIENCES
BUT THE NEIGHBORHOOD LANGUAGE.
AND CULTURE.
WHICH THE DAY SIR.
THE ACROSS THE NATION -- SUPPORT
PROGRAMS HAVE EMERGED.
AS A A PRACTICE THAT WITH PROVEN
BENEFITS -- TO BOTH PEERS AND
THE CLIENTS THEY ASSIST.
AND WE'RE WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A
HAND OUT THAT WILL DISTRIBUTED
[inaudible]
ON FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
ON JUST GIVE ME A A ONE PAGE THE
FIRST SIDE IS A DESCRIPTION OF
THE PROGRAM'S FOR PEER SUPPORT
SPECIALIST.
THE OTHER SIDE SHOWS THE
EVIDENCE BASED.
OUR RESEARCH THAT SHOWS HOW
BENEFICIAL PEER SUPPORT PROGRAMS
OR CAR.
NOW PIERS CAN INCLUDE PEOPLE OF
LIVE EXPERIENCE FAMILY MEMBERS
CARE TAKERS -- INDIVIDUALS
LIVING WITH MENTAL ILLNESS OUR
STATE.
NOW OUR STATE HAS -- FALLING
BEHIND.
THE RESIGNATION ON THIS ISSUE
AND IS LONG OVERDUE IN FACT IT'S
TIME TO ACT NOW.
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW. FORTY EIGHT
OTHER STATES HAVE DONE WHAT I'M
PROPOSING DID IN THIS BILL.
ALREADY THEY'VE ALREADY THAT
WERE ONE OF TO THAT HOUSE.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT URGES
STATES TO ADOPT CERTAIN TYPE
OCCASION PROGRAMS BECAUSE IT
HELPS STANDARDIZED THE PRACTICES
THE BEST PRACTICES AND MEDICAID.
REIMBURSES 50%.
OF THE COST APPEARS SERVICES IN
STATES WITH THESE.
OUR STATE CERTIFICATION PROGRAM
SO ESTABLISHING SUCH A PROGRAM
WOULD REDUCE THE FINANCIAL
BURDEN ON OUR COUNTY PROVIDERS.
THE FEDERAL CENTERS FOR MEDICARE
AND MEDICAID RELEASED THE
GUIDANCE BACK IN -- TWENTY OH
SEVEN TWELVE YEARS AGO.
ESTABLISHING THESE PROGRAMS --
AND THE STANDARDS -- TO ENABLE
THE USE OF FEDERAL MEDICAID
FINANCIAL PARTICIPATION.
CALIFORNIA HAS YET TO DO THIS.
THE RESEARCH ON THIS ISSUE IS IS
CLEAR.
AND PEOPLE SUFFERING FROM MENTAL
ILLNESS OR SUBSTANCE ABUSE
DISORDERS HAVE BETTER OUTCOMES
IF THEY CAN BONTA TWIT TRAINED
PEER SUPPORT -- SUPPORTERS
DURING HER TREATMENT.
THE BILL MAKES THE SURE THE
PEERS GET THE TRAINING THEY NEED.
TO DO THE BEST WORK IT WILL
ENSURE THEY GET PAID FOR THAT
WORK TO HELP GROW OR MENTAL
HEALTH.
SERVICES WORK FORCE.
AND RESULT IN BETTER CARE -- I
AM -- ESPECIALLY -- HAPPY TO
INTRODUCE THE CHAIR OF OUR STATE --
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION.
TO TARA -- TEMPLIN AND PUT SHE
SAID THE ACTUAL EXPERT ON THIS
SUBJECT SO SHE STARTED CHAIR OF
THE COMMISSION.
BUT AN EXPERT NOW I'LL TURN IT
OVER TO HER AND THEN WE HAVE
DOCTOR.
JOHN SHARON HE'S THE DIRECTOR OF
MENTAL HEALTH FOR LOS ANGELES
COUNTY.
AND KERIS MERRICK IS PRESENT OF
CO FOR PROJECT RETURN.
PEER SUPPORT NETWORK SO TO QATAR
YOU'LL BE THE FIRST.
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- WE
SIX MINUTES FOR ALL THE
WITNESSES HOW ME WITNESSES ARE
SPEAKING. THREE OKAY SO E. SELF.
ROUGHLY TWO MINUTES OF PEACE BUT
IS TOTAL SIX SO IF SOMEONE TAKES
UP MORE TIMES ON THE STATE OF
LESS.
THANK YOU WELCOME THANK YOU
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS --
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY TODAY A AS THANK YOU A
CENTER OF BATTLE US SENATE ABOUT
MENTION MY NAME IS QATAR TAMPLIN
AND I'M THE CHAIR OF THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION AND
THE CONSUMER EMPOWERMENT MANAGER
FOR ALAMEDA COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CARE -- THE COMMISSION
ALAMEDA COUNTY LA COUNTY THE
CYBER AGAINST THE TO THE MANY
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE IN THIS
ROOM AND THE DIVERSE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA.
ARE HERE IN SUPPORT OF SB.
TEN AN THE GOAL TO FINALLY
ESTABLISH A STATE WIDE PEER
SPECIALIST CERTIFICATION PROGRAM.
AND AGAIN I WANT TO THANK
SENATOR BELL FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
ON THIS BILL AND FOR NOT GIVING
UP ON US -- AS A PERSON WHO CAME
TO THIS COUNTRY AS A REFUGEE AND
THE EARLY EIGHTIES.
MY RESILIENCY FROM THE MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS IS I'VE
EXPERIENCED -- WAS PROVIDED
THROUGH PEER SUPPORT I NEEDED TO
FEEL HOPE THAT I CAN RECOVER IN
MY PEER SUPPORTERS LIKE CHARIS
WHO SITTING RIGHT -- NEXT TO
DOCTOR SHARON -- AS ONE OF THEM
INCLUDING MANY IN THE ROOM --
THE RESEARCH SUPPORTS THIS THIS
COUNTLESS STUDIES AS OF THE
SENATOR PASSED OUT THE DOCUMENT
FROM SANSA WHICH ALSO.
CARRIES MIRED HELPED CREATE WHEN
SHE WORKED AT SAM'S A INDICATES
THE POSITIVE OUTCOMES -- I
STRUGGLE THE NOT MY LOOK.
YOU KNOW I THERE WAS A TIME
WHERE I WANTED TO TAKE MY LIFE
AND IT WAS -- I NEEDED TO
CONNECT WITH SOMEONE THAT COULD
HEAR THE PAIN I WAS GOING
THROUGH.
CAN HOLD THE SPACE AND TO BE
ABLE TO WALK WITH ME ON THIS
JOURNEY OF RECOVERY.
I'M I'M NOT GONNA GO INTO THE
THE THE RESEARCH BEHIND IT
BECAUSE THE CENTER ALREADY YEAH
SHARED AND IT'S RIGHT IN FRONT
OF YOU.
BUT AS HE SAID THIS IS OUR YEAR
THE TIME IS NOW -- WE NEED HERE
THE PURE WORK FORCE TO BE VALUED
AND SUPPORTED BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AGAIN FORTY EIGHT OTHER STATES
HAVE THE CERTIFICATION AND I
REALLY DON'T WANNA BE BAGGING
BUT I DON'T WANT THIS TO BE THE
LAST EITHER -- THIS BILL IS
EXACTLY WHAT WE NEED IT'S OUR
OPPORTUNITY TO LEVERAGE FEDERAL
RESOURCES STRENGTHEN ACCESS AND
IMPROVE MENTAL HEALTH OUTCOMES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND WE ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTES.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ME IT'S SUCH
AN HONOR TO BE HERE TODAY -- AND
BIG TIME THANKS TO SENATOR BILL
HAS BEEN RELENTLESS ABOUT
GETTING THIS TAKEN CARE OF LOS
ANGELES.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- I
WANT ALSO THINK MY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS DEL STEINBERG -- AND
ALL OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE HERE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS WORK TODAY
INCLUDING A BUSLOAD APPEARS FROM
LOS ANGELES COUNTY -- WHEN I
SHOWED UP ITALY COUNTY THEY SAID
WHAT WAS THE WHAT'S YOUR TOP
PRIORITY THIS WAS MY TOP
PRIORITIES A MENTAL HEALTH
DIRECTOR LOS ANGELES COUNTY?
RECOVERY IS NOT JUST ABOUT
TREATMENT RECOVERIES ABOUT
OPPORTUNITIES THIS OFFERS AN ON
PARALLEL AMOUNT OF OPPORTUNITY
FOR PEOPLE WHO NEED WORK THEY
NEED TO BELONG TO TEAMS ANY
PURPOSE IN THEIR LIVES.
BOB IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS A BIG
PART OF THE REFORM IN OUR SYSTEM
THAT THAT FORM WILL BE DRIVEN BY.
OUR CONSUMERS ON THAT NOTE THIS
ISN'T ABOUT CHARITY THIS IS
ABOUT LEVERAGING THE KNOWLEDGE
OF LIVED EXPERIENCE THE STREET
CREDIBILITY THE TRUST AND
RESPECT TO IMPROVE ENGAGEMENT.
THAT IS CRITICAL TO OUR FIELD.
NEXT TO ME IS KERIS MYRICK YOU
ACTUALLY IS THE CHIEF APPEARS IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY HER PRIOR.
JOB WAS RECOGNIZED EARLIER AND
KERIS WILL LIKE MY CHIEF OF
PSYCHIATRY.
RECRUIT [inaudible]
HIRE.
TRAIN DEPLOY ORGANIZE A
WORKFORCE OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
TO GO AFTER THE ISSUES IN MENTAL
HEALTH AND LOS ANGELES COUNTY
THIS MUST HAPPEN IN CALIFORNIA
WE NEED TO SUSTAIN FUNDING IT
WILL SAVE LIVES AND MONEY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH -- GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- FOR ALL
OF THE WORK THAT YOU ALL DO AND
FOR HAVING US HERE I'M KAREN
COMMITTEE THANK YOU SENATOR PAUL
FOR ALL OF THE WORK THAT YOU'VE
DONE.
I'M KERIS MYRICK ON THE
DISCIPLINE CHIEF OF SERVICES IS
DOCTOR SHARON SIDE PREVIOUSLY I
WAS THE DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE
OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS FOR THE
CENTER FOR MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES THAT SANSA.
THE DOCUMENTS THAT YOU LOOKED AT
TODAY I'M REALLY ALMOST IN TEARS
BECAUSE I NEVER THOUGHT THEY
WOULD SHOW UP IN HEARING THAT.
OKAY THAT THIS IS REALLY AMAZING
THE WORK THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
LEAD DURING MY TIME THERE IS
MAKING A DIFFERENCE TO HELP
STATES ADVANCE THE PIER WORK
FORCE.
IN ORDER TO SAVE LIVES YES IT'S
GOING TO COST MONEY BUT THE
SAVINGS ON THE AND ARE THE LIVES
THAT ARE SAFE I'M A PERSON WHO
WAS DIAGNOSED WITH SCHIZOPHRENIA.
I WAS TOLD I WOULD NEVER BE
DOING WHAT I'M DOING TODAY THAT
I WOULD NEVER HAVE TWO ONE THREE
DEGREES BEHIND MY NAME.
THAT'S HOW I MET MY PEER
SUPPORTER -- MISS JACKIE
MCKINNEY -- AND AS AN AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMAN DIAGNOSED WITH A
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS MEETING
SOMEONE WHO WAS JUST LIKE ME
GAVE ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE
FORWARD. TWO WEEKS AGO I SAW UP
HERE IN -- AND A HOLLYWOOD --
WHO IS TWENTY YEARS OLD I MET MY
FIRST HERE WHEN I WAS?
FORTY NOBODY SHOULD HAVE TO WAIT
THAT LONG FAMILY SHOULDN'T HAVE
TO WAIT THAT LONG WE NEED TO
HAVE THE SERVICES WE NEED TO
HAVE THEM IN A IN A PROFESSIONAL
ICE MANNER.
SUCH THAT THERE ARE STANDARDS
ACROSS THE STATE AS THERE ARE IN
OTHER STATES IT IS ONLY TWO
STATE EVEN JUST A CUP COLUMBIA
HOUSE THAT'S RIGHT.
IT IS ONLY SOUTH DAKOTA IN
CALIFORNIA WE DO NOT WANT TO BE
LAST WE WILL NOT WAIT TO BE LOST
I REALLY REALLY AM LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE SUPPORT IN ORDER
THAT OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND OUR CITIZENS CAN HAVE THE
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS ALONG WITH
THE OTHER TREATMENTS CROSS
DISCIPLINARY TEAMS WHICH WE DO
IN LA AND ELSEWHERE -- THAT THEY
NEED AND DESERVE TO SAVE LIVES
WERE LOOKING FOR YOUR A YES VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY THANK YOU DR NEGLECTED TO
SAY THAT SHE'S THE NATIONAL.
PRESIDENT OF MIAMI.
WELL NO I WAS.
I GOT A LOT OF CREDIT I GOT A
LOT GOING ON HERE.
YEAH.
THANK YOU THANK YOU WE HAVE A
NATIONAL LEADER NINE EXCELLENT
WELL THANK YOU AND WE'RE HONORED
TO HAVE YOU HERE.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
INCOME THE MICROPHONE NAME
ORGANIZATION THAT YOU'RE
REPRESENTING ONE AND YOUR
EXPRESSION OF THAN POSITION.
THANK YOU WELCOME WE ARE
CONSTANTS ROSE AND JUSTIN WENT
WORTH OF LIVE FREE -- A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION AND WE
SUPPORT SENATOR BILL AND SB.
TEN THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT RIGHT WELCOME GOOD
AFTERNOON MICHELLE CAPITA WITH
US YEAH YOU CALIFORNIA I'M PROUD
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WELCOME I'M NOT ABOUT
OTHER WITH CREW STRATEGIES ON
BEHALF OF SAN JOSE MAYOR SAM
LICCARDO AND ALSO MENTAL HEALTH
AMERICA OF CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
IN THE WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CONNIE DELGADO ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION PLEASED TO
BE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
HEIDI SHRUNK WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
REHABILITATION AGENCIES IN
SUPPORT AND AGAIN HEIDI STRUNK
OM ON BEHALF OF THAT CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
IN WORKING WITH THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE
DISTRICTS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LAWRENCE REYES -- SEIU SEVEN TWO
ONE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND
ALSO SUFFERED IN THE FIGHT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ALONG THE THOMAS LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL
HEALTH COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKER.
AS SIXTY I USE SEVEN TWENTY ONE
STRONG REPRESENTED THE UNION AND
I AM STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
I SIMEON GANT CALIFORNIA BLACK
HEALTH NETWORK WE HEARD THIS
ISSUE IN OUR TOWN HALL MEETINGS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND WE ARE
IN SUPPORT WE BELIEVE IT'LL SAVE
LIVES AND MONEY.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS JOANNE FRIEDMAN
AND I AM JUST FOR ME -- ADVOCATE
ALSO ADVOCATE FOR CONSUMER
AFFAIRS LA DE LA DMA SACK A I'M
IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JOANNE
WEST POINT I WORK -- FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL HEALTH
HOMELESS OUTREACH MOBILE TEAM
AND I AM A MEMBER OF THE S. E.
I. YOU SEVEN TWO ONE AND I DO
SUPPORT SB.
TEN THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LESLIE
HILL I'M WITH DEPARTMENT OF
MENTAL HEALTH LOS ANGELES COUNTY
I'M A COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKER.
I AM ALSO WITH THE UNION S. E.
I. YOU SEVEN TWENTY ONE AND I AM
ABSOLUTELY A SUPPORTER OF SB TEN
I THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS GILBERT WILL BLOCK
IN AYE AYE SUPPORTERS BE TEN I
FROM LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES.
AND I SUPPORT SB TEN TO SAVE
LIVES AND HELP PEOPLE THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS FOR THE BETTERMENT
OF THE COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKING
WITH LOS ANGELES COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH I AM ALSO A MEMBER IT.
AS THE AYE YOU -- SEVEN TWENTY
ONE AND I'M SUPPORT OF SB
[inaudible]
TEN THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS BELLA LOPEZ AND
I'M A COMMUNITY WORKER. FOR
ALMOST TWENTY YEARS ALREADY.
OUR WAITING FOR THIS MOMENT.
I LOVE YOU SUPPORTED THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LETITIA MONSTRO DEPARTMENT OF
MENTAL HEALTH.
LA COUNTY I SUPPORT THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
HOSPITALS AND HEALTH SYSTEMS THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND THE VENTURA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS HERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
RESIDENTS HALLS WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
FOR MAURICE REGISTER REPRESENT A
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
A STRONG SUPPORT SB [inaudible]
TO THANK YOU.
WE NEED A ANTHONY APPOINTEE TO
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION.
AND AT FRESNO COUNTY RESIDENT
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
REGINALDO GLENN FORMER PEER
ADVOCATE CURRENT LA.
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL
HEALTH SUBSTANCE ABUSE COUNSELOR
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON AMANDA LEVY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON DON MONTONEROS
ARE ESSIE. SEVEN TWENTY ONE
MEMBER I AM A LOS GIFTS ANGELES
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL
HEALTH COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKER.
WITH WHOLE PERSON CARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB.
TEN THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS GAIL SULZER I'M A
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKER. FOR LOS
ANGELES COUNTY.
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF SB TENT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS IMMOBILIZED THE
FLOAT IS I'M WILL DID FROM THE
THE BUT THE MENTAL IT'S ON THE
MONTH OF THE SINUS.
I'M HERE BECAUSE I THE IN THE US
IN FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND PLEASE
BUT IT IS IN THE BILL SB DID
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS EUNICE AROUND
THIS AMOUNTS TO A VOLUNTEER FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL HEALTH.
NAMES YOU TO PLEASE ASK YOU FOR
A YES ON IS BE THEN.
THANK YOU.
JULIE INCLUDED OR ON BEHALF OF
OUR PEERS ENVISIONING AN
ENGAGING AND RECOVERY SERVICES
AND ALAMEDA COUNTY AS A SELF
IDENTIFIED PURE AND PROFESSIONAL
IN THE MENTAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
YOUR TO STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
AND MISCONDUCT ABOUT I JUST
FINISHED MY TRAINING AS IS BE A
SPECIALIST AND STUDIES OF
CONFIRMED THAT THE ESPECIALLY IS
THAT DOING A GREATJOB IMPROVE
AMID THE MENTAL HEALTH FOR
REHABILITATION IN CALIFORNIA.
I AM WERE PRESENTED -- IF WE
SHOULD MENTION PEONS IN OAKLAND
AND I SUPPORT THE SB.
TEN THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS PAMELA JORDAN I AM
AND ALAMEDA COUNTY XCELERATED
PURE SPECIALISTS.
I AM A MEMBER OF ALAMEDA CON
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEMS AND I
AM STRONG SUPPORT OF AS WRITTEN
THANK YOU.
GREETINGS ALL I AM PUSHING ME OF
PEERS IN VISION AND ENGAGING AND
RECOVERY SERVICES.
ALAMEDA COUNTY AND I'M STRONG
SUPPORT FOR SB TEN THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS KIND OF DAVIS
AND I'M WITH THE ADMIN ECONOMY
PULL OF CONSUMER TEMPLES
CONSUMER ADVOCACY.
AND WITH THE BLACK MAN SPEAK OF
RECOVERY SPECIALIST -- I IN
SUPPORT OF SB TEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
I'M ON A MACHINE A COKE OR I'M A
PART OF THE PEEL CC WHICH IS THE
POLITICAL WILL CUT COMMUTER
[inaudible]
FULLER.
CHAMPIONS AND I SUPPORT -- SB
SIX MONTHS SO NERVOUS S. B. TN.
AND I AM A LIVING WITNESS OF
WHAT PEER TO PEER TO PEER
SUPPORT CAN DO.
THANK YOU YOU DID A GREAT JOB
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS TONYA LEE HERE
AND I'M WITH THE POOL THE
CONSUMER JAPANESE AND I SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
FOR HI MY NAME IS MERRY HONDURAN
ALAMEDA COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CARE PULL OF CONSUMER CHAMPIONS
AND I AM IN SUPPORT.
OF SB TN THANK YOU.
I AM PUBLIC FRANKLIN AND I'M A
PULL THE CONSUMER CHAMPION OF
ALAMEDA COUNTY AND I'M APPEAR
SPECIALISTS AND I AM SUPPORT OF
SB.
TEN THANK YOU.
I AM CURTIS THREE BUT THE P. O.
C. C. AND I SUPPORT SB TEN THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON AUDIBLE SENATORS
MY NAME IS VIRGINIA HALL I'M
WITH ALAMEDA COUNTY BEHAVIOR
HEALTH CARE POOL OF CONSUMER
CHAMPIONS -- APPEARS SPECIALIST
GRADUATE AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF
SB.
TEN THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS AYE Q.
JOHNSON PROGRAM COORDINATOR
APPEARS ENVISIONING ENGAGE IN A
RECOVERY SERVICE AND I STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB.
TEN THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
DELORES BLACK MEN AND I'M A
MEMBER OF PEEL CC ALSO LIFT
EVERY VOICE AND SPEAK AND A
NOMINEE FACILITATOR AND I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
OF SB TEN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JAMES GLENN I'M A
PEER SUPPORT SPECIALIST AMID TO
APPEAR SUPPORT WORK FOR TWENTY
YEARS NOT SEEING THE IMPACT THAT
IT HAD THEM GIVING PEOPLE THEY
IDENTITY AUTHENTICITY VOICE AND
DIRECTION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELL HELLO MY NAME IS GORDON
REID I'M WOOD ALAMEDA COUNTY BAY
OF HEALTH CARE AND ALSO THE
CHECKOUT PERSON APPEALS CC.
AND I ALSO SUPPORT.
SB [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS MYRA CORONA AND
I AM PART OF P. O. C. C. N.
PUBLIC EDUCATION POLICY
EDUCATION -- AND I'M SUPPORT OF
SB TEN AND I ALSO SPEAK SPANISH.
THANK YOU.
CRISIS IN ME NUMBER OF MUDDY UP
IT IS YOU OPENED A LITTLE FOR
THE UP FOR YOU.
THE WHOLE GROUP FOR THE POISON
INCREDIBLE UCLA THAT'LL SON HIT
LIST YEP WILLIAM WHICH ALLOWED
HIM BREAK IN MISSISSIPPI THE YOU
LA MEANT THAT.
THE UP FOR YOU KAMALA LADY SAVE
A HAVE YOU.
GET A GOOD ASSET CLASSES.
HELLO -- GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS THE NORM OF THOSE MEN.
I WAS DIAGNOSED WITH.
THE TOOL.
YOU KNOW I HAVE.
TOOL.
I'M SORRY.
AND HEALTH PROBLEMS AND ISSUES.
BUT I'M HERE TO SUPPORT SB.
TEN I'M A FACILITATOR FOR
SPANISH SUPPORT GROUPS.
I'M ALSO A CO FACILITATOR FOR
TOOLS OTHER SPANISH SUPPORT
GROUPS.
I'M A CLIENT.
AND THREE GOALS IN LA COUNTY.
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT I'M ALSO
ACTIVITIES -- FOR THE CAB CLIENT
ADVISORY BOARD ACTIVITIES
COORDINATOR.
AND I FIGHT WITH MY CONDITION.
BUT WE NEED THIS. FOR US TO HAVE
OUR TITLES BECAUSE WE WITH CHEAP
SO MUCH AND THERE'S SO MUCH.
HELP THAT NEEDS TO GO OUT THERE
SO PLEASE HELP US. TO DO MORE
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MICHAEL RIGHT AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA
CLARA COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THREE THE ANDERSON ON
BEHALF OF THE ARC IN UNITED
CEREBRAL PALSY CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THERESA COMSTOCK ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LOCAL BEHAVIORAL HEALTH BOARDS
AND COMMISSIONS IN SUPPORT.
YOU. TO MADDEN REPRESENT A
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI MEGHAN STANTON I'M ON THE
BOARD OF KIMBROUGH CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF MENTAL HEALTH
CARE RUN ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL
AS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CONSUMER SELF HELP HERE LOCALLY
IN SACRAMENTO HERE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WHEN MEASURE BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAM
EXECUTIVES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU?
HI MY NAME IS CHRISTINA AND I'M
WITH THE POOL OF THERMOS
CHAMPIONS MORE SO WITH THE
PUBLIC POLICY EDUCATION
COMMITTEE.
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT SB TEN
THE HELP WAS HELP THEM AND HELP
THEM HELP US.
THANK YOU.
LIKE TO SAY SO [inaudible]
LISTENING.
AND YOU SUPPORT AND THAT'S WHY
SB TEN SPK OKAY THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS KENNETH GOLF.
AND OUR SUPPORT SB TEN I HAVE A
CERTIFICATE AS APPEARS SUPPORTER
[inaudible]
BY -- I'M ON THE PACIFIC CLINICS
CALLED THE ASSURANCE BOARD.
AND I AM THE TREASURER OF THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY CLIENT
COALITION.
I SUPPORTED AND WE'RE REALLY
PASSIONATE ABOUT.
THE OLDER.
GENERATION AS I'M GETTING UP
THERE MYSELF.
WE REALLY NEED ONE ANOTHER. TO
TO TO TO BILL EACH OTHER UP WE
THERE IS HOPE.
I THINK I CAN BE DONE.
THANK YOU SO ORTEZ ASKING PEOPLE
NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION THANK
YOU BUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FARMING
DATING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MORTON DOWNEY ON BEHALF OF
AMERICAN FOUNDATION FOR SUICIDE
PREVENTION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
IT'LL FOLLOW VENTURA COUNTY AND
STATE.
ADVOCACY SUPPORT UNDER M. HSA
SUPPORTING [inaudible]
TEN THANK YOU.
MORNING CARL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
REGGAE'S ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
IM GUADALUPE YET PLEASE I AM
HERE I AM ART AND CRAFTS
FACILITATOR FOR THIS SUPPORT
GROUP IN THE SPANISH.
AND WE KNEW YOU HELPFULL AND THE
SB TEN THANK YOU THANK YOU -- MY
NAME'S ANGELA BROCKMAN I AM A
RESIDENT OF SACRAMENTO AND I AM
CURRENTLY A STUDENT AT C. S. U.
S. AND I SUPPORT SB.
TEN THANK YOU.
HI ANDREA CORRECT ON BEHALF OF
ADVANCING CLIENT AND COMMUNITY
EMPOWERMENT THROUGH SUSTAINABLE
SOLUTIONS.
AND MENTAL HEALTH AMERICA OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
KAREN Và CARRY ON BEHALF OF NOR
CAL MHA AND ACCESS CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HELLO EVERYONE MY NAME IS DIANA
CARS STOLEN ALSO KNOWN AS DEANA
TO MY COMMUNITY WITH THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OF DEPARTMENT OF
MENTAL HEALTH.
I'M ALSO A MENTAL HEALTH
INSTRUCTOR AND KEEP YOUR SUICIDE
PREVENTION STRUCTURE AND I AM IN
FULL SUPPORT IT SAVE MY LIFE AND
WE GET TO TOUCH EACH OTHER SAVE
EACH OTHER'S LIVES THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS DANNY
OFFER FROM PLATINUM VISORS
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE NATIONAL ALLIANCE
ON MENTAL ILLNESS -- IN
ANTICIPATED SUPPORT -- SORRY TO
DO THAT BUT OUR BOARD HASN'T YET
VOTED ON ALL POSITIONS BUT WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB UNITE US
NINE A SIX LAST YEAR THANK YOU
FOR IT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY RACHEL FLORES
DIRECTOR HEALTH DIVISION SEIU
LOCAL SEVEN TO ONE WHERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TEN THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
PATRICIA GUESTS WITH SENECA
FAMILYOF AGENCIES A STATE WHY
PROVIDER OF CHILDREN SERVICES
AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
DANIEL A CALIFORNIA LINES OF
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ON TOP TWENTY DEL ADDED A COME
THE CORPORATION AND A DâN
CORPORATION.
SHARE.
I ORDER WENT SUPPORT SB WELL
ABOVE MEANT THEN.
OKAY THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS DEBORAH GATLIN --
APPEAR SUPPORT SPECIALIST FOR
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL HEALTH AND
I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF THAT C. R.
U. SEVEN TO ANYONE IN.
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TED THANK
YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON JIMMY FROM IN
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
WE'RE IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
RIGHT TO SOMEONE ELSE GóMEZ
MICROPHONE.
MARY HYATT FROM CALIFORNIA CIVIL
LIBERTIES ADVOCACY AND WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SEE NO ONE
ELSE AT THE MICROPHONE ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
CASEY NO WITNESSES OPPOSITION
QUESTION COMMITTEE MEMBER CENTER
STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
FOR SOMEONE WHO -- THANKS SO
MANY PEOPLE FOR FOR COMING OUT
FROM A THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO SUPPORT THIS
IMPORTANT BILL.
AND I ALSO WANT -- TO THING MY
MY FRIEND AND COLLEAGUE SENATOR
BILL FOR NOT ONLY THIS BILL BUT
BEING SUCH A GREAT CHAMPION FOR
FOR MENTAL ILLNESS AND THE
DISABLED.
THE DEVELOPING DISABLE
COMMUNITIES IS AN HONOR TO WORK
WITH YOU AND ARE IN OUR CAUCUS
AND IN YOUR LEADERSHIP IS GOING
TO HAVE -- VERY POSITIVE
RAMIFICATIONS FOR FOR MANY
DECADES TO COME AS ONE OF THANK
YOU FOR THAT -- INTO THIS NICE
LADY THE I GUESS WE'LL CALL YOU
THE CHIEF OF PEER SUPPORT --
COULD COULD CONGRATULATIONS TO
YOU FOR A FOR ALL OF YOUR
SUCCESS AND USE YOUR CERTAINLY
SURE SHOWN THAT AND I'M A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF MIAMI.
THAT -- YOU DID LET'S STICK BY
GET IN YOUR WAY AND
CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU -- FOR
ALL OF YOUR SUCCESS.
I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT I I I
THINK THIS BILL IS A IS A
TERRIFIC BILL -- YOU KNOW.
MENTAL ILLNESS -- IS IS
COMPLICATED AND WHAT GIVES A LOT
OF PEOPLE THAT HAVE MENTAL.
ILLNESS ISSUES IS BEING BLE --
TO COMMUNICATE WITH SOMEBODY
WHO'S BEEN THROUGH WHAT YOU'VE
BEEN THROUGH AND CAN TELL YOU
AND AND SHOW YOU THAT YOU'LL GET
THROUGH IT.
AND THAT SUPPORT BASE IS REALLY
IMPORTANT AND MORE IMPORTANTLY
IS THAT YOU'RE NOT ALONE.
AND SO I SEE THIS IS SAVING
LIVES TO OF A SUICIDE PREVENTION --
AND AND YOU KNOW WE WE HAVE WE
HAVE FORTY MILLION PEOPLE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH PSYCHIATRISTS
PSYCHOLOGISTS AND MFPS. TO TO
TAKE CARE OF EVERYBODY WE NEED
WONDERFUL PEOPLE LIKE OUR PEERS
TO BE THERE TO TO SUPPORT THE
COMMUNITY.
AND SO -- SENATOR -- BELL THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING FORWARD IF I
MAY I'D BE HONORED TO BE A CO
AUTHOR OF THE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THE BILL AS SAYING NONE I HEARD
EMOTION FROM CENTER STONE I
SENATOR ALSO.
I I JUST WANT TO ALSO THANK A
BIG SHOUT OUT TO LOS ANGELES FOR
COMING -- ALL THE WAY HERE TO
SACRAMENTO -- I'M A BIG BELIEVER
IN THIS MODEL THAT WE DO THE
MOST FOR MOST FOR THE MOST
PEOPLE WILL WE HELP THEM TO HELP
THEMSELVES.
AND I THINK THIS IS A PRIME
EXAMPLE OF THAT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEEN OTHER QUESTIONS I'VE AGAIN --
SIR BALLOT THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD I
KNOW WE TRIED LAST YEAR --
HOPEFULLY THIS YEAR WILL BE MORE
SUCCESSFUL -- BUT CLEARLY --
INSISTS THE SAID IT BEFORE WE'RE
READY FOR WOULD BE FORTY NINE
THAT IF THIS PASSES SO WE
DEFINITELY DON'T WANT OF WHEN
THE RACEFOR FIFTIETH -- SO WITH
THAT WOULD YOU LIKE THE CLUE
ACTUALLY THERE MOTION.
YES THAT'S RIGHT CENTER STONE AT
THE YOUR MOVEMENT OF SANDSTONE
DID MOVE SORRY -- SO WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE CENTER ABOUT
[inaudible]
JUST A THIS IS BEEN LIKE FOUR
YEARS WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON THAT
AS WE GOT REJECTED TWICE ALREADY --
IN TWENTY NINETEEN SO YOU'RE FOR
THIS WE HAVE TO MOVE FORWARD.
AND I LIKE TO THANK MY SPEAKERS
THESE IS THE NATIONAL.
ACTIONS THEY HAVE ON THE
SUBJECTS SO IT'S NOT JUST A THE
NATIONAL LEADER OF NATIONALLY --
NATIONALLY -- SO.
AND THEN OF COURSE WE HAVE TO
STEINBERG INSTITUTE AS WELL SO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ALL FOR
SUPPORTING THIS AN URGENT ABOUT.
I THANK YOU SO -- IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY -- CENTER STONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL TEN HI.
AYE STONE AYE STONE AYE DORADO I
DRAWS -- I'D GROVE.
GROUP I HER TADO. FOR TITLE I
LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE MITCHELL AYE MITCHELL
AYE MONNING.
MONNING I RUBIO.
RUBIO HI.
THE BILL HAS NINE VOTES SEND US
OF THAT BILL IS OUT THANK YOU.
NINE SORRY AGAIN THE RULES ARE
NO DEMONSTRATIONS MEANS KNOWS
SHOUTING OR CLAPPING IN THIS
OKAY WE GOT IT ALL RIGHT.
SORRY OKAY -- NAY NEXT IS A NOT
ITEM.
NUMBER ITEM NUMBER TWO SB TWELVE
CENTER B<c.cyan>.</c>
OF MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS -- I
WILL NOW PRESENT YES TWELVE SB
TWELVES A BILL TO ESTABLISH AN
INTEGRATED YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAM.
ADMINISTERED BY THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES.
AND OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION -- THE GOAL OF THIS
PROGRAM IS TO ASSIST SERIES OF
YOUTH DROP IN CENTERS.
OF IN MENTAL HEALTH CENTERS. TO
PROVIDE PREVENTION EARLY.
INTERVENTION SERVICES TO USE --
AGE.
TWELVE TO TWENTY FIVE NOW YOUNG
PEOPLE WITH EMERGING MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES HAVE DIFFICULT
FINDING TIMELY.
APPROPRIATE AND TREATMENT AND A
SERVICE SYSTEM THAT CAN RESPOND
TO THEIR NEEDS. TWO THIRDS OF
OUR ADOLESCENTS WITH MAJOR
DEPRESSIVE EPISODE.
ACTUALLY DID NOT GET TREATMENT
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THE LOW INCOME FAMILIES ARE
EVEN LESS LIKELY TO OBTAIN
TREATMENT.
BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF EARLY
IDENTIFICATION INTERVENTION
SERVICES YOUNG PEOPLE OFTEN DO
NOT REACH.
OUR HEALTH SOCIAL SERVICE OR
JUSTICE SYSTEMS UNTIL THEIR
MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEMS HAVE
BECOME MORE SEVERE.
AND OFTEN MORE DIFFICULT AND
COSTLY. TO TO TREAT.
AND THIS CAN LEAD TO DEVASTATING
OUTCOMES FOR YOUNG PEOPLE AS WE
HAVE SEEN WITH ON PRESIDENT --
INCREASE IN USE SUICIDE -- OVER
INCARCERATION EXCEPT AROUND.
WITH MORE MORE THAN -- 75% OF
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES DEVELOPING
BEFORE A PERSON TURNS
TWENTY FIVE EARLY DETECTION AND
TREATMENT GREATLY IMPROVES THE
HEALTH OF ADOLESCENTS.
AS THE TRANSITION -- TO
ADULTHOOD THIS BILL TAKES
PROACTIVE STEPS TO REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF UNDERSERVED ERROR ON
UNSERVED VIEW.
BY BOWSTRING THE MENTAL HEALTH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TREATMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE. FOR ADOLESCENTS
REGARDLESS OF INSURANCE
IMMIGRATION STATUS.
OTHER COUNTRIES HAVE MADE
DECISIONS OVER THE PAST THREE
YEARS TO PRIVATIZE SUPPORT. FOR
EARLY INTERVENTION FOR
ADOLESCENTS ONE INNOVATION
INNOVATIVE AND AN EXAMPLE OF A
NATIONAL.
COMMITMENT TO EARLY MENTAL
HEALTH SUPPORT.
IS THE HEAD SPACE PROGRAM.
THIS IS THE AUSTRALIAN MODEL FOR
TREATING YOU WITH EMERGING
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS.
AND WHICH HAS BECOME A
SIGNIFICANT COMPONENT.
IN THAT NATION'S MENTAL HEALTH
LANDSCAPE.
HAS BATES APPROACH APPROACHES
THE YOUTH WELLNESS AND A
COMPREHENSIVE AND USER FRIENDLY
WAY -- THE LED BY MEMBERS OF AN
ACTIVE USE LOCAL USED ADVISORY
GROUP -- TWO DESIGN SERVICES --
AND ENVIRONMENT THAT THEY WOULD
LIKE MOST LIKE TO SEE IN THEIR
COMMUNITY.
THIS YEAR A TWENTY FOUR MEMBER
YOUTH ADVISORY GROUP WAS CONVENE.
TO ENSURE THAT THE USE VOICE IS
AT THE FOREFRONT.
OF THE HEAD SPACE CENTER
EXPERIENCE.
ALSO CENTER CENTRAL TO HEAD
SPACE MODEL IS TO EMPHASIZE
SUPPORT IN CULTURAL COMPETENCE.
FOR FOR GROUPS LIKE THEY'LL BE
G. Q. USE HOMELESS SHOES AND
MINORITY -- YOU'VE COMMUNITIES
NOW AFTER AUSTRALIA IMPLEMENT
THEIR HEAD SPACE PROGRAM THEY
ACTUALLY SAW A 60% RATE OF
IMPROVEMENT.
AND YOU'VE THAT RECEIVE CARE --
THE SUCCESS IN THE AUSTRALIAN
MODEL IS INSPIRING AND WE CAN
EMULATED HERE IN CALIFORNIA --
SINCE THE INSTITUTION OF THIS
PROJECT -- IS THAT WE WE HAVE --
THERE THERE IS A HIGH INTEREST
IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR. TO TO
PARTICIPATE FOR PROJECTS
UNDERWAY IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY
STAFFORD -- SCHOOL PSYCHIATRY
HAS PARTNERED WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT
TELL PROVIDE SERVICES FOR THESE
PROGRAMS.
THE PROGRAM HAS ALSO GARNERED IN
KIND SUPPORT.
FROM OTHER PRIVATE ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING THE LUCILLE PACKARD'S
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL.
THROUGH COLLABORATIONS THE
CENTERS WILL BE ABLE TO LEVERAGE
GRANTS FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH SERVICES AND ELSEWHERE.
THE SERVICE THE CENTERS WILL BE
ABLE TO LEVERAGE FEDERAL
FINANCIAL PARTICIPATION. FOR
MEDI CAL FOR SERVICES RENDERED
OFF SITTING.
THE COST OF OPERATION.
THIS BILL -- PROVIDES IN IN A
WAY INNOVATIVE WAY TO INCREASE
ACCESS TO YOU MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES.
AND PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
COUNTIES. TO EFFECTIVELY UTILIZE
THEIR MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
FUNDS.
AND DRAW DOWN OTHER PORTS OF
FUNDING AND I'LL TURN OVER TO MY
WITNESSES NOW WE HAVE TONY IT
WENT FROM THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT COMMISSION.
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR.
AND EMILY ALISON PROSSER
DIRECTOR FOR SENATE.
SO TURN OVER TO MY WITNESSES
THANK YOU ARE YOU ARE.
THANK YOU WITNESSES SUPPORT.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON CENTER
PAN AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS EMILY ALISON AND I'M
THE POLICY DIRECTOR FOR SENECA
FAMILY OF AGENCIES.
SENECA IS A STATE WIDE PROVIDER
OF CHILDREN'S MENTAL HEALTH
CHILD WELFARE EDUCATION AND
JUVENILE JUSTICE SERVICES AND
WE'RE IN EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES SERVING OVER TEN
THOUSAND YOUTH AND FAMILIES EACH
YEAR.
I WANT TO FIRST EXPRESS OUR
GRATITUDE TO SENATOR BELL FOR
INTRODUCING THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION AND HIS LEADERSHIP
ON CHILDREN'S MENTAL HEALTH IN
GENERAL -- WE SEE THIS BILL IS
AN EXCELLENT EXAMPLE OF THE KIND
OF INNOVATIVE AND SOLUTION
FOCUSED INVESTMENTS THAT WE NEED
AND CALIFORNIA TO ADDRESS THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE OF YOUTH MENTAL
HEALTH.
SO I WANT TO UNDERSCORE AND
REITERATE SOME OF THE DATA THAT
THE SENATOR ALREADY SHARED WITH
YOU.
BUT CHILDHOOD AND ADOLESCENCE
HAS ALWAYS BEEN THE MOST
CRITICAL TIME FOR IDENTIFYING
AND ADDRESSING EMERGING MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS. 50% OF ALL CHRONIC
MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEMS BEGIN BY
AGE FOURTEEN AND 75% BY AGE.
TWENTY FIVE AT THE SAME TIME
THAT ALL OF THAT DATA IS TRUE
WE'RE SEEING THAT MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS FOR YOUTH ARE INCREASING
IN BOTH PREVALENCE AND ACUITY AT
ALARMING RATES.
THE RATE OF SELF REPORTED NO
HEALTH NEEDS AMONGST CALIFORNIA
ADOLESCENCE HAS INCREASED BY
OVER 60% IN THE LAST DECADE.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME THERE'S
BEEN A 2100% INCREASE IN SUICIDE
RATES AMONG GIRLS AGES.
TEN TO FOURTEEN DESPITE THE AND
AS THE SENATOR SAID YOU OF ALL
YOUTH DIAGNOSED WITH A MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITION NEARLY TWO
THIRDS ARE NOT RECEIVING
TREATMENT.
SO SOMETHING'S GOING ON AND WE
NEED MORE SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS
THIS.
SENATEBECAUSE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS LEGISLATION BECAUSE IT
ADOPTS AN APPROACH TO MENTAL
HEALTH THAT WE KNOW CAN WORK.
SO OUR AGENCY STARTED THIRTY
FIVE YEARS AGO MOSTLY AS A
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT PROVIDER
BUT HAVE INCREASINGLY DEVOTED
OURSELVES -- IN EVERY WAY TO
COMMUNITY BASED IN SCHOOL BASED
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
IN RECOGNITION OF THE
FUNDAMENTAL PREMISE THAT THIS
LEGISLATION IS BASED UPON WHICH
IS THAT MENTAL HEALTH CARE MUST
BE DELIVERED IN A LOCATION THAT
IS EASY FOR YOU TO ACCESS.
DELIVERED IN A MANNER THAT MAKE
MINIMIZES STICK MY AND IS YOUTH
DESIGNED AND YOUTH LED.
SO THIS ONE STOP SHOP DROP IN
CENTER IDEA THAT PUT FORWARD BY
THIS BILL WOULD ACCOMPLISH THOSE
OBJECTIVES.
FIRST IT ALLOWS CENTERS TO BE
LOCATED IN PLACES WHERE YOUNG
PEOPLE ALREADY ARE AND FEEL
COMFORTABLE AS OPPOSED TO ASKING
THEM TO GO ELSEWHERE SOMETIMES
DURING IN CONVENIENT HOURS TO
ACCESS SERVICES.
BY REMOVING THOSE TYPES OF
LOGISTICAL BARRIERS TO CARE WE
KNOW THAT THE RATES OF ACCESS
CAN GO UP SO STUDIES HAVE SHOWN
THAT YOUTH ARE MORE LIKELY TO
ACCESS MENTAL HEALTH CARE FOR
EXAMPLE IN SCHOOL.
THAN OTHER LOCATIONS.
SECOND THE DESIGN OF THESE
CENTERS WOULD BE LED BY TEENS
AND YOUNG ADULTS WHICH HELPS
ENSURE THAT THE SERVICES ARE
DELIVERED IN A MANNER THAT IS
APPROPRIATE AND NEEDED AND
ABSENT OF STIGMA.
SO IMAGINE EXPERIENCING ANXIETY
AND DEPRESSION AS A YOUNG PERSON
TODAY KNOWING THAT THERE'S A
PLACE YOU CAN GO ANY TIME WHERE
IT'S NOT OKAY BUT MAYBE EVEN
COOL TO ASK FOR HELP.
THAT WOULD BE FUNDAMENTALLY
DIFFERENT ON THE TYPE OF
APPROACH WE OFTEN SEE TODAY.
SO THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT YOUNG
PEOPLE KNOW WHAT IS NEEDED AND
WE SHOULD FOLLOW THEIR LEAD.
SENATE BECAUSE COMMITTED TO THE
VISION AND INTENTION OF SB
TWELVE AND FINDS THAT THE VALUE
OF MAKING SERVICES EASIER FOR
YOU TO ACCESS WOULD BE
IMMEASURABLE FOR OUR STATE -- WE
BELIEVE THAT INVESTING IN MODELS
LIKE THIS WOULD BE A HUGE STEP
FORWARD FOR CALIFORNIA AND
MAKING SURE THAT KIDS GET WHAT
THEY NEED -- WHERE THEY NEED AT
WHEN THEY NEED IT MOST WE ARE
DRIVE VOTE ON SB TOUGH?
THANK RICHARD MEMBERS TOBY EWING
WITH THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION.
I KNOW THE LAST FOUR FIVE YEARS
THAT I'VE BEEN WITH THE
COMMISSION WE SPENT A LOT OF
TIME TALKING TO YOUNG PEOPLE.
AND WE TALK WITH THEM ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES THAT THEY FACE IN
ACCESSING CARE AND SO YOU HEARD
SOME OF THE DATA AND I THINK THE
DATA ARE WELL KNOWN AT THIS
POINT THAT.
AT THIS STAGE IN AND AND AN
INDIVIDUAL'S LIFE IS WHEN WE
OFTEN SEE THE KINDS OF STRESS OR
TRAUMA OR THE CHALLENGES REALLY
COMING OUT IN HEALTH CHALLENGES.
WE ALSO SEE QUITE OFTEN A
FUNDAMENTAL MISMATCH.
BETWEEN THE NEEDS OF YOUNG
PEOPLE AND THE SERVICES THAT ARE
DESIGNED TO HELP THEM OR THAT
ARE IN PLACE TO HELP THEM BUT I
SHOULDN'T SAY DESIGNED TO HELP
THEM.
IN IN IN IN IN MANY WAYS I'D SAY
USE THIS ANALOGY OF HOW WE DID
BANKING IN THE NINETEEN SIXTIES
MONDAY THROUGH FRIDAY NINE TO
FIVE MAYBE.
NINETY THREE IF YOU HAD TO PASS
BOOK YOU CAN GET YOUR MONEY OUT
AND WE DIDN'T HAVE YOUR PASSPORT
YOUR OUT OF OUT OF LUCK.
TODAY WE'VE REALLY BEGUN TO
INVEST IN STRATEGIES THAT ARE
MUCH MUCH FRIENDLIER MUCH MORE
MOBILE MUCH MORE ALIGNED WITH
THE NEEDS OF INDIVIDUALS AS
CONSUMERS.
WHAT'S NICE ABOUT THE HEAD SPACE
MODEL THAT THE THAT LEGISLATION
IS SENATOR BALLOTS CAMPAIGNING
IS INTENDED TO BRING TO
CALIFORNIA.
IS IT REALLY STARTS ATTHIS
PROMISE OF LET'S TALK WITH YOUNG
PEOPLE ABOUT WHAT THEIR NEEDS
ARE LET'S DESIGN OUR SYSTEMS NOT
BASED ON ON REGULATORY RULES ARE
THE MONEY OR A AND AND ALONG
ESTABLISH SENSE OF HOW WE NEED
TO SERVE PEOPLE BUT LET'S.
ASKING PEOPLE IF WE COULD DESIGN
A STRATEGY THAT REALLY WAS
TAILORED TO WHAT YOUR NEEDS WERE
THAT INTEGRATED CARE AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PHYSICAL
HEALTH.
SOCIAL EDUCATION EMPLOYMENT AND
HOUSING SUPPORT WITH THAT LOOK
LIKE THE EVIDENCE AROUND THE
WORLD SUGGEST THIS WORKS SO FOR
THAT REASON THE COMMISSION IS
VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT.
OF ENGAGING THE STATE TO REALLY
REACH OUT AND AND ESTABLISH A
SERIES OF PROJECTS THAT WOULD
AGAIN THINK ABOUT HOW WE NEED TO
DO THIS AND HOW WE CAN DO THIS
IN A WAY THAT IS VERY GOOD
CENTRIC.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES A SUPPORT.
AND MY FRIEND.
BUT AFTERNOON DANIELLE MAILLET
CALIFORNIA LINES OF JOHN FAMILY
SERVICES AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
POURTANT AUDI THE THANK YOU.
LOWER CONSTANCE ROSEN JUSTIN
WITH WET WORTH OF LIVE FREE AND
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB TWELFTH
THANK YOU. THIRTEEN A HARRIS PO
CC ALAMEDA COUNTY.
WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
FOR SUPPORT S. B. TWELVE EACH
SEPARATE AS FIFTY CARE OKAY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AT THE END OF THE HOW
FAR DOWN THE MICROPHONE TO BEND
BUT RESIDENTS ALSO THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I ALWAYS AT ALL WITH CALIFORNIA
CHRONIC CARE COALITION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I COULD AFTERNOON YVONNE COUNTRY
WHAT THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NICOLE PASTORA ON BEHALF OF THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THREE TO ANDERSON
WITH ARKAN UCP CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION AND SUPPORT YOU.
MANY TIAS REPRESENTED SAN JOSE
EVERGREEN COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MARY HOW YET FROM CALIFORNIA
CIVIL LIBERTIES ADVOCACY WITH
SUPPORT THIS BILL WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS IS A STEP FORWARD TO
HELP OUR CHILDREN.
THANK YOU.
JIMMY FROM IN DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA WE'RE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
DELORES BLACK MEN I AM AT TEH
FAMILY ADVOCATE AS WELL AS A
MOTER TAPE PARENT AND NOT ME
ADVOCATE I AM ABSOLUTELY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
QUESTION LIVE FROM -- PIAS AND
VISION AND ENGAGING AND RECOVERY
SERVICES OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
ALAMEDA COUNTY AND I AM FULL
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
KATARA SLIMY TAMPLIN CHAIR OF
THE MAN ALL SERVICES ARE SIGNED
CAN ABILITY COMMISSION AND ON
BEHALF OF THE TRANSITION AGE
YOUTH PO CC COMMITTEE.
I AM IN SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU JOHNSON PEERS PRISON
VISION ENGAGING IN RECOVERY
SERVICE A TAE SUPPORTER AND I'M
IN SUPPORT.
MEYER CORONA AND I'M SUPPORT OF
SB TWELVE FROM ALAMEDA COUNTY
ADAM CHILD DEVELOPMENT MAJOR.
THANK YOU.
THERESA COMSTOCK EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR WITH CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY
NINE LOCAL MENTAL AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH COMMISSIONS WE'RE IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
JULIE INCLUDE OR WITH PIERCING
ENVISIONING AND ENGAGING
RECOVERY SERVICES ALAMEDA COUNTY
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU HI.
SEEN OTHER PEOPLE TO MAKE
FOUNDER ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE OF QUESTIONS FOR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY SAY NO QUESTIONS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ADS -- WANT THANK YOU
SIR BILL FOR BRING THIS FOR AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CHAIR AT A TOWN
HALL WITH STEINBERG INSTITUTE
WEIRD THIS WAS ONE OF THE MODELS
THAT WAS PRESENTED -- WE
ACTUALLY HAD A COMMON SKYPE OVER
FROM AUSTRALIA TALK ABOUT HEAD
SPACE AND SO IT'S REALLY
EXCITING TO SEE THAT WE'RE GONNA.
TRY TO DO THAT THIS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA BRING THIS INNOVATION
OVER HERE THROUGH THIS BILL SO
THANKS VERY MUCH DOING THAT --
IS THERE A MOTION WITH THE BILL
OKAY IT'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
MINING US IN A BILL WHICH LIKE
THE CLOTHES.
YES THERE'S STUDIES GOING ON
ABOUT EIGHT COUNTIES RIGHT NOW --
TO SEE HOW TO IMPLEMENT THIS AND
THE MENTAL HEALTH -- COMMISSION
IS WORKING WITH THEM -- WE'RE AT
THE BOTTOM WITH YOU WITH WE
THINK ABOUT 4% OF THE YOUNG
PEOPLE GET ADEQUATE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICE.
I'LL SAY THAT AGAIN 4%.
IN CALIFORNIA.
IT'S SO.
YOU KNOW WE'RE JUST AT THE
BOTTOM LET'S WORKERS WE HAVE TO
WORK OUR WAY OUT OF THAT HOLE.
SO THIS IS ONE WAY TO DO THAT
AND WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING LIKE
THIS.
TO ACCOMPLISH THAT.
IT'S SO BAD.
THAT WE HAVE TO DO SOME.
EXTREME I THINK [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HE CENTER BELL -- THIS BILL'S
BEEN MOVED BY -- CENTER MONEY
THE MOTIONS TO PAST
APPROPRIATIONS AGREE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
CAN I AND I STONE.
STONE AYE THE RAZA.
TORONTO I'D GROWTH.
GROW BY HER TADO.
RICARDO I'D LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING AYE MONNING
AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
RUBIO BY.
THAT BILLS OUT.
NINE ZERO ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT AND THEN FINALLY ITEM
NUMBER NINE SB.
FIVE EIGHTY TWO WELL.
THIS IS THE LAST ONE SORRY WE'RE
TAKINGSO LONG -- WILL NOW
PRESENT FIVE EIGHTY TWO THIS IS
SO -- ARE -- SCHOOL COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH CLEVERNESS BILL
AND WILL BEGIN BY -- THANKING
OUR COMMITTEE.
OF FOR THEIR EFFORTS AND ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
AND THIS BILL SB.
FIVE EIGHTY TWO IT IS A CRITICAL
COMPARTMENTALIZED IN EQUITY IN
TRIAGE GRANT FUNDS FOR YOUTH
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
RESTORING THE 40% CUT IN TRIAGE
GRANTS IN -- TWENTY EIGHTEEN IN
ADDITION THIS BILL REQUIRES A
HALF TO MENTAL HEALTH FUNDS THE
ALLOCATED TO YOUTH PROGRAMS
INCENTIVIZING COUNTY SCHOOL
INTEGRATE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
IN THE SCHOOLS. TO OUR
COMMISSION -- IN THE FIRST ROUND
OF TRIAGE GRANTS FIFTY FIFTY
APPLICATIONS WERE ACTUALLY
RECEIVED FOR THE US.
ONLY SIX WERE ABLE TO BE FUNDED
SPECIFIC TO YOUTH AND ONLY THREE
MET OR EXCEEDED THE THRESHOLD
FOR FUNDING.
THEREFORE THE GRANTS WITH USE
CENTRIC PROGRAMS RECEIVED JUST
OVER 15% OF THE GRANTS FROM
TRIAGE FUNDS.
SINCE THAT TIME A MORE USE
CENTRIC PARTNERSHIPS HAVE BEEN
PROPOSED.
BUT WE'RE NOT FUN TO DO THE CUTS
IN THE GRANT DOLLARS.
SPECIFICALLY THE COMMISSION
APPROVED TWELVE PARTNERSHIPS.
BY THE END OF THE LAST YEAR --
IN BUT WAS UNABLE TO FUND FOR
OTHERS THAT ARE PART.
WE EXPECT THE POOL OF APPLICANTS
TO SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE AND
GIVEN THE SIGNIFICANT NEED TO
ADD IN INTEREST TO INTEGRATE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IN THE
SCHOOLS -- WE EXPECT THAT PULLED
INCREASE FOR EXAMPLE ONE OF THE
CORE DEMANDS OF LOS ANGELES
TEACHERS WHO ARE ON STRIKE
EARLIER THIS YEAR WAS TO PROVIDE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ON SCHOOL
SITES.
ON WHAT THEY CALL COMMUNITY
BASED SCHOOLS.
IN ORDER TO ADEQUATELY SERVE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL AGE POPULATION
WE MUST ENSURE THAT HALF OF THE
FUNDS ARE TARGETED TO YOU.
WHERE THEY ARE IN IN SCHOOL?
THIS THIS BILL -- SUPPORT ENJOYS
THE SUPPORT OF THE MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS -- ALONG WITH SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS ALTERNATE OPTIONS
MY WITNESSES WE HAVE -- AN
ESTIMATE SIX OF EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND CHILDREN IN OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS THAT ARE -- SUFFERING
FROM -- MENTAL ILLNESS SO THIS
IS IMPORTANT AND I'LL TURN IT
OVER TO MY WITNESSES.
RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER
WELL A WITNESSES SUPPORT.
WHEN IS CHAIR MEMBERS AGAIN TOBY
EWING WITH A MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION -- I I
THINK IT WHEN IT COMES TO ADULT
MENTAL HEALTH PERHAPS
HOMELESSNESS IS THE PUBLIC FACE
OF THE CHALLENGES WE FACE IN
CALIFORNIA BUT WHEN IT COMES TO
CHILDREN AND YOUTH IT IS WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN OUR SCHOOLS --
WHETHER IT'S VIOLENCE OR ISSUES
AROUND SUICIDE OR BOWLING THAT
THE TRAUMA QUITE OFTEN GETS
EXPRESSED THROUGH WHAT'S
HAPPENING TO CHILDREN IN OUR
SCHOOL ENVIRONMENTS.
AS THE SENATOR SAID NGUYEN THAT
WHEN THE SPD TO PROGRAM WHICH
THE COMMISSION ADMINISTERS FIRST
WHEN OUT.
THE COMMISSION LEFT UP TO
COUNTIES THE DISCRETION TO
IDENTIFY WHAT WITH A LEADING
PRIORITIES AND BASED ON A
VARIETY OF FACTORS THE
OVERWHELMING INTEREST WAS IN
FUNDING PROGRAMS FOR ADULTS --
IN RESPONSE THE COMMISSION
SHIFTED AND REQUIRE THAT HALF OF
FUNDS OF THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
THE COMMISSION HE MADE AVAILABLE
FOR CHILDREN WITH A SET ASIDE OF
HALF OF THAT. FOR SCHOOL MENTAL
HEALTH AND WE WE'VE RECEIVED
TREMENDOUS RESPONSE FROM
COUNTIES TREMENDOUS RESPONSE
FROM SCHOOLS.
IN FACT MANY SCHOOLS CONTACTED
US TO ASK US IF WE WERE IN A
POSITION TO HELP THEM ADDRESS
OUR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS BUT
WE WEREN'T ABLE TO BECAUSE OF
THE STRUCTURE.
OF THE PROGRAM AS IT WAS AT THAT
TIME AS IT IS CURRENTLY.
WHAT WHAT SB FIVE EIGHTY TWO
REALLY INTENDS TO DO IS TO PUT
MORE RESOURCES AND RESPOND TO
THIS TREMENDOUS NEED THAT WE'RE
HEARING FROM SCHOOL DISTRICTS?
AND DO IT IN A WAY THAT'S MORE
MUCH MORE FLEXIBLE THAN THE WAY
SB TWO IS WRITTEN AT THE MOMENT.
SO THAT WE CAN BE MORE
RESPONSIVE TO WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN SCHOOLS.
AS THE AS THE SENATOR MENTIONED.
WE'RE HEARING ALMOST DAILY
STORIES FROM TEACHERS AND
PRINCIPALS AROUND THE NEED FOR
TRAINING.
AROUND THE NEED FOR BETTER
UNDERSTANDING HOW TO DO
REFERRALS -- WE'RE HEARING
STORIES OF CHILDREN AS YOUNG AS
KINDERGARTEN TALKING ABOUT
SUICIDE.
THESE ARE HEARTBREAKING STORIES
THAT -- COME TO THE COMMISSION
AGAIN ALMOST ON A DAILY BASIS
AND SO WE ARE VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT OF THIS OPPORTUNITY. TO
BEGIN TO INCENTIVIZE STRONGER
COOK SCHOOL COUNTY PARTNERSHIPS
AND PUT IN PLACE THE KINDS OF
RESOURCES THAT WE NEED TO EQUIP
OUR TEACHERS SEE QUIP OUR SCHOOL
PERSONNEL AND SUPPORTER COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS.
WHO ARE VERY INTERESTED IN
WORKING WITH THEIR SCHOOL
PARTNERS -- BUT FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS WE NEED TO DEVELOP SOME
OF SOME STRATEGY TO IMPROVE
STRATEGIES SOME INCENTIVES AND
SUPPORT IN ORDER TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS YVONNE CARRY
ON WITH ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS --
OUR MEMBERS AND EDUCATORS
GENERALLY SPEAKING ARE ARE
RESPONDING TO HISTORIC RATES OF
TRAUMA ANXIETY.
SUICIDE IDEATION -- DEPRESSION --
UNFORTUNATELY WITH MUCH OF THESE
TWO WOMEN AND MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS ARE BEING ON MATT DUE TO A
LACK OF RESOURCES THAT THAT
ALLEY ETS THAT THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION HAVE AVAILABLE TO THEM.
MEETING AT THAT THE MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS OF OUR OF OUR
STUDENTS IS GONNA REQUIRE BROAD
COORDINATED EFFORTS BUT WE
STRONGLY BELIEVE -- THAT SCHOOLS
ARE UNIQUELY POSITIONED TO HELP
MEET THAT THAT THE MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS OF STUDENTS.
BECAUSE OF THE AMOUNT OF TIME
THAT STUDENTS SPEND ON CAMPUS
BECAUSE OF RELATIONSHIPS THAT
OFTEN EXIST BETWEEN STUDENTS.
AND STAFF -- RELATIONSHIPS WITH
WITH GUARDIANS AND PERRANCE --
NOT TO MENTION THE ABILITY TO
PROVIDE SERVICES DISCREETLY --
AND AND FREE OF STIGMA.
TAXES SUPPORTS SB FIVE A TWO
BECAUSE IT WILL HELP STRENGTHEN
REGIONAL COORDINATION AND BECOME
PROVIDES ELEAZAR MUCH NEEDED
RESOURCES APPRECIATE SENATOR
BAIL ME TO CONTINUE CHAMPION ON
THE ON THIS TOPIC AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT BACK MIKE FROM ORACLE
HAVE BEEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THE MEASURE.
THANK YOU.
MORGAN CARLO AT THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. TO SAGACIOUS
SENECA FAMILIES AGENCIES
STATEWIDE PROVIDER CHILDREN
SERVICES IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
DANIELLE MAILLET CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES AND SUPPORT HE JERRY
FROM IN DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RESA COMSTOCK CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CALIFORNIA CIVIL LIBERTIES
ADVOCACY AT MEDI HYATT SPEAKING.
NINE REPRESENT A SCIENCE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
I SING OTHER PEOPLE'S MICROPHONE
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING ONE A QUESTION FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THERE'S A
MOTION BY SENATOR A STONE.
A CENTER RUBIO.
THANK YOU CHAIR.
WELL FIRST OF ALL I JUST WANNA
IN ON THE COMMANDED MISTER BILL
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD ON
THESE RICH YOU KNOW SOMETHING
THAT I'VE DEALT WITH IN
SEVENTEEN IN THE CLASSROOM FOR
SEVENTEEN YEARS.
NOT ONLY IS IT ABOUT THE
CHILDREN THAT NEED THE HELP THAT
THE SUPPORT SYSTEM FOR THE
TEACHERS BUT EVERY TIME A
TEACHER SPENDS TIME AWAY.
TRYING TO RESOLVE THE SET YOU
KNOW PROBLEMS IN THE CLASSROOM
OR OUTSIDE THE CLASSROOM IT
TAKES TIME AWAY FROM OTHER
STUDENTS FROM LEARNING AND AND
AND BEING FOCUS BUT I WANT TO
COMMEND YOU FOR THAT -- I KNOW
OUR TEACHERS ARE DROWNING I HEAR
IT EVERY SINGLE DAY AND SO WHEN
APPROPRIATE LIKE TO ADD AS A CO
AUTHOR AND WITH THAT I MOVE.
THE BILL.
I THINK IT'S RIGHT -- BUT WHEN
YOU WHEN YOU TAKE A OF FUTURE
AMENDMENT I THINK.
SO OKAY ANY OTHER -- A YES
CENTER MONEY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I ALSO
JUST WANT TO THANK SENATOR BILL
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THREE
BILLS YOU PRESENTED TODAY BUT IN
GENERAL ON MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. FOR YOUTH FOR ADULTS
FOR COMMUNITIES IT IS CRITICAL
TO THE PUBLIC HEALTH OF
CALIFORNIA WANT TO THANK YOU AND
WITNESSES WHO'VE SUPPORTED YOU
TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
A SIGNAL THE QUESTIONS --
ALRIGHT SO CENTER ABOUT I WANT
TO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR WORKING
WITH MY STAFF AND ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS.
THE I THINK IS FIRST OF ALL I
SHARE -- YOUR GOAL AND YOUR
DESIRE TO GET.
MORE OF THIS MONEY TO USE ORIENT
PROGRAMS AND THAT IT PRIORITIZE
THOSE AND SO CERTAINLY -- YOU
KNOW -- THE HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE
BILL I THINK THE ONE CONCERN I
HAVE AND I APPRECIATE OUR COULD
CONVERSATION IS IS THAT --
CERTAINLY WE HAVE MANY MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS YOU KNOW THIS
BETTER THAN ANYONE ELSE AND AND
STATE SENATE AND AND SO WHY
CERTAIN WHAT PRIORITIZE USE I I
ALSO DON'T HAVE A SITUATION
WHERE WE DOZEN A CERTAIN
PERCENTAGE AND I APPRECIATE YOU
IN YOUR TESTIMONY YOU SAID THAT.
YOU KNOW WE DO ANTICIPATE MORE
PEOPLE WILL APPLY AND I HOPE
THAT WILL BE THE CASE BECAUSE I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE AS YOU HAVE
OUTLINED THE BILL THAT.
AT LEAST HALF OF THE MONEY GOES
USE PROGRAMS BUT I'M ALSO
CONCERNED AS THIS IS TAXPAYER
MONEY THAT.
IF WE DON'T GET THOSE
APPLICATIONS AND WE DON'T HAVE
QUALITY APPLICANTS AND THE MONEY
SORT OF SITS THERE BECAUSE WE
HAVE TO DESIGNATE HALF BUT THERE
HAVE WE HAVE GOT THE
APPLICATIONS.
OF THE QUALITY THAT WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE YOU KNOW I KNOW WHAT
THE COMMISSION JUST HANDING OUT
MONEY TO SOMEONE WHO IS GOING TO
DO A GOOD JOB WITH THAT -- THAT
WE THEN THE CUMULATIVE BALANCE --
OVER TOO LONG OF A PERIOD OF
TIME I MEAN I UNDERSTAND GIVE ME
SOME TIME FOR MAYBE GETTING THE
WORD OUT DOING THE WORK TO TRY
TO GET MORE PEOPLE TO DEVELOP
THE KIND OF APPLICATIONS.
BUT I JUST DON'T HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE SOMEONE SAYS
WELL GEE NOT EVEN SPENDING THE
MONEY ADD THAT -- THAT WE'RE
PAYING TAXES FOR SO I APPRECIATE --
YOU'RE WORKING WITH I STAFF ON
THIS -- AND I KNOW THAT YOU WANT
YOU KNOW YOU YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
THE RIGHT THING AND I'M WITH YOU
THERE AND I AGREE WITH WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO SO I JUST
WANNA BE SURE WE DON'T CREATE A
SITUATION -- THOUGH THAT --
WHERE SOMEONE QUESTIONS -- THE
FACT THAT WELCOME QUESTIONS A
SITUATION THAT MIGHT OCCUR THAT
IF THE COMMISSION ISN'T GETTING
ABOUT THE MONEY THE TAXPAYER
MONEY IS IT GETTING ON TO THE
STREETS SO -- I'D CERTAINLY
LOOKING FOR TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE
GET MORE PEOPLE TO DO THIS
APPLICATIONS I'D LIKE TO SEE ALL
THAT MONEY GET OUT SO -- OKAY SO
WITH THAT -- A THINK IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY CENTER STONE I DON'T
SEE ANY OTHER QUICK COMMENTS --
CENTER BILL WHICH LIKE THE
CLOTHES.
I THINK -- THIS IS MORE OR LESS
AN ICE BREAKER BETWEEN THE
MENTAL HEALTH COMMUNITY AND THE
SCHOOL COMMUNITY BECAUSE IN THE
PAST THE BINS SILOS SEPARATELY.
AND AS WE SAW IN LOS ANGELES AND
OAKLAND AND YOU CAN GO ON AND ON
THE VARIOUS THE TEACHERS -- ARE
NOW SAYING HEY THIS WOULD BE A
GOOD IDEA TO HAVE.
SUPPORT YOU KNOW IN THE SCHOOLS
THE BENEFIT ALL THE KIDS IN THE
SCHOOL THEY HAVE A SUPPORT
SYSTEM FOR THE CHILDREN IN OUR
SCHOOLS SO.
SO WE'RE TRYING TO DO THIS IS AN
ICE BREAKER. TO HEALTH -- BOTH
THE SCHOOL SYSTEM.
ACHIEVE ACADEMIC PERFORMANCES
AND TRY TO HELP THE EARLY
DETECTION INTERVENTION.
OF CHILDREN ESPECIALLY.
AND I THINK WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
DOING IS ESPECIALLY THOSE IN --
AREAS THAT HAVE A LITTLE MORE
TRAUMA OTHER KINDS OF
DIFFICULTIES.
IN THOSE IN THOSE COMMUNITIES SO
THIS WOULD -- IS A STEP TOWARDS
WHAT AGO EQUALIZING -- SERVICES
IN SCHOOLS TO HAVE THIS KIND OF
SUPPORT SYSTEM IN THOSE TYPES OF
SCHOOLS TO BE ONE OF SEE IT THAT
WAY MINUTES.
TALK ABOUT EQUALIZING.
EDUCATION I THINK YOU HAVE TO
HAVE THIS KIND OF SUPPORT SYSTEM
SERGEANT ABOVE THANK YOU.
HI THANK YOU SO AT THIS.
THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
STONE -- THE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO EDUCATION
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CAN I AN ICE STONE.
STONE AYE DORADO HI DRAWS -- I'D
GROW.
GROW BY HER TOTO.
TOTO AYE LEYVA.
THEY'VE I'D MITCHELL BY MITCHELL
AYE MONNING NAY MONNING AYE
RUBIO.
AYE RUBIO AYE.
OR AT BILLS OUT NINE ZERO THANK
YOU THANKS FOR MUCH [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
NEXT UP ON FILE ORDER CENTER
HILL WELCOME I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN
VERY PATIENT.
AND DID YOU WANT TO TAKE THEM
YOU HAVE TO BILLS JOINT TAKE
THEM IN THE ORDERED AND THE FILE
OKAY SO WE ARE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO ITEM NUMBER.
THREE SB THIRTY EIGHT CENTER
HEALTH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES -- IN THEN I ALSO
HAVE MY JOINT AUTHOR OF SENATOR
GLAZER WHO WILL HAVE SOME
COMMENTS TO MAKE AS WELL AND
WE'RE HONORED TO HAVE HIM WITH
US TODAY -- SB.
THIRTY EIGHT YOUTH USAGE OF
FLAVORED TOBACCO PRODUCTS HAS
SURGED RECENTLY AS MANY OF US
KNOW I THINK COLLEAGUES THE
STATISTICS WILL SHOCK YOU AS
THEY DID TO ME.
BETWEEN TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION MORE YOUTH STARTED
FLIGHT USING FLAVORED ELECTRONIC
CIGARETTES.
THE STUNNING GROWTH AMOUNTED
278% INCREASE IN THE CIGARETTE
USED BY HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS.
AND A 48% INCREASE BY MIDDLE
SCHOOL STUDENTS.
THE YEAR OVER YEAR SPIKE ANY
CIGARETTE USE ALSO DROVE UP USE
OF TOBACCO PRODUCTS OVERALL TO
ALMOST FOUR POINT NINE MILLION
STUDENTS IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN A RACING WHAT
HAD BEEN DECADES OF DECLINES IN
USED TOBACCO USE YOU.
WE ARE A USE WE ARE AT THE
CENTER OF A YOUTH.
TOBACCO EPIDEMIC.
TAKING A PAGE FROM BIG TOBACCO'S
PLAYBOOK THE CIGARETTE COMPANIES
ARE DIRECTLY TARGETING YOUTH
WITH KID FRIENDLY FLAVORS LIKE
MANGO AND COTTON CANDY AND
CENTER GLAZER WILL HAVE OME
EXAMPLES CARTOON CHARACTERS ON
PACKAGING.
AND YOU'RE RESPONSIBLE
ADVERTISING CAMPAIGNS SOME VAGUE
COMPANIES EVEN SPONSOR SOCIAL
MEDIA INFLUENCERS UNDER TWENTY
ONE TO USE AND PROMOTE THEIR
PRODUCTS TO YOUTH MARKETS.
IT'S CRUCIAL THAT WE RECOGNIZE
THE PUBLIC HEALTH RISK FLAVORED
TOBACCO PRODUCTS POSE FAVORS
MATCH THE NATURALLY HARSH TASTE
OF TOBACCO MAKING THESE PRODUCTS
EASIER TO USE AND MORE APPEALING
TO YOU.
IN FACT LABOR TOBACCO USE IS
HIGHER WITH.
HIGHER WITH YOUTH THEN WITH
ADULTS.
AMONG TOBACCO USERS 80% OF KIDS
AGES TWELVE TO SEVENTEEN REPORT
CURRENT USE OF A FLAVORED
TOBACCO PRODUCTS COMPARED 2406%.
OF ADULTS TWENTY FIVE IN OVER
FLAVORED TOBACCO PRODUCTS LIKE
MENTHOL HAVE BEEN USED FOR
GENERATIONS TO TARGET
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES IN LGBT
Q. COMMUNITIES ADDING TO THE
HEALTH DISPARITIES IN
POPULATIONS ALREADY IMPACTED BY
SOCIAL INEQUITIES.
SB THIRTY EIGHT TAKE SWIFT
ACTION TO PROTECT YOUTH AND
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS FROM
FREIGHT FLAVORED TOBACCO
PRODUCTS THE BILL WOULD PROHIBIT
THE RETAIL SALE OF ALL FLAVORED
TOBACCO PRODUCTS ADULTS WOULD
STILL BE ABLE.
STILL BE ABLE TO PURCHASE
UNFLAVORED AND TOBACCO FLAVORED
PRODUCTS AT RETAIL PURCHASES ANY
FLAVORED ED ANY FLAVOR PRODUCTS
ONLINE OR PURCHASE ANY FLAVORED
PRODUCT THAT THEY WOULD LIKE
ONLINE.
WE HAVE SEEN THIS BEFORE WITH
BIG TOBACCO FALSE CLAIMS OF
SAFETY FLAVORS USED HOPE USERS
AND MARKETING OBVIOUSLY TARGETED
TO YOUTH THIS BILL MAKES
IMMEDIATE ACTION. SIX IMMEDIATE
ACTION TO PREVENT ANOTHER
GENERATION FROM TOBACCO AND
NICOTINE ADDICTION.
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF A WITNESSES
HERE AT SENATOR GLACIER.
JONATHAN THANK YOU.
SENATE GLACIER COUPLE BRIEF
COMMENTS FIRST TO THANK BY I
JOIN -- AUTHORSHIP WITH CENTER
HILL I THINK THE REASON THAT I
THINK BOTH OF US -- OUT WE'RE SO
CONCERNED ABOUT THE C. WE HEARD
SO MUCH FEEDBACK FROM OUR
DISTRICT -- I HAD -- A FEW WEEKS
AGO -- TWENTY MIDDLE SCHOOL KIDS
IN MY OFFICE AND I GENTLY SAID
TO THEM HEY -- HAVE YOU EVER
HEARD OF THIS THING CALLED
VAPING -- AND THEY ALL LOOKED AT
ME LIKE -- DAD KIND OF LIKE
THING.
AND HE SAID ABSOLUTELY THEY SAID --
EVERYBODY'S DOING IT HE SAYS IN
AND AND THEIR MIDDLE SCHOOL KIDS
THEY SAID THAT A BABE IN THE
HALLWAYS THE VAPOR ON THE
PLAYFIELD SAY EVEN VAPE IN THE
CLASSROOM.
AND IT WAS LIKE -- THIS IS A
THIS IS A SERIOUS SERIOUS
PROBLEM AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL TRIES TO ADDRESS -- AS
SENATOR HILL SAID.
YEAH THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF THE
MARKETING RIGHT WATERMELON
STRAWBERRY HE'D LIKE -- TO SMELL
THE VAPING PRODUCTS WE CAN SEND
OUT AROUND TO THE THE MEMBERS --
BUT THIS THIS FLAVOR -- GRANT
PERMISSIONS THE CHAIR SAID TO
HERE.
WITH THE PERMISSION OF THE CHAIR
AND LET ME JUST SAY IN
CONCLUSION THAT -- EASY
CIGARETTES THEY'RE INFECTING THE
HEALTH OF OUR CHILDREN -- THE
REJECTING THEM TO NICOTINE.
THEY'RE PROVIDING A GATEWAY TO
TOBACCO USE.
AND THEY'RE ENGAGING THEM IN
ILLEGAL CONDUCT AND WE HAVE TO
ACT URGENTLY ON THIS MATTER IT
IS REALLY OUT OF CONTROL THANK
YOU SENATOR HILL.
THANK YOU SENATOR GRAY SHIRT AND
WE DO HAVE A NUMBER OF WITNESSES
MISTER CHAIR AT THANK YOU FOR
THE INTELLIGENCE OKAY THANK YOU
SO WITNESSES SUPPORT I DON'T
KNOW HOW THE PEOPLE TESTIFY YOU
GOT SIX MINUTES TOGETHER.
ALL RIGHT SO [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THE TIME OUT OF YOUR BUSY
SCHEDULES TO LEARN MORE ABOUT
THE IMPORTANT ISSUE OF KIDS
VAPING.
MY NAME IS TAYLOR BARKER I AM
FIFTEEN YEARS OLD I TEN FOOT
HIGH SCHOOL SHASTA COUNTY.
TODAY I AM HERE WITH ATHLETES
AVE.
SHARE WITH YOU WHAT IS HAPPENING
IN YOUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS.
THE BEING HAS BECOME EXTREMELY
POPULAR.
ROUGHLY SIX OUT OF EVERY TEN
SINCE I TALKED TO HAVE A BEFORE
OR CURRENTLY VAPING NOW.
SOME KIDS BRING THE BABY TO
SCHOOL AND EVEN THE BATHROOMS
WHICH HAS GOTTEN THE NICKNAME
THE JEWEL ROOM.
I HAVE A FRIEND WITH ASTHMA WHO
CAN'T USE THE BATHROOMS AT
SCHOOL BECAUSE THE VAPING CAUSES
HER TO HAVE A HARD TIME
BREATHING.
IN A SHOCKING AS IT IS SOME KIDS
EVEN DATE DURING CLASS.
IT IS SO COMMON TODAY.
NOW THAT IS A SOCIAL NORM AND IF
YOU DON'T PARTICIPATE IN IT YOUR
MADE FUN OF KEEP IN MIND THIS
ISN'T JUST BURN OUTS AND PARTY
YEARS.
IT'S ALSO THE STAR FOOTBALL
PLAYERS NAY P. STUDENTS.
THE PROBABILITY THAT YOUR KIDS
AND GRANDKIDS VAPE IS VERY
HIGHLY.
WHAT MAKES MATTERS WORSE AS MANY
STUDENTS ARE BECOMING ADDICTED
TO NICOTINE AND UNDERSTAND THE
DANGERS?
I'VE SEEN KIDS NOT EAT THEIR
LUNCH AND USE THE LUNCH MONEY
THAT THEIR PARENTS GAVE THEM TO
BUY VAPE JUICE.
IT'S GET TOO CAUGHT UP IN THE
FRUITY TWENTY FLAVORS TO REALIZE
THE DANGERS CHEMICALS THEY'RE
PUTTING IN THEIR BODIES.
ONLINE MARKETING HAS MADE IT
EASIER THAN EVER FOR STUDENTS TO
OBTAIN ACCESS THESE NICOTINE
DEVICES WITHOUT THEIR PARENTS
EVER KNOWING.
I HAVE A CLEAN CUT SIXTEEN YEAR
OLD FRIEND WHO ORDERS BABY
PRODUCTS IN BULK ONLINE
THEMSELVES INDUSTRIES THESE
PRODUCTS TO OTHER STUDENTS.
WITHOUT YOUR HELP I ONLY SEE
MATTERS GETTING WORSE.
I AM GENUINELY SCARED AND
CONCERN FOR THE YOUTH AND
GENERATIONS TO COME.
PAPERS BUT THE DETECTIVE
DANGEROUS AND FIGURATIVELY A
POISON.
WITH THAT BEING SAID I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT YOU
CONSIDER WHAT CAN BE DONE TO
PROTECT YOUR STUDENTS FROM THE
GROWING THREAT OF VAPING.
AND THE DANGEROUS HEALTH EFFECTS
GREAT AS A RESULT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR INDUSTRY
ENGLISH COMMITTEE MEMBERS I
THINK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB.
THIRTY EIGHT MY NAME IS DOCTOR
BONNIE HUBBARD FELL SURE I'M A
PROFESSOR OF PEDIATRICS AND
DIRECTOR OF RESEARCH IN THE
DIVISION OF ADOLESCENT MEDICINE.
AT STANFORD UNIVERSITY I'M A
DEVELOPMENTAL PSYCHOLOGIST WITH
ADDITIONAL TRAINING IN
ADOLESCENT AND YOUNG ADULT
HEALTH I HAVE OVER TWENTY FIVE
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE RESEARCHING
WHY YOUTH USED TOBACCO WITH E.
CIGARETTES AT THE CORE OF MY
CURRENT WORK.
I'M ALSO THE FOUNDER AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
STANFORD TOBACCO PREVENTION TOOL
KIT.
I'M HERE TO EXPRESS THREE MAIN
CONCERNS ABOUT FLAVORED TOBACCO
PRODUCTS.
FIRST AS MENTIONED THERE ARE
OVER FIFTEEN THOUSAND FLAVORS
AVAILABLE FOR E. CIGARETTES AND
NUMEROUS FLAVORS IN OTHER
TOBACCO PRODUCTS WHICH IS CHOOSE
SMOKELESS HOOKAH CIGARS.
THESE FLAVORS ATTRACT YOUNG AND
NEW USERS SUCH AS THE RUIT AND
CANDY FLAVORS BUT ALSO MEANT AND
MENTHOL THAT YOU ARE USING A
RECORD.
NUMBERS IN FACT MANGLE IMAGE ARE
THE MOST POPULAR USE FLAVORS
ANGELS. 80% OF ADOLESCENT SITE
FLAVORS IS A REASON FOR USE
FLAVORS MASK THE HEART HARSH
TASTE OF TOBACCO RESULTING IN A
MORE PLEASANT SMELL AS YOU'RE
SEEING.
AND SMELLING NOW THAN THAT WOULD
BE FOUND IT WITH TOBACCO Là.
MùT TWO THREE PORT THAT THEY
WOULD QUIT USING TOBACCO IT
FLAVORS WERE NOT AVAILABLE.
SECOND FLAVORS MASS THE RISKS
THAT ARE INHERENT IN TOBACCO
INCLUDING THE FACT THAT MANY E.
CIGARETTES AND IN PARTICULAR THE
NEWER POD BASED PRODUCTS LIKE
JEWELS HAVE AS MUCH NICOTINE AND
HIGHLY NICK CONCENTRATED
NICOTINE.
AS THAT WOULD BE FOUND IN ONE TO
TWO PACKS OF CIGARETTES KIDS ARE
ADDICTED TO THESE PRODUCTS AND
THERE FOUR TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
GO ON TO USE CIGARETTES IF THEY
START WITH ELECTRONIC CIGARETTES.
LESLIE SENATORS WHO WILL LIKELY
HERE TODAY ARGUMENTS THAT ADULTS
NEED FLAVORS TO SUCCESSFULLY
QUIT SMOKING CONVENTIONAL
CIGARETTES HOWEVER THAT IT'S
SIMPLY NOT BORNE OUT BY RESEARCH
WELL TOLD ME LIKE FLAVORS ANY
CIGARETTES THEY ARE MORE LIKELY
TO QUIT SMOKING CIGARETTES
WITHOUT THEM.
THE EVIDENCE IS CLEAR THE
FLAVORS ATTRACT KIDS
EXTRAORDINARILY HIGH LEVELS OF
NICOTINE GET AND KEEP KIDS
ADDICTED AND ADULTS DON'T NEED
THESE FLAVORS TO QUIT SMOKING I
THEREFORE URGE YOU TO PASS SB
THIRTY EIGHT TO PROTECT.
THE HEALTH OF OUR CHILDREN.
AFTERNOON I'M DOCTOR PHILIP
GARDNER I WOULD IN THE CULTURE
OF THE AFRICAN AMERICAN TOBACCO
CONTROL LEADERSHIP COUNCIL.
I ALSO WORK AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT TO BACK RELATED
DISEASE RESEARCH PROGRAM WHICH
I'VE DONE FOR THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS.
LET ME MAKE ONE THING CLEAR IN
THE FIRST PLACE THE THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING THAT THE SENATE
CAN DO THAT THE LEGISLATURE CAN
DO. TO PROTECT OUR HEALTH IS TO
GET RID OF FLAVORS AND TOBACCO.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS YOU PUT
FLAVORS IN THE BACK -- IT HELPS
TO POISON TO GO DOWN EASIER
THERE'S NO MISTAKE ABOUT THAT
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE JEWEL
EXPLOSION THAT EVERYBODY'S
TALKING ABOUT IN THE FIFTEEN
THOUSAND FLAVORS.
IT'S A FLAVOR EXPLOSION WE'VE
BEEN AWARE OF THIS EXPLOSION FOR
SOME TIME UNFORTUNATELY IT'S
BEEN CONCENTRATED AROUND MENTAL
WE KNOW THAT MENTAL HAS AN
ANESTHETIC EFFECT ALLOWS DEEPER
INHALATION.
THE DEEPER YOU INHALE THE MORE
TOXINS AND NICOTINE YOU TAKE IN
THE MORE NEGATIVE AND TALKS AND
YOU TAKE IN THE GREATER THE
ADDICTION THE GREATER THE
ADDICTION IT'S HARDER TO QUIT
WE'VE KNOWN THIS FOR YEARS.
THIS IS PARTICULARLY TRUE OF THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY --
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A PREDATORY
SITUATION WHEN THE TOBACCO
INDUSTRY WHERE THEY'VE MARKETED
THESE PRODUCTS THERE'S GREATER
ADVERTISEMENTS GREATER
PROMOTIONS AND THE THING THAT IS
MOST DISGUSTING IS THAT.
MENTHOL CIGARETTES ARE CHEAPER
IN THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY COMPARED TO OTHER
COMMUNITIES.
LET'S BE CLEAR THAT AFRICAN
pFROM TOBACCO RELATED DISEASE
THAT INCLUDES HEART ATTACKS
STROKES AND LUNG CANCER.
BUT IT'S NOT JUST BLACK FOLKS IN
THIS NOT JUST KIDS WERE TALKING
ABOUT ADULTS HERE THE MAJORITY
OF WOMEN WHO SMOKE SMOKE MENTHOL
CIGARETTES.
THE MAJORITY OF THE LGBT
COMMUNITY WE HAVE THE TIME.
LET ME LET ME STOP I WANT TO
TAKE MY FRIENDS FOR A A TIME TO
SPEAK.
I WANT TO CALIFORNIA LEGISLATOR
TO TAKE THE LEAD ON THIS I THINK
IT'S GOOD NUMBER OF CITIES OF
ALREADY DONE THIS OF THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN TOBACCO CONTROL
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL HAS WORKED
WITH THE CITY'S WE'D LIKE TO
WORK WITH THE STATE ON THIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
WITNESSES A SUPPORT -- FEW NAME
AND ORGANIZATION AND DECISION
BACK MICROPHONE [inaudible]
KEEP.
KATHY HALL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PTA IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
YOU [inaudible]
AFTERNOON.
ZACHARY CORBEAU WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION WE
ARE ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
OKAY.
TIM GIVES A WITH THE AMERICAN
CANCER SOCIETY CANCER ACTION
NETWORK PROUD CO SPONSOR OF THIS
CRITICAL LIFESAVING LEGISLATION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU. TWENTY FOUR EIGHT AS
AMERICAN UNG ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA ALSO PROUD CO SPONSOR
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
JAMIE MORGAN WITH THE AMERICAN
HEART ASSOCIATION ALSO PROUD
BECAUSE SPONSORED THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MORNING CARVALLO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
TESTING RANDOMLY HAVE A HOT
BOXES CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
BETSEY ARMSTRONG ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA'S LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS FRANK THE CHIANG
I'M A MEMBER OF AYE WHY T. C.
INTERNATIONAL USED TOBACCO
CONTROL.
ORGANIZATION AND I'M ALSO I ALSO
ATTEND THE SOUTH HIGH SCHOOL IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY NAIME STRONG
SUPPORTER SB.
THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SERGEANT CHOI.
I'M LED INTERNATIONAL USE
TOBACCO CONTROL AND I ATTEND
SEMINAR HIGH SCHOOL IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS AIR STYLES ING
AND I AM A MEMBER OF THE
INTERNATIONAL YOUTH SOCCER
CONTROL.
AND I ALSO ATTEND SAN MARINO
HIGH SCHOOL OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND I ALSO SUPPORT SB.
THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS KATHY SON AND
THEN I AM A MEMBER OF THE
INTERNATIONAL USE TOBACCO
CONTROLLED MAGICIAN AS A TEN
TEMPLE CITY HIGH SCHOOL IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY.
I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB THIRTY
EIGHT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS TONY LOU AND I AM A
MEMBER OF INTERNATIONAL YOU
TOBACCO CONTROL AND I TEND
HUNTING TO MIDDLE SCHOOL AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS LISA LU AND I'M WITH
INTERNATIONAL USED TOBACCO
CONTROL I ATTEND SAN MARINO HIGH
SCHOOL IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB.
THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
ROBERT HARRIS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF ADDICTION
MEDICINE AND BRIE THE LA IN
TOTAL SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
THANK YOU.
MARCUS AUTHOR JOTA CALIFORNIA
PENTACLE NETWORK IN SUPPORT YOU.
THE SET SHORT ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA ONCOLOGY IN THE
MEDICAL ONCOLOGY ASSOCIATION OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ONE REPRESENTING
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
CALIFORNIA DIVISION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CUT THE MUSTARD PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTITUTE IN STRONG SUPPORT YOU.
TWO MEN REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS AND THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF CARDIOLOGY
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HI SONNY KENNEDY'S MOTHER OF A
TWELVE YEAR OLD SON WHO ATHLETE
WAS VAPING.
DANCE STUDIO OWNER OF KIDS THAT
ARE BEING AND FOUNDER OF
ATHLETES DON'T BATES IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU --
MICHAEL RIGHT AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA
CLARA COUNTY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
DAN BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIANS PART THANK YOU.
I'M CARE MONTGOMERY AND I'M A
STUDENT AT DURING HIGH SCHOOL
AND I AM IN FULL SUPPORT OF SB.
THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS NICK RODRIGUEZ AND
I ATTEND INSPIRES SCHOOL OF ARTS
AND SCIENCES AND I'M IN AND I AM
IN FULL SUPPORT OF SB.
THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MD PATEL I ATTENTION
COULD JUNIOR HIGH SCHOOL AND I'M
IN FULL SUPPORT OF SB.
THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS TO BE THE PATEL I
TEND TO GO HIGH SCHOOL AND I'M
IN FULL SUPPORT OF THIS BE THE
THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ABIGAIL CLOVER I GO
TO WEST VALLEY HIGH SCHOOL AND I
AM IN FULL SUPPORT OF SB.
THE THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS AUSTIN BURKE I GO
TO WEST COTTONWOOD SCHOOL AND I
AM IN FULL SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY
EIGHT THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS ABBY BURLESON I
ATTEND BRENDA'S MILL SCHOOL AND
I CAME IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY
EIGHT THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS DENNIS IN YOUR
HEART MEANT AND I GO TO CALVARY
CHRISTIAN ACADEMY AND I'M IN
FULL SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY EIGHT
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS KELSEY DENNY I
ATTEND WEST COTTON WOOD JUNIOR
HIGH SCHOOL AND I AM A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF SB.
THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS BAD AGHAST AT NEAR
I ATTEND RED BLUFF HIGH SCHOOL
AND I SUPPORT SB.
THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
I'M GONNA SEE A BATTLE I GO TO
TURN AWAY SCHOOL AND I'M A
SUPPORTER OF SB THIRTY EIGHT
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS ANGELINA
WOODWARD AND I TEND TO
UNIVERSITY PREPARATORY SCHOOL
AND I AM IN FULL SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS FINALLY MEN I GO
TO IT MORE UNION ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL AND I'M IN FULL SUPPORT
OF SB THIRTY THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS SEAN KINGSTON I GO
TO A SICKLY MIDDLE SCHOOL I AM.
IN FULL SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S COSTA MORRISON I
ATTEND CARDINAL CREEK CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I'M FULL SUPPORT OF
SB THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
I MERELY BURKE I GO TO WEST
COTTON WOOD JUNIOR HIGH AND I'M
IN FULL SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY
EIGHT THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS CAMERON FULLY
ANKLE TO CUT MY CREATURES COOL
AND I AM IN FULL SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LEAH PACE I GO TO
UNIVERSITY PREPARATORY SCHOOL I
AM IN FULL SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS CLAY BAILEY I GO
TO THE CHECK A MIDDLE SCHOOL AND
I'M IN FULL SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LAURIE K. HELL I'M
FROM REDDING CALIFORNIA I'M A
PARENT OF TWO COLLEGE STUDENTS
AND I'M FULL SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS TERRA BOBBY I SHOULD
I GO UNIVERSITY PREPARATORY
SCHOOL AND I AM IN FULL SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS WRITER MAN I GO TO
SIX IN THIS WONDERFUL SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S LAMMY LOW I GO TO
US AS MIDDLE SCHOOL AND I'M IN
FULL SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ALEC YOU LOW AND I
GO TO SAINT JOE'S MIDDLE SCHOOL
AND I'M IN FULL SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LYNN INDIANA
CINNAMON OR GO TO SUPPORT MY
SCHOOL AND FALLS.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MARIE MOON I'M A
REGISTERED NURSE AND SHASTA
COUNTY AND I'M IN FULL SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS HALEY AUSTIN AND I
GO TO SCHOOL A MIDDLE SCHOOL AND
I AM IN FULL SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS KELLY HARPER I GO TO
ANDERSON HIGH SCHOOL AND I MEN'S
FULL SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ABIGAIL CIRCLE I GO
TO RABBI OF HIGH SCHOOL AND I'M
IN FULL SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS RAIL IN CERTAIN I GO
TO WEST VALLEY HIGH SCHOOL AND
I'M IN FULL SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS KENDALL TOMLINSON
I GO TO UNIVERSITY PREPARATORY
SCHOOL AND I'M IN FULL SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS DAVE TOMPKINS.
AND I A TEN FOOT HIGH SCHOOL AND
I AM IN FULL SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS KAREN CLEMENT AND
I TEN REBEL FIGHTERS GOING I AM
IN FULL SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LOTUS NORRIS A AT
TEN ANDERSON HIGH SCHOOL AND I
AM FULL SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS PIPER HOWARD I
ATTEND NORTH CALGARY SCHOOL AND
I'M IN FULL SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS SELENA AND I GO TO
BUCK I SCHOOL OF THE ARTS AND I
AM IN FULL SUPPORT YOU.
HI MY NAME'S ALEXIS JAMES AGO
SHOT SIZE GOV FULL SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
I WILL BE AN ARM AND I GOT A
SHASTA HAS GONE I FULLY SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS RANDY ELO I GOT A
SHASTA HIGH SCHOOL AND I SUPPORT
SB.
THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LOIS ONCE AND I GO
TO SHASTA HIGH SCHOOL AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB THIRTY EIGHT
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS BRIAN HARDEN I GO TO
WATER FOR HIGH SCHOOL I'M IN
FULL SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CHRISTINE CHESSON I'M
WITH PAVE PARENTS AGAINST VAPING
E. CIGARETTES MORE IMPORTANTLY
I'M THE SAN FRANCISCO PARENT OF
A TEEN ADDICTED TO JEWEL AND I'M
IN FULL SUPPOT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS SAM APPLE RYAN
INSTRUCTOR OF COMPUTER
INFORMATION SYSTEMS THAT SENDS A
CITY COLLEGE AND I AM IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
I AM WORKING WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANY TAKEN WITH CAMPAIGN FOR
TOBACCO FREE KIDS STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU [inaudible]
RIGHT.
THANK YOU SEEN OLD PEOPLE OF
MICROPHONE -- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION AND ACTUALLY BEGIN
PLEASE ALLOW THEM TO COME UP TO
THE TABLE
.
OKAY WELCOME SO -- AGAIN SIX
MINUTES TOTAL ALL RIGHT SIR I
GOT THAT RIGHT.
AND TELL ME PEOPLE SPEAKING YES
THREE THREE ALL RIGHT TO FIGURE
OUT THE TIME BETWEEN ALL OF THE
OKAY.
RIGHT WELL WELCOME [inaudible]
MILLION.
RESET [inaudible]
DELETE [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
THAT.
AT THE HEAD AGAIN.
WHAT'S RED WITH A AGO CAN YOU
HEAR ME OK.
UGH THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE -- MY
NAME IS CHASE RIGBY I GREW UP IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA BUT RECENTLY
MORE RECENTLY RELOCATED TO THE
SACRAMENTO AREA.
FOR CAREER PURPOSES.
I WORK FOR A MAJOR CHOCOLATE
COMPANY CONDUCTING RETAIL SALES.
I AM A REGISTERED VOTER AND I
BELIEVE IN THE POWER OF OUR
GOVERNMENT AND WHAT YOU GUYS ARE --
TO ME TODAY.
THIS IS PARTIALLY WHY I FELT MY
PRESENCE HERE TODAY WAS
NECESSARY -- AT THE AGE OF
FIFTEEN I WAS INTRODUCED TO
TOBACCO THROUGH A FRIEND WHICH
DEVELOPED INTO A VERY DEEP
PROTECTION.
OF THIS WAS A HUGE SURPRISE TO
MY FAMILY AS I COME FROM A LINE
OF EDUCATORS WHO HAVE NEVER
SMOKED CIGARETTES.
MY ADDICTION LASTED A TOTAL OF
NINE YEARS AS I WAS UNABLE TO
QUIT CIGARETTES REGARDLESS OF MY
MANY ATTEMPTS -- WHEN JULES
INTRODUCED AS A NEW PRODUCT I
WAS IMMEDIATELY ABLE TO KICK THE
DISGUSTING HABIT?
I'VE NOT HAD A SINGLE CIGARETTES
SINCE THE INCEPTION OF TOOL --
WHEN I WAS A SMOKER I WAS NOT
CAPABLE BEING HEALTHY NOR WAS I
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN PHYSICAL
ACTIVITY -- TIME I LOST MY SENSE
OF SMELL -- MY ABILITY TO TASTE
FOODS DIMINISHED AND TO MY
AMAZEMENT I HAVE FULLY RECOVERED
FROM THE NEGATIVE EFFECTS HE
CAUSED BY CIGARETTES IN MY
OPINION -- WHEN OF?
I BEGIN USING THIS PRODUCT I WAS
VERY INTERESTED IN THE NON
TOBACCO FLAVORS AS I WAS TRULY
TRYING TO DISTANCE MYSELF FROM
BEING ASSOCIATED WITH TOBACCO.
THESE FLAVORED PRODUCTS WERE
INSTRUMENTAL IN MY ABILITY TO
STOP SMOKING CIGARETTES I CAN
ONLY HOPE THAT FLAVORS CONTINUE
TO BE AVAILABLE FOR ADULT
SMOKERS SUCH AS MYSELF WHO DOES
WHO HAVE DECIDED TO TAKE THE
NEXT STEP INCLUDING TOBACCO -- I
WOULD LIKE IT TO BE KNOWN HOW
IMPORTANT TOOL HAS BEEN IN THE
HORRIBLE PROCESS.
OF QUITTING CIGARETTES I WAS A
TEENAGER WHEN I BEGAN SMOKING
AND I CAN COME CONFIDENTLY TELL
YOU THAT IT WAS THE WORST
MISTAKE OF MY LIFE -- I CAN ALSO
CONFIRM WE SHARE WITH YOU THAT
MY WIFE WHOM I'VE BEEN WITH
SINCE THE AGE OF SIX SEVENTEEN
WOULD NOT ACCEPT MY MARRIAGE
PROPOSAL AND TELLER WAS
CIGARETTE FREE.
I WAS ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH THIS
SOLELY BECAUSE OF MY TRANSITION
TO JEWEL.
THIS PRODUCT HAS BEEN THE ONLY
SOLUTION AND MY MISSION TO STOP
SMOKING.
THESE FLAVORS WERE AND MAJOR
PART OF MY ABILITY TO
PERMANENTLY QUIT SMOKING.
AND ULTIMATELY I IMPLORED THE
COMMITTEE TO VOTE NO ON
PROPOSITION SB THIRTY EIGHT AND
FIND AN ALTERNATIVE WAY TO
RESTRICT USAGE BY UNDERAGE
PEOPLE WHILE ALLOWING ADULT
SMOKERS ACCESS TO A PRODUCT THAT
CAN.
AND WILL ACTUALLY HELP THEM QUIT
CIGARETTES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME.
THANK YOU MEMBERS COMMITTEE MY
NAME'S KEN ELLIE AND I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE VAPOR TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION AND ITS SIX HUNDRED
MEMBERS OF MANUFACTURERS
IMPORTERS WHOLESALERS AND
REAILERS.
I WANT TO MAKE A COUPLE POINTS
ABOUT THIS THIS CATEGORY
PRODUCTS AND FOR SMALL THAT THEY
ARE NOT IN FACT TOBACCO IN THE
ONLY COMMON DENOMINATOR BETWEEN
THESE PRODUCTS AND TOBACCO IS
NICOTINE.
THE ROYAL COLLEGE OF PHYSICIANS
IS DETERMINED THAT THAT THESE
PRODUCTS ARE 95% SAFER THAN
TRADITIONAL CIGARETTES IN PUBLIC
HEALTH ENGLAND HAS DETERMINED
THAT THEY'RE USEFUL TOOL.
IN HELPING TO PICK PEOPLE QUIT
TO WRESTLE CIGARETTES IN FACT
AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY SAID
THAT USING THE CURRENT
GENERATION OF THE CIGARETTES IS
LESS HARMFUL THAN -- SMOKING
CIGARETTES.
THE FLAVORS BAN WOULD S.
ESSENTIALLY DECIMATE THIS THIS
CATEGORY AND I WOULD SAY THAT --
THAT IN A JANUARY TWENTY
EIGHTEEN STUDY THE TOBACCO
CONTROL -- FOUND THAT BETWEEN
ONE POINT SIX MILLION AND SIX
POINT SIX MILLION AMERICANS WILL
DIE AS A RESULT OF CIGARETTE
SMOKING AND THESE ARE --
PRODUCTS THAT CAN HELP PEOPLE
PREVENT THOSE DEBTS.
AB POINT ON APRIL TWENTY
EIGHTEEN STUDY BY J. C. CHEN
THAT FOUND THAT.
SMOKERS WHO USE VAPOR PRODUCTS
WERE MORE LIKELY TO ROUTE TO
REDUCE OR SMOKING OR QUIT THEIR
SMOKING WITH ONE OR MORE NON
TOBACCO OR NON MENTHOL FLAVORED
PRODUCTS.
THE FINAL POINT THAT I WANT TO
MAKE IS THAT THERE IS NO
CHARACTERIZING FLAVOR TO THESE
PRODUCTS THEY TASTE LIKE NOTHING
SO EVEN TOBACCO IS A FLAVOR
ADDED TO THESE PRODUCTS.
SO.
ADDING FLAVORS IS NOT MASKING A
TOBACCO FLAVORED ADDING FLAVOR
TO THE PRODUCT.
WE WOULD URGE YOU TO OPPOSE THIS
BILL AND WE'D LOVE TO WORK WITH
YOU ON A MEANINGFUL AND PROVEN --
WAYS TO CURB THE YOUTH USAGE
PROGRAM WHAT FOOTWEAR CONCERNED
ABOUT AS WELL THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JAMES TRACK
HERE ON BEHALF OF JEWEL LABS --
I'M PLEASED TO INTRODUCE
ACTUALLY GOLD WHO IS -- JEWELS
CHIEF ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICER
WHO'S HERE TO PROVIDE A SHORT
STATEMENT BUT ALSO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS RELATED TO THE PRODUCT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. TWO LABS
AGREES WITH THE INTENTION OF
SENATE BILL THIRTY EIGHT TO
RESTRICT USE ACCESS FROM VAPOR
PRODUCTS.
HOWEVER WE BELIEVE THAT THE
PROPOSED BAN ON ALL FLAVORED
VAPOR PRODUCTS AT RETAIL WILL
NOT EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE.
WELL HARMING THE OVER THREE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS WHO SMOKE
AND OTHERWISE MIGHT SWITCH TO
VAPOR PRODUCTS. FORTY THOUSAND
OF WHOM WILL DIE EACH YEAR OF
SMOKING RELATED DISEASES.
SMOKERS NEED A VIABLE
ALTERNATIVE TO DRIVE THEM FROM
CIGARETTE USE.
PAPER PRODUCTS CAN FILL THAT
VOID AND FLAVORS PLAY A CRITICAL
ROLE.
WELL ADDITIONAL LONG TERM
RESEARCH IS NEEDED THE GROWING
SCIENTIFIC CONSENSUS ON PAPER
PRODUCTS IS THAT THEY ARE A LESS
HALL HARMFUL ALTERNATIVE
COMPARED TO COMBUSTIBLE
CIGARETTES.
IN OUR STUDIES OF THOUSANDS OF
JEWEL USERS PEOPLE WHO
EXCLUSIVELY USE NON TOBACCO
FLAVORS.
WERE 30% MORE LIKELY TO SWITCH
THAN THOSE WHO USE TOBACCO
FLAVORS.
MINT AND MANGO CONSISTENTLY HAVE
THE HIGHEST WHICH RATES AMONG
ADULT SMOKERS IN OUR STUDIES.
BUT LET US BE CLEAR.
AND I SAY THIS AS A MOTHER WE
DON'T WANT ANY NON NICOTINE USER
TO USE OUR PRODUCTS ESPECIALLY
USE.
WE SUPPORT SUBSTANTIAL CATEGORY
WIDE ACTIONS TO RESTRICT YOUTH
ACCESS.
SUCH AS IMPOSING ENHANCED AGE
VERIFICATION REQUIREMENTS FOR
RETAIL AND ONLINE SALES.
AND BANNING FLAVORS AND
PACKAGING THAT ARE DIRECTLY
TARGETED AT A YOUNGER AUDIENCE
SUCH AS THOSE THAT MIMIC YOUTH
APPEALING CANDIES.
DESSERTS OR DRINKS HOWEVER WE
FEEL IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT AS WE
CONTINUE TO PURSUE NEW
LEGISLATION TO PROTECT CHILDREN
WE ALSO PRESERVE ACCESS FOR THE
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIA SMOKERS.
WHO COULD POTENTIALLY BENEFIT BY
SWITCHING FROM COMBUSTIBLE
CIGARETTES?
WE ARE COMMITTED TO WORK
CONTINUING OUR WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE COMING WEEKS
AND MONTHS. TO SUCCESSFULLY
ADDRESS THIS PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- I WAS TOLD THREE
WITNESSES AND TIME IS UP SO --
IF YOU WISH.
TO WELL SO SO WE HAVE WE ALLOW
PEOPLE TO GIVE PUBLIC CUTS STATE
THEIR POSITION AND PUBLIC
COMMENT WE DID WE ALLOW EACH
SIDE SIX MINUTES.
AND THOUGH WE ARE SO.
SO.
OF THIS OKAY THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT IS CONCERNED MY CULTURE MY
REYES AS AN ARAB AMERICAN.
AND ISSUE HERE IS WITH YOU.
OKAY JUST BE PRODUCTS OKAY --
SISTER.
AND IN THE CITY THIS IS SIR.
YEAH THAT'S IF YOU HAD INFORMED --
COMMITTEE STAFF WE IF YOU ARE A
DIFFERENT POSITION.
OKAY ALL RIGHT SO -- WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION -- BACK MICROPHONE --
PLEASE GIVE YOUR NAME L.
ORGANIZATION OF COURSE YOUR
POSITION NOT PRESUMING
OPPOSITION IF YOU'RE STANDING AT
THIS TIME.
WELCOME.
MY NAME IS JOE FORMER OWNER OF
FREEDOM FROM TOBACCO FREEDOM
BATES ORANGE COUNTY CALIFORNIA.
OPPOSE SB THIRTY EIGHT AS IT'S
OVER STEP IN ADULTS RIGHTS AND
DIGNITY.
HOPE YOU FOLKS CAN COME UP WITH
ANOTHER SOLUTION LIKE BEING AN
INTERNET SALES OF THE LIQUIDS.
SHOULD BE SUFFICIENT OKAY SIR
OKAY THANK YOU THAT IF YOU JUST
NAME ORGANIZATION YOUR POSITION
ON THIS BILL THANK YOU AFTERNOON
KATE BELUM HAVE TO CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION
BECAUSE THE IMPACT WILL HAVE ON
OUR BRICK AND MORTAR STORES.
IN THE STATE OF THE ART THANK
YOU.
DENNIS FOR FROM BEHALF
CALIFORNIA DISTRIBUTORS
SITUATION WHO SERVICES BURKE
MORE STORES IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
JOHN FLANAGAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CIGAR ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA AND
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
JEFFREY COREY PRIVATE CITIZEN --
NON SMOKER FOR THREE MONTHS
AFTER FORTY YEARS OF SMOKING A
OPPOSED TO THE LEGISLATION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I GET AFTERNOON ERIN NORWOOD ON
BEHALF OF SWEDISH MATCH NORTH
AMERICA WE HAVE AN OPPOSE LAST
AMENDED POSITION AND I WAS
WONDERING IF I MIGHT SPEAK TO
THAT BRIEFLY.
YOU CAN SPEAK BRIEFLY TO THE
AMENDMENTS WITH HIM THANK YOU AS
WE DISPATCH NORTH AMERICA IS A
PRODUCER OF SMOKELESS TOBACCO
PRODUCTS AND WE EVEN HAVE A
TOBACCO FREE NICOTINE PRODUCT --
ALL OF OUR FLAVORS ARE ALL OF
OUR PRODUCTS ARE FLAVORED
THEY'RE TYPICALLY MINTS
WINTERGREEN HONDAS ARE FLAVORS
THAT THE FDA HAS CONSISTENTLY
SATTAR NOT KID FACING AND AS
SUCH WE WOULD ASK FOR AN
EXEMPTION FOR THOSE PRODUCTS
THANK YOU.
BERMAN NOBLE DEAR ON BEHALF OF
THE OVER THIRTEEN HUNDRED
MEMBERS OF THE AMERICAN PUT --
PATROLLING AND CONVENIENCE STORE
ASSOCIATION WE'RE IN OPPOSITION
TO BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS EDWARD ELLIS I'M A
PRIVATE CITIZEN AND I AM OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
THAT AFTERNOON NADIA MERS THE
ANALYSTS CALIFORNIA STATE
LICENSE ATTORNEY PENDING
AMENDMENTS AND TO THE DISTRICT
OF CALMLY COLUMBIA SORRY AND I
VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AND
HAVE INTENT TO CHALLENGE IF.
IT PASSES TODAY AS IT
SUBSTANTIALLY OVER BROAD THANK
YOU THANK YOU CERTAINLY ANYONE
THREE TO FILE A LAWSUIT.
THANK YOU HI FRIENDS IT'S AN
OWNER OF SEE THREE VAPORS IN
COSTA MESA AND THE COMPANY
MANUFACTURING LLC -- WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE STATE OF THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU.
IS AB WADAH ON BEHALF OF AN
FASTER USA -- WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
JAMES WHITING OWNER V. SIX CITY
MISSION VIEJO AND WE'RE OPPOSED
SB [inaudible]
THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
CARE MAN OWNER OF YOU SICK VAULT
IN ORANGE COUNTY CALIFORNIA AND
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE SB.
THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
KERRY HAS FORMER SMOKER HER
QUICK WHO QUIT USING FLAVORED
PAPER PRODUCTS WHEN NO OTHER
CESSATION DEVICES WORKED OPPOSED.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS RICK MILLER
BRACE WAIT TIME THE OWNER OF
THESE TV PRINT OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
A DIFFERENT WAY REPRESENTING
TASTE VAPOR AND OAKLAND JULY
WILL BE YEAR TEN NO TOBACCO
PRODUCTS I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS STEPHANIE OAK AND
WE T. H. OUR POLICY.
I'VE BEEN A SMOKER FOR TWENTY
SEVEN YEARS AND FLAVORED PAPER
PRODUCTS ARE KEEPING ME AWAY
FROM CIGARETTES SO I STRONGLY
OPPOSED THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON CAN A BOMB
BEHALF OF THE MCLEAN COMPANY
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST DISTRIBUTOR
IN OPPOSITION WE DO HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
TO HAVE A CHAT WITH YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS PAUL RULE AND
PRACTICES AND I OPPOSE THIS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO THAT MY NAME IS BRIAN
HICKOX -- I HAVE BEEN A VAPOR
FOR OVER FIVE YEARS I LOST MY
MOTHER TO CANCER AT THE AGE OF
FOURTEEN AND THAT IS WHY I
BECAME OF THE HE MEANT SUPPORTER
OF THIS INDUSTRY IN THIS
COMMUNITY NGUYEN VAPING HELPED
ME QUIT SMOKING MYSELF.
TODAY I AM THE PRESIDENCY OF
DOOMSDAY GOURMET LLC IN THE
OWNER OF A BUNKER BY DOOMSDAY
GOURMET RIGHT HERE IN SACRAMENTO
I'M RESIDENT CARMICHAEL I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
BRENDAN MAKE YOURSELF A RESIDENT --
ORANGE COUNTY FIVE YEARS SMOKE
FREE AND I OPPOSE THANK YOU.
MASON LOPEZ REPRESENTING THE
SICK VAULT ORANGE COUNTY
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TRYST IN ANNA
STARTED SMOKING CIGARETTES AT
FIFTEEN YEARS OLD I MANAGED TO
QUIT THINKS DEVELOPING A TWENTY
YEARS OLD I'M TWENTY THREE NOW
THREE YEARS NO CIGARETTES.
THANK YOU THANK OF OPPOSED THANK
YOU.
I'M TAKE A PERMIT I'M A CONSUMER
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
AB PARKER -- A PRIVATE CITIZEN
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
ERICA THIS CASTING MIKE SUMER
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MICHAEL BUYERS I'M A
CONSUMER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS FRANCIS REBAR AMY
CONSUMER NAY STAR LABELS.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS RONALD WHAT'S FOR AND
I'M A REGISTERED ALCOHOL AND
DRUG TECHNICIAN WHOSE BEEN
VAPING FOR OVER THREE YEARS AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS GREG THOMAS I'M A
CONSUMER AND PRIVATE CITIZEN AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IN MIAMI AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS TO BE A CHAU
I'M A LOCAL TOBACCO STORE OWNER --
I WOULD JUST HEARING SENATOR
HILL COMMENDED THAT FLAVOR
TOBACCO SHOULD BE ONLY AVAILABLE
ONLINE.
WHEN HIS OUT TESTIMONY BRITAIN
AS THE ORDER THAT ARE THE BIG
PROBLEM IS ONLINE FOR THE
THROUGH THE FENCE LET'S BILL AND
I REALLY OPPOSE IT THANK YOU?
THANK YOU AGAIN NAME WORKSTATION
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS CAN YOU CHECK
KARA I'M A SMALL LOCAL
BUSINESSMEN AND PRESIDENT OF
LOCALIZATION APT ON THE TWO
HUNDRED NINETY ONE MEMBERS WHO
OPPOSES BUT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS SAM RIGID MILLION
LOCAL OUT TOBACCO DISTRIBUTOR
ALSO A BOARD MEMBER SEGMENT A
CHAPTER A PIECE HERE ASSOCIATION.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
I'M CRUZ CATCHER MEMBER OF EPCOT
APPLES THIS BILL.
BECAUSE IT IS GOING TO AFFECT
THE RETAILERS BIG BABY HAVE BEEN
SUPPORTING -- THERE YOU LOOK FOR
ALL THE KIDS TO GET THAT WE DO
NOT SELL IT TO MY NOTICE AND
IT'S NOT US INTO THE
MANUFACTURER WATER WHEN YOU TO
COULD I DO WE DO THAT I TO ME.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
YOUR NAME BURGER THIS I'M A
CONSUMER AT A LOCAL BUSINESS
BUSINESS OWNER I HAVE STRONGLY
OPPOSE AS WE THIRTY EIGHT THANK
YOU.
MAYBE MONEY I OPPOSE THIS OF
LIVER BàN THIRTY EIGHT BECAUSE
I'M A MANAGER OF A SMOKE SHOP ON
BEHALF OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
WHO WALKING TO MY STORE.
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIRTY EIGHT
THANK YOU.
THE SAME ARE ONEY -- CALIFORNIA
RETAILER AND LOCAL BUSINESS
OWNER -- I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIRTY EIGHT OKAY THANK YOU.
FINALLY A BUSINESS OWNER AN X.
ONLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU.
CAROLINE BILL HUNTER ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA FUEL THE
CONVENIENCE ALLIANCE WE
CERTAINLY WANT BELIEVE WE SHOULD
DO MORE TO KEEP TOBACCO OUT OF
THE HANDS OF TEAM BUT WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS BILL GOES TOO FAR.
AND WOULD HURT SMALL MINORITY
FAMILY OWNED BUSINESSES SO WE
BOTH BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
IF HE NOW THE CONNIE AND I'M A
CONSUMER IN ROCKLIN CALIFORNIA
AND I OPPOSE SB.
THIRTY THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS NO RUNNING IN THE
CONSUMER IN A LOCAL BUSINESS
OWNER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
PROTECT MY FREEDOM OF CHOICE.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S MICELI SENIORS THE
I'M THE MOTHER OF THREE ONE WEST
POINT GRADUATE ONE ATTORNEY AND
ONE DAUGHTER WHO WORKS FOR THE
CITY.
AND A SAN DIEGO AND I OPPOSE
THIRTY EIGHT BECAUSE I THINK IF
YOU'RE SMART ENOUGH YOU'LL DO
WHAT YOU GOTTA DO.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS VICTORIA DROUGHT ARE
I WORK FOR A COMPANY CALLED
DESERT VAPORS FROM PALM DESERT --
WHERE ANY LIQUID MANUFACTURING
COMPANY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL?
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS RUSS SMALL SIR ON
THE OWNER OF THAT SURVEY PERSON
PALM DESERT CALIFORNIA MY
COMPANY OF THE LAST SEVEN YEARS
HELPED TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
FORMER SMOKERS CONVERT TO VAPOR
PRODUCTS.
FLAVORS WERE INTEGRAL PART OF
THAT PROCESS SO WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB.
THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
NAME IS ERIC LOAN SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER IN SAN JOSE A LITTLE OVER
SIX YEARS -- STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL OKAY THANK YOU.
HI GEORGE OBISPO REPLACE PAPER
CORPORATION AND BOARD MEMBER FOR
VAPOR TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION
OPPOSES BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S MIKE I'M
REPRESENTING FEDERAL COPY
PRESENTE SICK CALIFORNIA WHERE
WE HELP A LOT OF PEOPLE QUIT
SMOKING SO OPPOSE BILL.
THANK YOU.
REMOTE COREY ON BEHALF OF MARI
MANUFACTURER OF HOOKAH TOBACCO
WE ALSO STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
THANK YOU.
GEORGE JOHNSON SAN DIEGO OWNER
OF A PIPE MANUFACTURE FOR
EIGHTEEN YEARS PLEASE PROTECT
TRADITIONAL HOOKAH PIPE SMOKING
THANK YOU THANK OPPOSE.
THANK YOU.
JOHNNY ALL GONNA SMALL BIZ
OWNERS SAN DIEGO ALSO PART OF
THE NETWORK OF ARAB AND ARAB
AMERICAN PROFESSIONALS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL AS IT DOES
GO AGAINST MY CULTURE AND RACE
AS AN ARAB AMERICAN.
I APOLOGIZE TO THE BOARD.
I'D EVERYTHING WAS ABOUT VAPE
AND I'M PART OF A DIFFERENT
ASPECT OF THIS INDUSTRY AND IT
SHOULD BE TAKEN IN CONSIDERATION
THAT'S WHY I REQUEST SOME SORT
OF AMENDMENT OR PROPOSAL -- IN
THE FUTURE HERE OKAY SO YOU YOUR
YOUR ASSETS -- ASKING FOR
AMENDMENTS IN THE FUTURE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
JOHN HAVE YOU ONE OF ALL
AMERICAN DISTRIBUTION
CORPORATION OWNER OF ALL
AMERICAN -- TOBACCO VENTURES --
DISTRIBUTOR RETAILER OUT BATTLE
ARM IN A STOP KIDS IS NOT
AGAINST BECAUSE IS AGAINST
PARENT PARENTING CONTROL AND ALL
MY CELLS.
ARE STRONGLY OPPOSE SB THIRTY
EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WHEN IS THE US HOSPITALS DOT ON
AN X. NOT BE PAPER IN SACRAMENTO
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL?
THANK YOU.
DOESN'T CARE IN AN EXTENDED BE
VAPOR I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN HOWARD FATHER OF THREE
FORMER SMOKER THANKS TO FLAVORS.
I OPPOSE THANK YOU.
MARK OUR TO A FATHER OF TWO
CHILDREN WHO WERE LONG TERM
SMOKERS ADOPTED TOBACCO IN HIGH
SCHOOL.
THAT -- QUIT DUTIES CIGARETTES
SO I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU.
CHECK A POWERED EX SMOKER DUE TO
VAPING AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE IF.
MY NAME IS SHANNON HOWARD I'M
ALSO A FORMER SMOKER WHO WAS
ABLE TO QUIT.
THANK YOU TO THE USE OF FLAVORED.
THE LIQUID I OPPOSE THANK YOU.
ROUGHLY MY NAME'S GUY BILLION
FROM THE REASON FOUNDATION WHERE
THINK TANK WE BELIEVE IN FATE
FREE KIDS BUT ALSO A SAFE HOME
ADOPTION OF ALTERNATIVES BATTLES
PROD TO OPPOSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
OKAY SEE NO OTHER PEOPLE THE
MICROPHONE [inaudible]
OKAY.
THURSTON FIRST THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR -- I'D LIKE US TO
QUESTIONS TO THE CHILDREN -- ONE
IS COULD CAN YOU DESCRIBE YOUR
FLAVORED PRODUCTS AND TELL US
WHY YOU BELIEVE THAT THEY ARE
IMPORTANT TO ADULT SMOKERS AND
THE AND THE DATA YOU HAVE TO
SUPPORT THAT NUMBER [inaudible]
ONE NUMBER.
TWO HI I'VE NEVER TRUSTED THE
TOBACCO COMPANIES.
THE MAN SHOWN TO LIE TO CONGRESS
I BELIEVE THEY SELL CIGARETTES
KNOWING THAT THEY CAUSE
MORBIDITY AND MORTALITY.
CAN I HAVE A CONCERN THAT 30% OF
YOUR COMPANY'S BEEN BOUGHT UP BY
BIG TOBACCO.
HOW CAN WE BE ASSURED THE YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO SUCCUMB TO BIG
TOBACCO'S -- YEARNING TO MAKE
MONEY OVER THE LIVELIHOOD OF
CHILDREN THAT ARE GETTING
ADDICTED TO NICOTINE.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTIONS --
SIR TO ANSWER THE FIRST QUESTION
THE FLAVORS WE HAVE MEANT AND
TOBACCO AND MENTHOL THAT ARE
CURRENTLY IN RETAIL IN NOVEMBER.
WE UNDERTOOK A LARGE ACTION PLAN
TO TO BEGIN TO ADDRESS YOUTH
USAGE WHICH INCLUDING PULLING
THOSE OUT OF RETAIL AS WELL A
COMPLETELY COMING OFF OF SOCIAL
MEDIA OTHER THAN THE USE OF
TWITTER.
I'M HAVING ADDITIONAL ONLINE AGE
VERIFICATION ADDITIONAL RETAIL
CONTROLS SUPPORTING TWENTY ONE
PLUS LEGISLATION WHICH IS OF
COURSE ALREADY IN EFFECT HERE AS
WELL AS TECHNOLOGY SOLUTIONS.
WE HAVE MANGO CUCUMBER FRUIT AND
CRAM THAT ARE CURRENTLY ONLY
AVAILABLE ONLINE TO TWENTY ONE
PLUS USERS -- AND I WAS TALKING
EARLIER ABOUT OUR BEHAVIORAL
SCIENCE PROGRAM WE HAVE OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DREW USERS IN
THAT PROGRAM OVERALL.
I'M YESTERDAY ACTUALLY OUR
SECOND S. SECOND PEER REVIEWED
PUBLICATION WAS RELEASED IN THE
HARM REDUCTION JOURNAL THAT
SPECIFICALLY TALKS ABOUT THIS
THE IMPORTANCE OF FLAVORS AND
SWITCHING.
THAT WE'VE SEEN AND THIS
PARTICULAR SURVEY WAS ALMOST TEN
THOUSAND ADULT USERS AND WE SAW
IN THAT SURVEY THAT IF YOU IF
THOSE SMOKERS WERE USING.
SOLELY A NON TOBACCO FLAVOR THEY
HAD A 30% INCREASE IN THEIR FULL
SWITCHING RIGHT.
WILL SWITCHING IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT FOR HARM REDUCTION YOU
GET THE PUBLIC HEALTH BENEFIT
WHEN YOU'RE NOT EVEN TAKING A
PUFF OF A CIGARETTE.
SO WE HAVE SEEN IN OUR DATA AND
WE HEAR ANECDOTALLY WITH WITH
SMOKERS HAVE SWITCHED ALL THE
TIME.
THAT FLAVORS ARE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO THEIR SWITCHING I
KNOW IT'S NOT INTUITIVE.
I HAVE A MENTOR MYSELF WHO WAS A
LONG TIME SMOKER HE SENT ME AN
EMAIL AND JEN END OF JANUARY OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN SAYING HUGHES
MANGO.
HE SAID IT WAS THIRTY DAYS SINCE
YOU HAVE A CIGARETTE AND IT WAS
THE LONGEST YOU'VE GONE WITHOUT
A CIGARETTE SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX TO THIS DAY HE STILL
HAD A CIGARETTE.
AND FOR THOSE SMOKERS YOU'VE
HEARD FROM IN THE ROOM IT'S AN
INCREDIBLY EMPOWERING THING FOR
THEM.
AND WE ALSO THINK VERY IMPORTANT
FROM A PUBLIC HEALTH PERSPECTIVE --
WITH RESPECT TO YOUR SECOND
QUESTION IS A GREAT QUESTION --
I PERSONALLY STRUGGLED WITH IT --
AND WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS THAT --
THAT OSHA HAS A 35% INVESTMENT
IN THE COMPANY AFTER THEY GET
THROUGH ANTI TRUST APPROVALS
THEY'LL HAVE THREE SEATS ON THE
BOARD THERE WILL NEVER HAVE A
CONTROLLING VOTE ON THE BOARD.
AND THERE ARE ADDITIONAL
PROVISIONS IN THE CONTRACT TO
PREVENT THEM FROM THAT CONTROL
POSITION.
THE REASON THAT WE UNDERTOOK
THIS INVESTMENT WAS IN ORDER TO
ACCESS TO THEIR LIST OF
SEVENTEEN MILLION -- AGE
VERIFIED ADULT SMOKERS TO WHOM
WE CAN DIRECTLY MARKET -- WE
WILL BE PUTTING INSERTS INTO
PACKS OF MARLBOROS SAYING NEXT
TIME TRY JEWEL AND MAKE THE
SWITCH -- AN INCREASE IN PROVED --
POSITIONING IN STORES AND IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT RETAIL IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
SMOKERS GO GET THEIR CIGARETTES
AT RETAIL.
AND IF WE WANT THEM TO SWITCH TO
A LESS HARMFUL ALTERNATIVE IT
NEEDS TO BE RIGHT THERE NEXT TO
IT.
SO THOSE ARE THE REASONS WE
UNDERTOOK I COMPLETELY
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN HAPPY TO
TALK FURTHER ABOUT IT AS WELL --
BUT WE'VE THOUGHT VERY HARD
ABOUT IT IN THE CONTRACT THANK
YOU -- ACTUALLY BEFORE -- BEFORE
YOU MOVE ON TO FURTHER QUESTIONS
ACTUALLY SIDE IF YOU WISH TO
HAVE YOUR WITNESSES AT THE TABLE
THEY WANT ACCESS TO HELP ANSWER
QUESTIONS -- THEY CAN.
THE ONES WHO TESTIFIED WE CAN
GET AROUND JUST.
THANK YOU OKAY YEAH ALL RIGHT --
CENTER MONEY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. ONE
THINK THE AUTHORS FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD ALL THE WITNESSES
FOR BEING HERE.
MY FIRST QUESTION IS FOR THE
GENTLEMAN WHO.
SWITCHED FROM COMBUSTIBLE
TOBACCO TO VAPING
ARE YOU STILL USING THE PRODUCTS.
YES SIR IN ARE THE PRODUCTS THAT
YOU USED TO THEY CONTAIN
NICOTINE.
YES SIR.
IS IT FAIR TO SAY YOU'RE
ADDICTED TO NICOTINE.
YES AND DO YOU KNOW OF ANY
HEALTH BENEFITS TO NICOTINE
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
I WILL MENTION THAT -- AS SOON
AS TOOL CAME OUT WITH A LOWER
NICOTINE STRENGTH I IMMEDIATELY
TRANSITION TO THAT AND HAVE HAD
NO PROBLEMS SINCE THEN IT'S BEEN
EASY.
SO I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
TO LESSEN THE NICOTINE AMOUNT AS
TIME GOES ON BUT IT WAS NOT HARD
FOR ME TO SWITCH TO THE LOWER
NICOTINE LEVEL IN Q. IN YOUR
WHERE THAT SOME OF THE JEWEL
PRODUCTS THAT ARE BEING USED BY
CHILDREN -- MIDDLE SCHOOL KIDS
HAVE A HIGHER CONCENTRATION OF
NICOTINE THAN CIGARETTE PRODUCTS
THAN CIGARETTES -- YES I THINK
THAT'S A LITTLE HARD. TO TO THE
STATE POLICE YES ON BECAUSE IF
YOU TAKE ONE INDIVIDUAL -- AND
THAT'S YOUR ONLY HIT ALL DAY
THAT NO THAT'S NOT A STRONGER
MAN A NICOTINE THAN SMOKING A
CIGARETTE.
IN HOW MANY YOUNG PEOPLE DO YOU
THINK TAKE.
ONE HIT A DAY I HONESTLY DON'T
KNOW BUT I CAN REFLECT MY OWN
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE WHEN I BEGAN
SMOKING I DIDN'T JUST FULLY GO
INTO SMOKING TWENTY CIGARETTES A
DAY.
BUT BY THE END OF MY HABIT I WAS
SMOKING THIRTY PLUS CIGARETTES A
DAY -- BUT AT THE BEGINNING IT
WAS.
SOMETHING LIKE ONE TO FIVE
CIGARETTES A DAY SO I WOULDN'T I
WOULDN'T SAY IT WAS UNREASONABLE
TO SAY THAT.
JEWEL SMOKERS AS DOES TEENAGERS
SMOKE -- AND THE DATE OF A FAIR
AMOUNT LESS THAN ADULTS SMOKE
BUT NEIGHBORS.
YOU DO BELIEVE NICOTINE TO BE AN
ADDICTIVE PRODUCT ABSOLUTELY.
SENT MY CHILDREN NEED TO VAPE
WHEN THEY'RE IN SCHOOL -- I
DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S WHY THEY
THEY FEEL THE NEED TO BE PUT IN
SCHOOL OR COULD BE PEER PRESSURE
EXCEPT -- FOR WHEN I WAS STILL
GOING TO SCHOOL IT IT WAS RIGHT
IN THE TRANSITION PERIOD OF
WHERE.
PEOPLE WERE STILL KIND OF COOL
IF YOU SMOKE CIGARETTES AND BY
KIND OF BY THE END OF MY HIGH
SCHOOL LIFE IT WAS NOT COOL AT
ALL SIX HUNDRED SO.
I APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY IN
FOR THE DOCTOR FROM UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA.
MY QUESTION FOR YOU SIR IS IF
YOU KNOW -- ARE MORE SMOKERS
BENEFITING THROUGH VAPING TO
STOP THEIR THEIR ADDICTION.
TO TOBACCO PRODUCTS.
OR OR MORE YOUNG PEOPLE USING
THEIR PRODUCTS AND BECOMING
ADDICTED TO NICOTINE.
WELL I THINK WE HAVE TO LOOK AT
BOTH SIDES OF THIS -- NUMBER ONE
THERE ARE NUMEROUS STUDIES THAT
SHOW THAT PEOPLE THAT USE
ELECTRONIC CIGARETTES TRANSITION
TO REGULAR CIGARETTES WE HAVE A
LOT OF STUDIES ON THAT WE WILL
SHARE WITH YOU.
THAT MATERIAL SECONDLY AND
UNFORTUNATELY THE SECOND PART OF
YOUR QUESTION WE KNOW THAT THE I
MEAN THE STATISTICS ARE
OVERWHELMING THAT 78% INCREASE
AND NICOTINE USE OVER THE LAST
TWO YEARS BY CHILDREN CHILDREN
FOLKS.
TWELVE TO SEVENTEEN IS WHAT WHAT
WHAT WHAT WE'RE UP AGAINST HERE.
LET ME JUST SAY -- THE THE IDEA
THAT.
THE ROYAL -- MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
OF ENGLAND SUGGESTION THAT THE
CIGARETTES ARE 95%.
OF LESS -- HARMFUL THAN REGULAR
CIGARETTES MANY OF US DISAGREE
WITH AND THERE'S MANY MANY
PAPERS WRITTEN ABOUT THAT.
MANY PAPERS WRITTEN ABOUT THAT
SO I THINK YOU TWO QUESTIONS ARE
RIGHT PEOPLE -- WHO START USING
THE CIGARETTES ARE TRANSITION TO
TO THE CIGARETTES THE MATURE?
THE STUDY SHOWED THAT THE
MAJORITY OF THEM GO BACK TO
REGULAR CIGARETTES -- IN FACT I
THINK THE DATA SHOWS PRETTY
CONCRETE LEAVE THAT WHAT WE
BASICALLY HAVE FOR TOOL USERS IN
THE UNITED STATES AND THAT'S THE
MAJORITY OF WHAT PEOPLE DO --
AND AND AND THAT'S THAT'S WHAT
HOW I WOULD ANSWER YOUR QUESTION
THANK YOU IN -- FOLLOW UP
QUESTION.
IN YOUR TESTIMONY TALKED ABOUT --
THE TARGETING OF CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES IS THIS DONE IN
TERMS OF ADVERTISING OF PRODUCTS
IN.
TARGETED COMMUNITIES.
I WOULD I WOULD EVEN TAKE IT A
STEP FURTHE -- THERE'S A WHOLE
HISTORY OF THE TOBACCO INDUSTRY
TARGETING OF MINORITY
COMMUNITIES AND SPECIALLY THE
BLACK COMMUNITY AND GETTING THEM
FLAVOR PRODUCTS WHAT'S BEEN MOST
INTERESTING TO ME ABOUT IS THE
PIVOT JEWELS TAKEN.
THAT ALL OF A SUDDEN WHAT IT
WANTS TO BE A PARTNER WITH THE
BLACK COMMUNITY AND MEETING WITH
DIFFERENT PLAY GROUPS AND HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO HELP SAVE THE
TOBACCO EPIDEMIC IN THE BLACK
COMMUNITY.
AND IT'S THE SAME PLAY BOOK THE
TOBACCO INDUSTRY IS USED FOR THE
LAST -- UNFORTUNATELY THE LAST
SIXTY OR SEVENTY YEARS WITH OUR
COMMUNITY.
LOOK THERE ARE STUDIES AND I
MENTIONED IT AND WE'VE BEEN WE
SHOULD WE SHOULD ALL BE AWARE OF
IT.
THERE ARE MORE PROMOTIONS FOR
TOBACCO PRODUCTS IN THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY THERE ARE
MORE -- DISCOUNTS.
AND THE PRODUCTS ARE CHEAPER --
WE HAVE STUDIES BOTH COMING OUT
OF MASSACHUSETTS WHO STUDIES
COMING OUT OF CALIFORNIAN FACTS
AND IT IS KNOWN FUNDED AT
STANFORD OF LOOKING AT THIS
PHENOMENA.
THE IDEA OF PUTTING UP A COUPON
FOR JUL IN A MARLBORO CIGARETTE
IS THE PROOF OF THE TOOL USE AND
AND AND IN INCREASING THE
ADDICTION OF PEOPLE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
OF WHILE IT MAY BE TRUE THAT
THAT THE ONLY THREE MEMBERS OF
THE BOARD OF TOOL CIGARETTES ON
ON OF THE PHILIP MORRIS ON JUL
CIGARETTES -- I THINK THE
PROBLEM IS IS THAT THE MARKETING
OF THESE PRODUCTS NOW HAS MUCH
MORE BACKING THEIR OF THEIR
FIGHT WITH THE FDA GETS MUCH
MORE DEVELOPED -- I THINK WE WE
WE HAVE A CHANCE TO I MEAN I
WOULD SAY THE LAST THING I SAID
AT THE OPENING OF THE ONE THING
THAT FOLKS COULD DO IN THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE THAT
OTHER THAN ANYTHING ELSE.
IF YOU TAKE FLAVORS OUT OF
TOBACCO PRODUCTS IT WOULD
IMPROVE THE PUBLIC HEALTH IN
CALIFORNIA STRAIGHT UP.
THANK YOU SIR.
STRAIGHT UP.
I'D I REDUCE SO ACTUALLY YES I
AM.
YEAH IT'S AGAIN -- WE TREAT
EVERYONE THE SAME.
NO OUTBURSTS SEVEN VERY
INDICATED EVEN TO PREVIOUS
GROUPS THE SO IF WE CAN PLEASE
MAINTAINER DECORUM HERE WOULD BE
APPRECIATED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- YET IS
THE PRACTICE TO TREAT ALL VIEW
POINTS WITH RESPECT IN THIS
BUILDING.
SO I APPRECIATE THAT MISTER
CHAIR -- IN FOR THE AUTHOR
SOMEONE AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
THE DATA THAT SHOWS YOUTH ARE
ALSO ABLE TO ACQUIRE THESE OVER
THE INTERNET -- I BELIEVE YOU
HAVE ANOTHER BILL THAT'S GOING
TO ADDRESS THAT ISSUE THE NEXT
BILL YES.
SB THIRTY NINE WHAT WILL ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE.
SO THAT IS PART OF YOUR OVERALL.
STRATEGY OF ON THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
MIGHT I RESPECT ON TO TO WE GIVE
THOSE YOU COULDN'T ACTUALLY IF
YOU'RE ASKED THE QUESTION.
THEN YOU MAY RESPOND SO IT'S UP
TO THE SENATOR FOR NOW QUESTION
ANSWER PERIOD CENTER LEYVA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THANK
YOU GENTLEMEN -- SENATORS AND
I'M HAPPY TO BE A CO AUTHOR ON
BOTH OF YOUR BILLS.
AND WE TALKED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
NICOTINE AND HOW ADDICTIVE IT IS
SO I JUST LOOKED IT UP ON
WIKIPEDIA SO WE COULD.
HAVE AN IDEA OF WHAT WIKIPEDIA
SAYS A NICOTINE IS HIGHLY
ADDICTIVE IT IS ONE OF THE MOST
COMMONLY ABUSED.
DRUGS SO I THINK THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE LEAVING OUT
OF THIS EQUATION NICOTINE IS A
DRUG.
IT ALSO SAYS THAT NICOTINE
INDUCES BOTH BEHAVIORAL
STIMULATION AND ANXIETY.
NICOTINE ADDICTION INVOLVES DRUG
REINFORCE BEHAVIOR COMPULSIVE
USE AND RELAPSE FOLLOWING
ABSTINENCE.
IT GOES ON AND ON BUT I THINK
YOU PROBABLY GET MY POINT.
MY FRUSTRATION AS SOMEONE WHO
GREW UP DURING A TIME WHEN
CIGARETTES WERE POPULAR AND VERY
GLAD THAT I NEVER STARTED.
IS WE'VE SEEN A DECREASE IN
TOBACCO USE AND NOW WE SEE A
RISE IN VAPING THIS IS JUST A
GREAT WAY FOR THE TOBACCO
INDUSTRY TO FIND A NEW REVENUE
STREAM.
AND I KNOW JEWEL WE MET YOU CAME
TO MY OFFICE YESTERDAY.
AND I THINK YOU GUYS SEE
YOURSELVES AS THE GOOD PLAYERS
IN A BAD INDUSTRY BUT I'M GONNA
HIGHLIGHT BAD INDUSTRY IF WE
DON'T HAVE THE FLAVORS THEN
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO MAKE ANOTHER
CHOICE AND IF THEY WANNA VAPE
GREAT BUT QUITE DOESN'T TASTE AS
GOOD IT'S PROBABLY NOT AS MUCH.
FUN IT'S PROBABLY NOT COOL.
SO WE REALLY WANT TO DO
SOMETHING FOR THE GOOD OF
SOCIETY LET'S GET PEOPLE ON
ADDICTED IF YOU'RE NOT ADDICTED
TO TOBACCO BUT YOU'RE ADDICTED
TO NICOTINE.
WHAT'S THE STEP FORWARD HERE I I
JUST I JUST REALLY DON'T SEE IT
I APPRECIATE THAT THIS IS YOUR
JOB AND THIS IS WHAT YOU DO AND
APPARENTLY IT'S WHAT YOU FEEL
PASSIONATE ABOUT -- BUT I JUST I
JUST DON'T SEE IT SO -- THANK
YOU AGAIN THANK YOU FOR LETTING
ME BE A CO AUTHOR I LOOK FORWARD
TO VOTING I ON THE BILL.
THANK YOU SENATOR GROWTH.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND YOU
KNOW THANK YOU I'D LIKE TO THINK
CENTER HILL FOR ALLOWING ME TO
MEET WITH HIM REGARDING MY
CONCERNS ABOUT THE AT THE
BUSINESS ASPECT OF THIS
PARTICULAR -- DISCUSSION THAT
WE'RE HAVING TODAY AND SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME ON THAT --
I DO HAVE A A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS -- ONE I WANT TO START
OUT IT COULD BE MY MISS MY
UNDERSTANDING I IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING BUT I DON'T KNOW
IF I'M CORRECT SO I'M JUST GOING
TO ASK.
EXISTING LAW MAKES IT A CRIME
PUNISHABLE BY A FINE OF SEVENTY
FIVE DOLLARS OR THIRTY HOURS A
WEEK IF COMMUNITY SERVICE TO BE
IN POSSESSION.
OR PURCHASE RECEIVER POSSESSION
OF CERTAIN PRODUCTS -- MEANING
THIS PARTICULAR PRODUCT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TODAY FOR MINORS.
IS THAT LOST ELIMINATION OF A
PRODUCT IS ACTION AT SEVENTY
FIVE DOLLARS AND THIRTY HOURS OF
COMMUNITY SERVICE NOT AWARE OF
THAT AT ALL I DON'T BELIEVE
THERE IS A PENALTY FOR
POSSESSION OF THE SOMEBODY
ANSWER DOT PRODUCT THERE IS A
FINE OF SEVENTY DOLLARS AND THE
EXISTING PENALTIES.
ENTERS ITS STRUCTURE OF THE
STATE ACTON AND WHICH CURRENTLY
IN PLACE WE'RE NOT.
TOUCHING THAT ARE CHANGING THAT
SO DID WE REPEAL THAT CAN
SOMEBODY ANSWER THAT.
WE'RE NOT REPEALING THAT NO BUT
DID WEEK BECAUSE IT WAS EXISTING
LOT ONE TIME BECAUSE I'M READING
IT RIGHT HERE IT SAYS EXISTING
LAW MAKES IT A CRIME PUNISHABLE.
BY A FINE OF SEVENTY FIVE
DOLLARS OR THIRTY HOURS OF
COMMUNITYSERVICE WORK FOR A
PERSON UNDER THE EIGHTEEN YEARS
OF AGE.
IN ORDER TO PURCHASE RECEIVE OR
BE IN POSSESSION OF THESE
PRODUCTS SO IS IS THAT LAS STILL
EXIST.
CHANGE THE THE AGE FOR SMOKING
TO TWENTY ONE THAT WAS REPEALED --
IT WAS OKAY SO WE DID REPEAL
THAT SO NOTE STUDENT -- AND AGE
MINOR CAN BE PUNISHED FOR BEING
IN POSSESSION OF OKAY SO I DO
HAVE AN AND WEBER WANTS TO
ANSWER THESE QUESTIONS I'M OPEN
TO IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE YOU SIR
AND I'M NOT TRYING TO PIN YOU
DOWN.
WE WE WILL AS IT CURRENTLY LEGAL
WILL DIRECT QUESTIONS TO THE
AUTHORS ORDER.
OKAY IS THERE HE IS IF YOU YOU
KNOW IF YOU WISH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND IS IT
CURRENTLY LGAL TO SELL FLAVORED
MARIJUANA PRODUCTS SINCE IN
CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
YES.
DOES THIS BILL CONTINUE TO ALLOW
THE SALE OF FLAVORED MARIJUANA.
IT IS THE INTENT OF THE BILL TO
SELL FLAVORED MARIJUANA NOTE SO
IS IT CURRENTLY LEGAL TO SELL
FLAVORED MARIJUANA PRODUCTS.
IN CALIFORNIA.
NO.
CURRENT CURRENT.
LAW.
EXCUSE ME AGAIN.
ABOUT HIS ANIMALS AND THAT'S I I
WOULD ASK THAT PEOPLE PLEASE
MAINTAIN DESERVED QUORUM IT'S
THE CHAIR WITH THEIR IF.
THERE'S SOME QUESTIONS WE HAVE
STAFF -- CAN LOOK THAT UP YOU
CAN GET FLAVORED TOBACCO
FLAVORED MARIJUANA EDIBLES AND
OTHER THINGS YES YOU CAN.
DOES YOUR BILL HOW CAN YOU.
BE HERE -- SIR IF YOU ARE NOT.
ABLE TO FOLLOW THE RULES.
WE MAY HAVE TO ASK YOU TO LEAVE
BUT THANK YOU.
I PREFER NOT TO DO THAT WITH THE
TEARS INDULGENCE AWKWARD ASKING
QUESTIONS.
THAT.
IS IT CURRENTLY -- FOR LEGAL TO
SELL FLAVOR ALCOHOL IN
CALIFORNIA.
I WOULD THINK SO YES.
SO I GUESS I ASK THOSE QUESTIONS
AND THE REASON WHY I ASK THOSE
QUESTIONS IS BECAUSE THERE ARE --
IT POLICIES THAT WE AS A
LEGISLATIVE BODY PEOPLE IN THE
PAST HAVE PUT IN PLACE TO LIMIT.
THE ABILITY FOR MINORS UNDER THE
AGE OF EIGHTEEN OR TWENTY ONE TO
BE ABLE TO NOT PURCHASE.
OF THOSE PRODUCTS.
THROUGH EDUCATION INCREASED
ENFORCEMENT FINES PENALTIES
THINGS LIKE THAT.
I GUESS MY CURE US MY CURIOSITY
IS IS THAT ALL OF THOSE THINGS
MARIJUANA -- CIGARETTES THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS EVER YOU KNOW
ALCOHOL THOSE THINGS ARE
ADDICTIVE AS WELL SO I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS IS THAT.
WHY IT ALL ALBION WHY NOT ALLOW
INDUSTRY? TO ADDRESS THESE THESE
ISSUES RECUR GUARDIAN MINERS
LIKE WE HAVE ALL AND THEIR
INDUSTRIES THAT WE DON'T WANT
OUR CHILDREN TO HAVE ACCESS TO
BUT STILL ALLOW ADULT ACCESS.
HIS INDUSTRY IN RELATED TO
NICOTINE ADDICTION AND TOBACCO
AND CERTAINLY SINCE THE 35% OF
THIS COMPANY IS NOW OWNED BY A
TOBACCO COMPANY.
THEY FAILED TO DO THAT.
HISTORICALLY.
WE CONTINUE TO MARKET THE
THAT PRODUCT INTO THE HANDS OF
YOUNG PEOPLE I DON'TSEE I'VE
NOT PERSONALLY SEEN THAT WITH
ALCOHOL.
THE END WOULD NOT SEEN THE 78%
INCREASE IN ONE YEAR FOR HIGH
SCHOOL USE.
OF E. CIGARETTES OR 48% INCREASE
IN MIDDLE SCHOOL USE.
OF THE CIGARETTES THIS IS AN
EPIDEMIC THAT REQUIRES THIS
ACTION TODAY I DON'T TRUST THE
TOBACCO INDUSTRY I DON'T TRUST
TOOL I DON'T TRUST THE
MANUFACTURERS OF THIS PRODUCT.
TO SAY THAT THEY'RE GOING.
TO MANAGE IT THEMSELVES AND
REGULATE THEMSELVES TO MAKE
THOSE CHANGES AND TO KEEP THAT
OUT OF THE HANDS OF CHILDREN.
SO I GUESS I YOU KNOW.
TO RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE ONLY
BECAUSE YOU KNOW I DON'T I DON'T
SEE THE MARIJUANA INDUSTRY DOING
THE SAME THING I YOU KNOW
THEY'RE PROVIDING -- FLAVORED
TOBACCO PRODUCTS ARE FLAVORED
PRODUCTS LABOR DUMMIES FLAVOR
THINGS LIKE THAT THAT WOULD
APPEAL TO KIDS.
AND WE MANAGED TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO REGULATE THAT INDUSTRY TO A
POINT THAT DOESN'T ALLOW CHILD
ACCESS.
I GUESS -- THE IMPACT OF THIS
BILL ONE BUSINESS WHIH WE
TALKED ABOUT A BUSINESS -- YOU
KNOW AS A BUSINESS OWNER -- AND
AGAIN IT'S JUST A BIT IT'S A
BUSINESS AS A BUSINESS OWNER
THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT
THAT'S MADE IN ORDER -- TO INTO
YOU KNOW MARKET A PRODUCT --
ORDERED A SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT
ON EMPLOYEES AND AND INVESTMENT
TO STEVEN STARTED BUSINESS IN
THE STATE.
SO I TO I KNOW THAT WE HAD
SIGNIFICANT TESTIMONY FROM
BUSINESS OWNERS HERE I KNOW
THERE'S PROBABLY -- FORTY THREE
SHOPS THAT ARE LICENSED TAX
PAYING SMALL BUSINESS VAPE SHOPS
YEAH I'M HERE IN SACRAMENTO
ALONE IN.
THE EIGHTEEN SUGGEST THAT THEY
MIGHT LOSE 85% OF THEIR BUSINESS
AND POSSIBLY SHUT DOWN -- AGAIN
IS THERE ANY WAY THAT WE CAN
RESTRICT THE USE OF UNDER AGE --
ACTIVITY IN THESE BILLS ARE THIS
PRODUCT.
WITHOUT AN ALL OUT BEYOND AND
I'M JUST ASKING FOR
CONSIDERATION IN THAT.
BURGER AND I WILL IN
INTERESTINGLY THE USE USE OF
MARIJUANA MY UNDERSTANDING IS
ACTUALLY DECLINING.
SINCE THE LEGALIZATION OF
RECREATIONAL USE OF MARIJUANA IN
CALIFORNIA SO IT'S ACTUALLY
GOING THE OTHER DIRECTION.
EVEN WITH THE GUMMY BEARS AND
SOME OF THE OTHER THINGS THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS A
BUSINESS OWNER I GUESS WHAT I
HAVE TROUBLE.
UNDERSTANDING AND I CAN SEE SOME
IMPACT OF THAT BUT IF I WERE
ADDICTED TO NICOTINE.
AND I WALK INTO A RETAIL
ESTABLISHMENT.
ADDICTED TO NICOTINE.
AND I WANNA FLAVORED NICOTINE
PRODUCTS.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE NICOTINE
FIVE FLAVORED NICOTINE PRODUCT
BUT I'M ADDICTED TO NICOTINE.
I'M GONNA BUY WHATEVER PRODUCT
THEY HAVE IT HAS NICOTINE AND SO
THEY'RE GOING TO GET THE SALE.
PEOPLE GONNA SPEND THE MONEY ON
THE PRODUCT THAT MEETS THE NEED
TO TO SUPPLY THEIR ADDICTION.
THAT'S WHERE I DON'T BELIEVE
THEY WILL LOSE THE MONEY THAT
EVERYONE TALKS ABOUT OF THE
BUSINESS THAT THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
I'M ADDICTED TO NICOTINE.
I NEED THAT FIX AND I'M GONNA
GET IT WHATEVER IT COSTS.
M. OKAY WHY IBM I DO THINK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR RESPONSE AND
I DO A I DO THINK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR MEETING WITH ME -- BASED ON
WHAT YOU JUST SAID IT'S IT'S
ILLEGAL THOUGH FOR THESE UNDER
TWENTY ONE YEAR OLDS TO PURCHASE
THIS PRODUCT WHETHER THEY'RE
ADDICTED TO IT OR NOT I WAS
REFERRING TO TWENTY ONE YEAR OLD
OKAY.
BILLS OR DOING THE DISHES I
DON'T THINK THESE RETAIL
ESTABLISHMENTS EVER SELL TO
MINORS.
THEY MADE BUT I DON'T BELIEVE
THEY DO INTENTIONALLY BUT
THERE'S A TALKING ABOUT THE
ADULT BUSINESSES THEY MAY LOSE
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT THEY
CAN NO LONGER SELL FLAVORED
TOBACCO PRODUCTS.
IF YOU WALK INTO THAT STORE
YOU'RE GOING TO BUY EIGHT
NICOTINE.
SUPPLY PRODUCTS WHATEVER THAT IS
TO METHAT HAVE IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR [inaudible]
SENATE MITCHELL -- FIRST OF ALL
I'D LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
MIDDLE SCHOOLERS AND HIGH
SCHOOLERS IN THE HEARING ROOM
TODAY BECAUSE YOU ALL HAVE ACTED
WITH.
GREAT DIPLOMA AND MATURITY MUCH
MORE SO THAN SOME OF THE OTHER
SO I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND
CONGRATULATE YOU.
I HAVE A QUESTION THROUGH THE
CHAIR IF I MAY ADDRESS IT TO THE
GENTLEMAN WHO ARE MAKING OUT TO
BE A LONG TERM SMOKER.
I'M CURIOUS.
AS A FORMER TOBACCO SMOKER.
ARE YOU SUGGESTING THAT IF YOU
COULD HAVE HAD ACCESS TO THE
FLAVORS TO VAPING THAT YOU
WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
SUCCESSFULLY TRANSITION.
I'M SUGGESTING THAT.
WHEN THE SMOKERS QUIT
CONSIDERING QUITTING SMOKING
ANYTHING THAT?
REALLY ASSOCIATE THEMSELVES WITH
TOBACCO CIRCUITS HAVE FOR
EXAMPLE CIGARS DIP PRODUCTS
ANYTHING ASSOCIATED WITH TOBACCO --
ISN'T GOING TO HELP YOU QUIT
SMOKING CIGARETTES SO THE SECOND
THAT THIS BECAME A MAJOR
PHENOMENON THE PEOPLE -- AND YOU
START HERE OF THE OTHER FLAVOR
CHOICES.
IN YOUR MIND YOU CAN.
IMMEDIATELY START TO ASSOCIATE
THAT YOU'RE NOT SMOKING TOBACCO
I'D ALSO LIKE TO ADD IN ON THAT
POINT THAT NOT ALL NICOTINE IN
PAY PRODUCTS COMES FROM TOBACCO --
THERE'S MANY THERE'S OTHER
SOURCES THAT NICOTINE COMES FROM --
BUT YES I I I AM STATING THAT IT
WAS EXTREMELY HELPFUL FOR ME TO
BE ABLE TO BECAUSE AT THE SAME
TIME THAT THERE WAS FOR FLAVORS
THERE WAS ALSO TOBACCO.
FLAVOR.
THAT I COULD HAVE CHOSEN FROM
BUT YOU OPTED NOT TO BECAUSE IN
YOUR MIND YOU WERE TRANSITIONING
AWAY FROM SMOKING SO THE FLAVOR
GAVE YOU THE IMPRESSION THAT YOU
WERE.
NOT REALLY SMOKING CORRECT -- IT
DEFINITELY DID IT DEFINITELY DID
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT MORE
RECENTLY WHEN WHEN THE 3%.
WHEN THE LOWER NICOTINE LEVELS
CAME OUT THE -- THE THEM THE
IMMEDIATE ENTRY.
IMMEDIATE ONES THAT WERE
AVAILABLE TO ME WE'RE BACK TO
THE TOBACCO FLAVOR AND SO I
ACTUALLY BOUGHT THAT AND I CAN
TELL YOU THAT IT TOUGH MENTALLY.
DEFINITELY BROUGHT ME BACK TO
CIGARETTE SMOKING WHICH BY THE
WAY I FIND DISGUSTING.
ABSOLUTELY 1100% AND THAT WAS
VERY HARD AND SO WHEN I HEARD
THEM TALKING ABOUT -- THEY'LL
GET THEY'LL GET ANYTHING THAT'S
NOT TRUE THAT'S REALLY NOT TRUE
I THINK.
A LOT OF PAPERS WOULD GO AS FAR
AS TRYING TO BUY THEIR OWN
LITTLE FLAVOR.
YOU KNOW AN EDIBLE GRADE LAVORS
THAT THEY COULD ADD TO THEIR
THEIR NICOTINE THIRD THEIR PAPER
PRODUCTS AT THAT POINT -- IT IS
VERY MUCH SO BUT THE FLAVORS FOR
ME PERSONALLY WERE A MAJOR PART
OF ME BEING ABLE TO DISASSOCIATE
WITH TOBACCO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER.
Q. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
RIGHT.
YES -- CENTER STONE -- I WANT TO
JUST -- AND JUST MAKE A FEW CAN
CONCLUDING COMMENTS ABOUT -- THE
HEARING TODAY -- WITH REGARD TO
MY TO MY COLLEAGUE -- TALKING
ABOUT FLAVORED ALCOHOL AND
FLAVORED -- CANNABIS -- THE
DIFFERENCE IS [inaudible]
THAT [inaudible]
TOBACCO KILLS [inaudible]
TOBACCO.
HAS CARCINOGENS DUNDALK MY
TRADITIONAL TOBACCO -- YOU CAN'T
OVERDOSE BY INHALING MARIJUANA.
WE HAVE INSTANCES WHERE CHILDREN
OF EDEN EDIBLES AND HAVE.
HAD FATAL.
ACTIONS -- CERTAINLY IF YOU
DRINK TOO MUCH ALCOHOL YOU CAN
BECOME AN ALCOHOLIC AND YOU CAN
DIE OF CIRRHOSIS OF THE LIVER.
BUT I THINK THE DANGERS OF
TOBACCO.
THERE IS PLACES -- THE FLAVORED
ISSUE IN IN A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT CATEGORY [inaudible]
SO.
I AM A PHARMACIST.
AND I HAVE I WORK HARD IN MY
CAREER IN.
INCREASING LAWS THAT ALLOW US TO
HELP PEOPLE.
GET OFF OF TOBACCO TO START
TAKING TOBACCO.
THE LAWS OF ALLOW US.
TO BASICALLY RECOMMENDED
PRESCRIBED.
NICOTINE CESSATION PROGRAMS.
BUT THIS ISSUE LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IS VERY PERSONAL FOR
ME.
IT'S PERSONAL BECAUSE MY MOTHER
[inaudible]
CHARLENE.
WHO HAD ME WHEN SHE WAS
SEVENTEEN YEARS OLD?
DIED AT FIFTY SEVEN YEARS OLD.
FROM LUNG CANCER.
AND I SPENT MANY NIGHTS WITH HER
SHE DIED SIX MONTHS FROM THE
DIAGNOSIS.
AND **** STOP SMOKING FOR TEN
YEARS.
IN ONE OF THE MOST COMPELLING
THINGS THAT SHE SAID TO ME WHEN
SHE WAS DYING [inaudible]
WAS THAT [inaudible]
GOD.
HAD ME HAVE YOU AT A YOUNG AGE.
FOR A REASON.
AND THAT WAS SO WE COULD SPEND A
WHOLE LIFETIME TOGETHER.
AND HOW SHE REGRETTED.
YOU KNOW.
THE POISONS.
I'LL NEVER FORGET A DAY WHEN I
WAS DRIVING INTO LOS ANGELES WE
WERE A LOW INCOME FAMILY.
DRIVING INTO LAW SAYING TO SEE
MY GRANDPARENTS AND ON THE RADIO
THE FRONT SEAT TO MY SISTER WAS
IN THE FRONT SEAT IN A CAR SEAT
AND I WAS IN THE BACK.
THE NEWS FLASHES CAME OVER.
NAT KING COLE'S.
DIED.
OF LUNG CANCER [inaudible]
FROM SMOKING.
AND I SAID TO MY MOM I SAID.
MOM WHY ARE YOU SMOKING
[inaudible]
IT KILLS.
HAD HE SAID.
BECAUSE I HAVE SOMETHING CALLED
AN ADDICTION.
IT'S NOT THAT I WANT TO SMOKE.
IT'S THAT I HAVE TO SMOKE.
MY GRANDMOTHER VIRGINIA FRIEDMAN.
I RAN OUT OF MONEY WHEN I WAS
GOING TO UCICE I TRANSFERRED TO
UCLA TO GO TO SCHOOL.
I ASKED MY GRANDMOTHER CAN I
COME LIVE WITH YOU.
SHE SAID THAT I COULD A LITTLE
FOR FIVE YEARS A YEAR UCLA FIVE
FOUR YEARS THE U. S. C. SCHOOL
PHARMACY.
MY GRANDMOTHER WAS A SMOKER SHE
SPOKE FOR OVER SEVENTY YEARS.
AND HAD A HORRIFIC DEATH OF
EMPHYSEMA.
MY UNCLE TOM [inaudible]
WHO IS?
AN INCREDIBLE HUMAN BEING
ACTUALLY.
INTRODUCED ME AND TAUGHT ME
ABOUT POLITICS HAVING BEEN A
POLITICS HIMSELF.
LIVES IN LOS ANGELES IN CHERRY
HILLS AND SENATOR -- HOLLY
MITCHELL'S DISTRICT.
WHO CAN'T EVEN WALK FROM THE BED
TO THE TOILET?
BECAUSE OF HIS SMOKING HISTORY.
AND HE'S MAX OUT AN OXYGEN.
HE'S MAX OUT ON HIS DRUGS.
AND IT'S NOT GOING TO BE --
EIGHTY CLOSE IN TIME FOR HIM.
AND I PRAY FOR HIS.
HAS ABLE HIS ABILITY TO SOMEHOW
OXYGENATE.
I LOVE HIM VERY VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
MY FRIENDS.
I UNDERSTAND THE BUSINESS
ATTRIBUTES PEOPLE THAT HAVE
EMBRACE THIS FLAVORING AND OF
DEVELOP BUSINESSES.
BUT I WOULD TELL YOU RIGHT NOW
THAT WHEN MY MOTHER WAS SMOKING
WE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT WE KNOW
TODAY.
BECAUSE WE WERE NEVER TOLD THE
TRUTH BY MOMENT WAS NEVER TOLD
THE TRUTH.
THAT HER GENERATION WAS NEVER
TOLD THE TRUTH.
AND HOW MANY MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
DIED AND SUFFERED COULD YOU
IMAGINE NOT BEING ABLE TO CATCH
HER BREATH TO DIE [inaudible]
SO.
AS A MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND RIVERSIDE COUNTY
I SAT ON A WONDERFUL
ORGANIZATION THE MANY OF YOU ARE
VERY FAMILIAR WITH.
THIS CALL FIRST.
FIVE FIRST FIVE RECOGNIZES THAT
THE MOST IMPORTANT INTERVENTION
THAT YOU CAN HAVE IN A CHILD'S
LIFE IS IN THE FIRST FIVE YEARS
OF THEIR LIFE.
AND IT'S SUPPORTED BY TOBACCO
TAXES.
AND THE GOOD NEWS IS.
THAT OVER THE YEARS WE'VE SEEN A
DECLINE IN TOBACCO USE AND THE
BAD NEWS FOR FIRST FIVE IS AT
THE SCENE A DECLINE.
AND THE REVENUE STREAMS.
ALSO SERVING ON THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WILL LEAD
ENTERTAINER BUDGET EVERY YEAR WE
HAVE OPEN ENROLLMENT.
IT WAS TOLD TO US IN DECEMBER SO
I COUNTY WHICH IS THE FOURTH
LARGEST COUNTY IN THE STATE OUR
COST EVERY YEAR. TO TAKE CARE OF
PEOPLE.
BECAUSE OF TOBACCO RELATED
ILLNESSES IT'S THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
[inaudible]
AND NOW.
WHEN WE THOUGHT WE WERE GETTING
OUT OF THIS TOBACCO GENERATION
AND WE'VE?
GONE OVER THE HUMP.
IN THE END LEADING PEOPLE TO
GOOD HEALTHY LIVES.
WE SEE THE STATISTICS THAT THESE
AUTHORS ARE BROUGHT FORWARD 70%
INCREASE.
IN THE UTILIZATION -- IN THE
PAST TWO YEARS 48% IS EVEN MORE
DISTURBING IN MIDDLE SCHOOLS.
AND TO ME IT'S IT'S VERY
TRANSPARENT.
THAT THESE TOBACCO COMPANIES
INVESTING IN THESE VAPING
COMPANIES HAVE ONE GOAL AND A
ONE GOAL IS NOT. TO TRY TO GET
PEOPLE TO STOP USING TRADITIONAL
TOBACCO THEIR GOAL IS TO GET
YOUNGSTERS.
ADDICTED TO NICOTINE ONE OF THE
MOST.
A NEW ADDICTIVE PRODUCTS IN THE
WORLD.
EVEN AS ADDICTIVE AS HEROIN
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN.
THIS IS PURPOSEFUL.
AND WHY ARE THEY DOING IT
THEY'RE DOING IT BECAUSE THEY
WANT TO MAKE MONEY.
AND THAT'S WHY.
I'VE CHOSEN NEVER TO TAKE ANY
TOBACCO MONEY IN MY TENURE HERE
IN THE STATE LEGISLATURE AND I'M
GOING TO MAINTAIN THAT
[inaudible]
SO.
I KNOW THIS IT IS A VERY
POWERFUL ADDICTION.
MY FELT FELLOW SENATORS.
AND YOU THAT IF YOU HAVE A
CHOICE.
OF A BIG.
VERSUS USING TRADITIONAL TOBACCO.
THAT IS NOT GOING TO GIVE YOU
THE TARS AND CARCINOGENS THAT
ARE GONNA CAUSE CANCER -- IF
YOU'RE AN INTELLIGENT PERSON.
AND CAMPY THAN THE ADDICTION
YOU'RE GOING TO USE THE
UNFLAVORED PRODUCT. TO SATISFY
YOUR NEED FOR NICOTINE.
BUT MY CONCERN.
AND THE DOCTOR CONFIRMED IT.
IS THAT THESE PRODUCTS ARE A
GATEWAY TO GETTING PEOPLE BACK
ON TRADITIONAL TOBACCO.
AND I DON'T WANT MORE MONEY
GOING TO FIRST FIVE AGAIN AFTER
YEARS OF EDUCATING PEOPLE ABOUT
THE HAZARDS IN DANGERS LOOK AT
THE WARNINGS THAT ARE ON A PACK
OF CIGARETTES.
IT CAN CAUSE DEATH.
CAUSE OF DEATH YOU DON'T SEE IT
ON MARIJUANA PACKAGING.
YOU DON'T SEE IT ON BOTTLES OF
ALCOHOL THOUGH IF THOSE ARE.
CHRONICALLY MUSIC CERTAINLY CAN
DIE.
SO WHILE IT IS PROBABLY -- RARE
FOR A REPUBLICAN. TO TAKE A
STANCE AS I AM TAKING I'M VERY
PROUD OF MY STANCE I STAND WITH
THESE TWO COLLEAGUES I'M A CO
AUTHOR WITH THESE. TWO TO CALL
AUTHORS AND I WILL DO EVERYTHING
IN MY POWER TO EDUCATE OUR YOUTH
ABOUT THE HAZARDS OF NICOTINE
AND THE HAZARDS TOBACCO SMOKE AS
LONG AS I LIVE IN THE MEMORY.
OF MY MOTHER CHARLENE MARCH.
NOW MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU -- IT'S HARD TO FOLLOW
THAT CENTER STONE BUT ALL RIGHT
WELL I DID HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS BUT YOU KNOW WHAT --
WELL LET -- MORE FISH ANSWER
STUNS THAT IS AND HE'S MOVED THE
BILL SO.
AT THE ASKER AUTHORS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
MEMBERS AND THANK YOU SENATOR
STONE. FOR THE THAT THE PASSION --
IN FOR SHARING THAT VERY --
STRONG AND POWERFUL STORY OF
YOUR FAMILY.
THE IMPACT THAT A TOBACCO
NICOTINE HAD ON YOUR FAMILY
THANK YOU THAT.
WORDS CAN'T EXPRESS THAT IN
THANK YOU TO MY JOINT AUTHORS.
SENATORS GLAZIER AND AND A
SPECIAL THANKS TO THE YOUTH WHO
ARE HERE TODAY FOR BEING HERE
SPENDING THE WHOLE DAY HERE.
AND FOR THE GREAT SUPPORT THAT
YOU'VE GIVEN AND AND ATHLETES
DON'T BABY IS.
MAY I AM A WE'RE ALL WITH.
THANK YOU.
A THE CALLING TO THE THE
OPPOSITION HAS MADE SEVERAL
CLAIMS MANY CLAIMS THAT THEIR
PRODUCTS HELP ADULT SMOKERS QUIT
WE'VE HEARD THAT.
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
WELL IF JUL OR ANY OTHER TOBACCO
COMPANY WANTS TO HELP ADULTS
QUIT SMOKING.
pUNDER SB THIRTY EIGHT THEY STILL
HAVE THE OPTION TO APPLY TO THE
FEDERAL DRUG ADMINISTRATION TO
AND GET THEIR PRODUCTS
DESIGNATED AS A TOBACCO
CESSATION.
EIGHT OTHERS HAVE DONE THAT.
AND THEIR PRODUCTS THAT HELP YOU
AND THEY HAVE NICOTINE.
IN THEM TO HELP THE BILL BUT
THAT'S NOT WHAT THEY WANT.
THAT'S WHAT THEY TELL US BUT
NO E. CIGARETTE HAS SUCH
APPROVAL NOR HAVE ANY EVEN BEEN
FETED AT ALL BY THE FDA.
WELL I UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS
OF THE OPPOSITION THE IMPACT
FLAVOR TOBACCO IS HAVING ON OUR
KIDS IS TRULY ASTONISHING.
AND I JUST WANT.
TO IF USED TO TO SEE IF WE HAVE
A FRONT IN THE BEGINNING BUT 80%
OF YOUNG PEOPLE.
WHO HAVE EVER USED TOBACCO
STARTED WITH THE FLAVORED
PRODUCT 80% THE START OF THE
FLAVORED PRODUCT? 74% OF YOUTH
WHO USED JUL FLAVORED PODS.
OBTAINED THE DEVICE FROM A
PHYSICAL RETAIL LOCATION 74%.
THIS IS THE ONE THAT I THINK IS
MOST COMPELLING AND WAS FOR ME.
BECAUSE THEY WE TALK ABOUT THOSE
WHO HAVE MIGRATED IN A PROTECTED
GOTTEN OFF OF TOBACCO CIGARETTES
IN GOING TO E. CIGARETTES AND
HOW GREAT THAT IS FOR THEM AND I
APPLAUD THEM FOR THAT.
BUT THIS.
THE STATISTICS SHOW.
THAT FOR EVERY ADULT WHO QUIT
SMOKING USING E. CIGARETTES
[inaudible] EIGHTY USE A NEW
SHE ATE DALY TOBACCO USE THROUGH
E. CIGARETTES.
EIGHTY SO WHAT'S THE BALANCE IN
THAT.
IT ALSO E. CIGARETTE USERS ARE
56% MORE LIKELY TO HAVE A HEART
ATTACK AND 30%.
MORE LIKELY TO SUFFER A STROKE.
THOSE ARE THE STATISTICS
COLLEAGUES.
THIS NEEDS TO STOP.
BEFORE WE GET ANOTHER GENERATION
HOOKED ON NICOTINE AND SADLY.
WE MAY ALREADY BE TOO LATE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
IN CENTER MAJOR.
I CONCUR THANK YOU.
FOR OKAY THANK YOU MEMBERS THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT SO -- THE BILL IS
BEEN -- SECONDED BY -- CENTER
STONE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
AN HI CAN I STONE.
STONE I TORONTO HI DRAWS -- I'D
GROVE [inaudible]
HER TADO.
TITLE II.
LEYVA LEYVA AYE MITCHELL HI
MITCHELL AYE MONNING AYE MONNING
AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
RUBIO I THE BILL HAS EIGHT VOTES --
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU.
OKAY LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER FOUR SB THIRTY NINE
CENTER HELL THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR SB THIRTY NINE WILL IMPOSE
STRICTER AGE VERIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS FOR TOBACCO
PRODUCTS SOLD ONLINE.
OR BY MAIL THE SALE OF TOBACCO
PRODUCTS ONLINE PRESENT
SIGNIFICANT A SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC
HEALTH PROBLEM.
MANY INTERNET TOBACCO VENDORS DO
LITTLE TO VERIFY THE AGE AND
IDENTITY OF THEIR CUSTOMERS
MAKING IT VERY EASY FOR MINORS
TO PURCHASE TOBACCO PRODUCTS.
SEVERAL STUDIES HAVE CONCLUDED
THAT YOU'D HAVE EASY ACCESS TO
TOBACCO PRODUCTS ONLINE CENTER
HELL IF I CAN PLEASE ASK --
PEOPLE TO I KNOW HIM AND STEEP
SOME PEOPLE LEAVING THESE BE
SOUNDS WE CAN HEAR AS
PRESENTATION THANK YOU. ONE SUCH
STUDY THE TALKS ABOUT TOBACCO
SALES AND PRODUCTS ON LINE ONE
STUDY EVEN FOUND THAT MINERS
WERE SUCCESSFUL IN BUYING E.
CIGARETTES ONLINE 93% OF THE
TIME.
AND 95% OF THE CIGARETTE
DELIVERIES WERE SIMPLY LEFT AT
THE DOOR AS AMAZON DOES.
MODEL AFTER STANDARDS FOR
ALCOHOL DELIVERY AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL DOES JUMP A MEMBERS.
SB THIRTY NINE WILL REQUIRE
TOBACCO PRODUCTS TO BE.
ONLY IN CONTAINERS LABELED WITH
THE WORDS CONTAINS TOBACCO
PRODUCTS SIGNATURE OR PERSON
TWENTY ONE YEARS OF AGE OR OLDER
REQUIRED FOR DELIVERY JUST IS
DONE TODAY WITH ALCOHOL.
THE BILL ALSO REQUIRE TOBACCO
VENDORS TO OBTAIN THE SIGNATURE
OF A PERSON TWENTY ONE YEARS OF
AGE OR OLDER BEFORE DELIVERING A
TOBACCO PRODUCT WHILE MY
PREVIOUS BILL SB.
THIRTY EIGHT PROHIBITS THE
RETAIL SALES OF FLAVORED TOBACCO
SB THIRTY NINE TAKES STEPS TO
BLOCK YOUTH ACCESS TO TOBACCO
PRODUCTS VIA ONLINE OR MAIL
DELIVERY BUT I THINK THE
IMPORTANT PART HERE IS IT.
FLAVORED TOBACCO PRODUCTS ARE
STILL AVAILABLE ONLINE.
RIGHT NOW IT IS FAR TOO EASY FOR
USED TO BUY TOBACCO ONLINE THIS
BILL ESTABLISHES A BASELINE
PROTECTIONS THAT ARE ALREADY IN
PLACE FOR ALCOHOL AND OTHER
PRODUCTS.
WE HAVE A COUPLE OF WHAT
WONDERFUL WITNESSES TO SUPPORT
THANK YOU MET MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU CENTER HELLO WITNESSES
SUPPORT.
HELLO MY NAME IS THE SALUTE AND
I'M THE FOUNDER AND PRESIDENT OF
INTERNATIONAL USE TOBACCO
CONTROL.
WHICH IS A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION COMPRISED OF TWO
HUNDRED HIGH SCHOOLERS IN THE US.
CANADA.
CHINA PAKISTAN AND SAUDI ARABIA.
WE SEEK TO PREVENT TEENAGE
DOUBLE SMOKING GLOBALLY THROUGH
LEGISLATIVE REFORM AND
EDUCATIONAL AWARENESS AND READY
REACHED THREE THOUSAND YOUTH
INTERNATIONALLY.
SO IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
INTERNATIONAL USED TOBACCO
CONTROL SURVEY TO FIVE EIGHT
HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN STUDENTS
GLOBALLY AND WE FOUND A TEENAGE
SMOKING RATE OF 12%.
WHICH IS MORE THAN TWICE THE
AMOUNT IN CALIFORNIA.
SO WHY IS THERE'S A SIGNATURE
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE ONE IS
BECAUSE OF LEGISLATION IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE THE LEGAL
SMOKING AGE TO BE TWENTY ONE
YEARS OLD.
SECOND IS BECAUSE OF REGULATION
BECAUSE THE ID CARD NEEDS T BE
CHECKED FOR EVERY TOBACCO
PURCHASE.
ALLOWS THESE EDUCATION WITH ALL
HIGH SCHOOLERS BEING REQUIRED TO
TAKE A HEALTH CLASS IN HIGH
SCHOOL.
HOWEVER OVER THE YEARS THESE THE
SAFETY NET THAT WE CREATED FOR
TEENAGERS HAVE BEEN BREACHED.
BY THE IN ADEQUATE REGULATION ON
THE ONLINE TOBACCO SALES.
WE'RE GOING TO A. B. C. NEWS WE
SEE.
CHILDREN LIKE FOURTEEN YEAR OLD
BORING JACOBSEN BEING ABLE TO
PURCHASE 50% OF HER ONLINE
TOBACCO ORDER WE ALSO SEE KIDS
LIKE A YEAR OLD IN NIKO WHO IS
ABLE TO RECEIVE THREE CARTONS OF
REGION YEAH LIGHT AFTER HIS
ONLINE PURCHASE.
AND EVEN SEVEN YOUR JOEY WHO
ACTUALLY ENTERED HIS BILL
BIRTHDAY ONTO HIS ONLINE
PURCHASE.
BUT WAS STILL DELIVERED A
TOBACCO PACKAGE IN THE NEXT FEW
DAYS ARTS PORSCHE.
THESE ARE CHILDREN THESE ARE
CHILDREN WHO ARE CURIOUS THESE
ARE CHILDREN WHO DON'T KNOW
ABOUT THE MANIPULATION OF THE
BIG TOBACCO INDUSTRY THESE ARE
CHILDREN BECOME EASILY ADDICTED.
TO THESE PRODUCTS FOR THE BECOME
BY ONLINE.
SO IT'S TIME THAT CALIFORNIA'S
STEP UP AGAINST THIS ONLINE MISS
REGULATION.
AND WITH.
WITH BEING ABLE TO REINFORCE OUR
LEGISLATION REGULATION EDUCATION
WITH BILL FOR SB THIRTY NINE WE
CAN SEE STRICTER REGULATION.
THROUGH STRICTER LEGISLATION ON
THE ONLINE TOBACCO AGE
VERIFICATION AS WELL AS
INCREASING THE PARENTAL
SUPERVISION AND PREVENTING
SMOKING BEFORE YOU EVEN START.
SO TODAY ON ON BEHALF OF
INTERNATIONAL USED TOBACCO
CONTROL ON BEHALF OF ALL THE
TEENAGERS WERE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THE CALIFORNIA SENATE.
TO PASS SB THIRTY NINE FOR THE
CHILDREN FOR TEENAGERS AND FOR
THE FUTURE OF AMERICA.
GOOD AFTERNOON TERRY MEMBERS AND
THE RATE IS AT THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION IN CALIFORNIA ONE OF
THE PROUD CO SPONSORS OF THIS
BILL IT'S A COMMON SENSE MEASURE
THAT PUTS AB PROTECTIONS IN
PLACE FOR YOU THAT WE HAVE FOR
OTHER.
PRODUCTS AND WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE AND HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES
SUPPORT BACK MY PHONE. TO MED
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
CARDIOLOGY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
VIDEO BORN REPRESENTING AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA
DIVISION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THAT RECORD OVER THE CALIFORNIA
DENTAL ASSOCIATION WE ARE ALSO
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JESSICA RAN ON HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT YOU.
BUT SAM SUNG WITH THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA'S LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IN TERMS PARK
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS FRANKLY CHIANG I'M
WITH INTERNATIONAL YOUTH TOBACCO
CONTROL ORGANIZATION I TEND
LISTA HIGH SCHOOL IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY NINE FOUR SUPPORT US SB
THIRTY NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SERGEANT CHOI I'M WITH
INTERNATIONAL YOUTH HAVE A
CONTROL AND I GO TO SAN MARINO
HIGH SCHOOL IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND I'M IS A FULL SUPPORT
OF THIS.
BILL THANK YOU.
NAME IS TWENTY LIEU AND I'M WITH
INTERNATIONAL YOU TO BACK
CONTROL AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS KATHY SON I'M A
MEMBER OF INTERNATIONAL USE
TOBACCO CONTROLS IN ADDITION A
TEN TEMPLE CITY HIGH SCHOOL IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
AS THE FOLEY SUPPORT OFF SB
THIRTY NINE THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M AIR STYLES SAYING AND
I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
INTERNATIONAL USED TO WALK
CONTROL AND I AM A STUDENT FROM
SAN MARINO HIGH SCHOOL OF THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
AND I ALSO SUPPORT SB THIRTY
NINE THANK YOU. TEN GIVES
AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY CANCER
ACTION NETWORK PROUD BECAUSE
SPONSOR THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION THANK YOU.
CHENEY MORGAN WITH THE AMERICAN
HEART ASSOCIATION ALSO AM PROUD
BECAUSE SPONSORED BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
AT THE MOST WORK ON BEHALF OF
THE PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE AND
THE SIERRA CLUB WHOSE ADVOCATE
HAD TO LEAVE INSTRUCTS.
BIRD HARRISON THE HALF BREED THE
LA AND THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
ADDICTION MEDICINE IN SMART
THANK YOU.
BRANDON MARGIE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CHRISTINE CHESSEN WITH PAVE
PARENTS AGAINST VAPING AN INS E.
CIGARETTES IN STRONG SUPPORT YOU.
MY NAME IS ABIGAIL CLOVER I A
ATTEND WEST VALLEY HIGH SCHOOL
AND I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTY NINE THANK YOU.
NICOLE OVER MOTHER OF ABIGAIL
CULVER UNKNOWN COLOR TO
TEENAGERS AND FULL SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
KATHY HALL FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PTA IN SUPPORT IF --
MICHAEL RIGHT AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA
CLARA COUNTY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
DR BONNIE HELP VULTURE
PROFESSORS UNIVERSITY AND
FOUNDER EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
TOBACCO PREVENTION TOKEN IN
STRONG SUPPORT I KEEP.
NICOLE BARKER SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER AND MOTHER OF TWO
TEENAGERS IN THIS VERY STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
TAYLOR BARKER AT THE ATHLETES
UPDATE IN FULL SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
RENDON HARD FROM WHATEVER HIGH
SCHOOL IN FULL SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HE AMBER SO I TEND TO THE WAY
SCHOOL AND I'M FULL SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
LEE PACE FROM UNIVERSITY
PREPARATORY SCHOOL I AM FULL
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANY SANTIAGO EMINEM ONCOLOGY ARE
IN AND I'M IN FULL SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THEY MARIN FULLY I GOTTA CREEK
COTTONWOOD CREATURES GO NAMES IN
FULL SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
AMY FOLEY A MOTHER OF THREE
CHILDREN AND FULL SUPPORT OF
THIRTY NINE THANK YOU.
HI SONYA KENNEDY MOTHER OF A
TWELVE YEAR OLD ATHLETE THAT
BEEPS AND FOUNDER OF ATHLETES
DON'T PAID IN FULL SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
ABIGAIL CIRCLE I ATTEND REBEL
HIGH SCHOOL AND I FULLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS RAYMOND STERN I
ATTEND WES I HIGH SCHOOL AND I
FULLY SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS BAD I GUESS DINNER I
ATTENDED BOTH HIGH SCHOOL AND I
FULLY SUPPORT YOU.
MY NAME IS KLAY BAILEY I ATTEND
AT PARTICULAR MIDDLE SCHOOL AND
I FULLY SUPPORT YOU.
MY NAME IS AUSTIN BURKE I ATTEND
WEST VALLEY I TEND WEST COTTON
WOULD SCHOOL AND I FULLY SUPPORT
SB.
THIRTY NINE THANK YOU.
I'M HERE WE BURKE I ATTEND
WESCOTT WITH JUNIOR HIGH AND I
FULLY SUPPORT YOU.
RED TO MILAN TO A PHYSICAL
EDUCATION TEACHER AT BUCKEYE
SCHOOL THE ADS IN REDDING I
FULLY SUPPORT SB.
THIRTY NINE EIGHTY MY NAME IS
MARLEY MAN I TEND WHAT MORE
UNION ELEMENTARY SCHOOL AND
FULLY SUPPORT HIM.
MY NAME'S MARIE MOON I'M A
PARENT AND A REGISTERED NURSE
AND I SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ABBY BURLESON I
ATTEND BRENDA'S MIDDLE SCHOOL
AND I CAME IN SUPPORT OF SB.
THIRTY NINE THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S TERRA BOBBY I SHALL I
GO UNIVERSITY PREPARATORY SCHOOL
AND I AM FULL SUPPORT.
ARE YOU.
HI MY NAME IS HALEY AUSTIN IRIS
CLAIM MIDDLE SCHOOL AND I FULLY
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS KELLY HARPER I GO TO
ANDERSON HIGH SCHOOL AND I
SUPPORT.
YOU.
MY NAME IS THEIR TONGANS AYE TEN
FOOT HIGH SCHOOL AND I FULLY
SUPPORT SB.
THIRTY NINE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS WRITER MEGA
DISAGREEMENTS SCORNFULLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S LAMINITIS AS MIDDLE
SCHOOL AND I FULLY SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MY NAME'S ALEXIS JAMES AGO
CHAVEZ GOING TO FULLY SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S OLIVIA NORMAN I GOT
ACCESS TO HIGH SCHOOL I FULLY
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ALEC YOU ARE GOING TO
ESTES MIDDLE SCHOOL AND I FULLY
SUPPORT.
YOU.
MY NAME'S LOIS ONCE AND I GO TO
SHASTA I'M.
SCHOOL ASSEMBLY SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MY NAME'S ON THE LOW I GOT A
SHASTA HIGH SCHOOL AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S COSTA MORRISON I A
ATTENDS CON WITH CREEK CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I FULLY SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MY NAME'S KENDALL TOMLINSON I GO
TO UNIVERSITY PREPARATORY SCHOOL
AND I FULLY SUPPORT YOU.
MY NAME'S LISTENER AS I ATTEND
ANDERSON HAS GONE I SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ANGELINA WOODWARD I
GO TO UNIVERSITY PREPARATORY
SCHOOL AND I FULLY SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS KATHY DENNY I GO TO
WEST CURRENTLY JUNIOR HIGH
SCHOOL AND I FULLY SUPPORT THANK
YOU [inaudible]
FOR MY NAY.
MY NAME IS ANASTASIA HARTMAN.
AND I GO TO CALVARY CHRISTIAN
ACADEMY AND I FULLY SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SLATED TO WANT TO GO
TO BUCK I SCHOOL THEY ARE TODAY
FOR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS COREY DINNER I'M A
MOTHER OF FOUR AND A SCHOOL
COUNSELOR AND I SALUTE FULLY
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S KERA MONICA MARINE A
TENDER IN HIGH SCHOOL AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT [inaudible]
YOU.
MY NAME IS NICK RODRIGUEZ I
ATTEND INSPIRE HIGH SCHOOL OF
ARTS AND SCIENCES AND I FULLY
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ANDY PATEL A ATTEND
GOOD UNION HIGH SCHOOL AND FULLY
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
I NAMES TO BE TO PATEL I TEND TO
GO HIGH SCHOOL AND I FULLY
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SEEN OTHER PEOPLE THE
MICROPHONE ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
COMMA.
I GUESS YOU SEE THERE THAT'S
RIGHT MAKE ROOM OVER THERE
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS -- JAMES
TRACK HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CIGAR ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA --
BRIEFLY. FOR THE CIGAR INDUSTRY
IN PARTICULAR -- MAIL ORDER
SHIPMENTS ARE IMPORTANT BECAUSE
THERE ARE LITERALLY THOUSANDS OF
CIGAR AND PIPE TOBACCO BRANDS
SIZES -- AVAILABLE TO CONSUMERS --
MOST CONVENIENCE STORES DO NOT
CARRY PREMIUM CIGARS -- IN EVEN
SPECIALTY RETAIL TOBACCONIST --
ONLY HAVE THE ABILITY TO CARRY A
SMALL FRACTION OF THE OVERALL
UNIVERSE OF AVAILABLE PRODUCTS --
SO ORDERING BY MAIL OR VIA THE
INTERNET IS OFTEN THE ONLY WAY
CONSUMERS ARE ABLE TO PURCHASE --
THE SPECIFIC TYPE OF PREMIUM
CIGARS THEY SEEK -- THE AUTHOR
STATED THAT THE BILL IS MODELED
AFTER ALCOHOL DELIVERY
REQUIREMENTS WHICH ALREADY
REQUIRE -- ADULT SIGNATURE UPON
DELIVERY -- AND AND WE
UNDERSTAND THAT -- CAN PRESHEAF
THE AUTHOR'S GOAL HERE THE BILL
DIFFERS FROM ALCOHOL DELIVERY IN
JUST ONE KEY RESPECT -- AND I'LL
CALL CUSTOMER CAN DESIGNATE A
DELIVERY ADDRESS -- THAT IS WELL
LET ME START THE VAST MAJORITY
OF DELIVERIES ARE MADE A PARTIAL
DELIVERIES ARE MADE DURING
NORMAL BUSINESS HOURS WHEN
CONSUMERS ARE NOT HOME TO SIGN
FOR THEIR PACKAGES.
SO NOW CALL CUSTOMER CAN
DESIGNATE AN ALTERNATE ADDRESS
FOR DELIVERY SUCH AS THEIR PLACE
OF EMPLOYMENT -- WHERE THEY
WOULD BE ABLE TO SIGN FOR A
PARCEL DURING REGULAR BUSINESS
HOURS -- THIS BILL -- LEAST AS
WRITTEN NOW -- DOES NOT PROVIDE
THAT REQUIREMENT SO IF -- A
CUSTOMER WAS ON THE WAS NOT AT
HOME TO RECEIVE THE SHIPMENT IT
WAS NOT DELIVERED IT WOULD JUST
GET SENT BACK -- AND SO WE WE
ARE OPPOSED FOR THAT REASON BUT
I HOPE TO BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR ON THAT.
THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU.
OKAY ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SAY NINE QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SCENE NINE UP SO -- THIS CENTER
HILL -- SOUNDS LIKE A SO CAN YOU
DRESS THE OPPOSITION CONCERNS I
MEAN IT'S I THINK GIVEN THE
TENSE OF YOUR BILL WHICH IS TO
BE SURE THAT AT THE DAHLE
RECEIVES THE PRODUCT RIGHT AND
ACCEPTS THE PRODUCT -- THAT.
DIDN'T SEEM UNREASONABLE AND
SOMEONE WHO YOU KNOW DOESN'T TO
THRILLED ABOUT GETTING TOBACCO
IN PEOPLE'S HANDS BUT STILL AS
AN UNREASONABLE TO HAVE BILL TO
DESIGNATE A AN ALTERNATE
LOCATION WHERE SOMEONE'S SO I
WOULD YOU TO DO SO I I AGREE
WITH YOU MISTER CHAIR AND AND
WE'LL WORK.
WITH MISTER JACK I THINK THAT
THERE IS SOME WAY TO TO MAKE
THAT HAPPEN IN IN THE INTENT IS
THERE AND CERTAINLY THE AGE
VERIFICATION IS THE KEY.
AND HOW WE CAN MAKE THAT WORK WE
HAPPY TO WORK WITH THIS PROJECT
THANK YOU AS I AID FROM YOUR
TEST MANDER STANDARD THAT WOULD
SATISFY YOUR CONCERNS.
OKAY ALL RIGHT OKAY AND YOU CAN
LOOK AT THE AUTHOR ON ON THAT
OKAY ANY OTHER QUESTIONS THEN.
I SEE NO THE QUESTIONS OF WAS
THERE A MOTION ON THE BILL IT'S
A MOTION MOVED BY CENTER MINING
I WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE CENTER
HELLO YES OR NO VOTE MEMBERS
THANK YOU THING THANK YOU FOR
INDULGENCE TODAY.
OKAY SO IT'S BEEN TAKEN BY
CENTER MINING -- THE MOTION IS
TO PASS APPROPRIATIONS AS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AND I AND I STONE.
STONE I DORADO.
GROVE.
GROVE EYED HER TADO.
HER TOTAL I'D LEYVA.
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING AYE AYE
MONNING AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
RUBIO.
OKAY THE BILL HAS SEVEN VOTES
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THAT'S ENOUGH TO
GET IT OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
VERY MUCH MEMBERS THANK YOU --
OKAY HI I GUESS -- SINCE THE
FIFTH CENTER BRADFORD'S OFFICE
WHEN WAY IT LET HIM KNOW THAT --
HE'S OPTIONS THERE BUT SINCE --
CENTER MONEY USE HERE THOUGH AND
CENTER MINING WHICH LIKE PERCENT
YOUR BILL ITEM NUMBER -- SEVEN
SB.
THREE FORTY SEVEN WOULD YOU MIND
OPENING THE ROLE FROM THE ATKINS
BILL RIGHT QUICK PLEASE -- THANK
YOU MISS MITCHELL BUT WOULD YOU
OPEN THE ROLE IN THE ATKINS BILL
RIGHT FAST SURE MR MON OKAY
ACTION IS -- CENTER MONEY IS
MOVING TO THE PODIUM --
SECRETARY THAT'S WHAT'S IF YOU
DON'T MIND WE'LL JUST QUICKLY --
GO THROUGH THE AT YEP IF YOU
WHAT LET'S GO THROUGH ALL OF
THEM THAT WE HAVE ANY RIGHT NOW
SO -- SO SECRETARY -- SO IT'S
ITEM NUMBER SO WE TO OPEN THE
ROLE FOR ABSENT MEMBERS --
STARTING WITH ITEM NUMBER.
THREE OKAY ITEM NUMBER THREE SB
THIRTY EIGHT SIX EIGHT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THAT SOME MEMBERS.
GROWTH.
GROVE NO OKAY SO THAT BILL IS
NOW OUT.
EIGHT ONE NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER FOUR SB -- THIRTY NINE
CENTER -- HILLS BILL US A GROUP
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
TORONTO [inaudible]
LEYVA.
OKAY SO WE'LL KEEP THAT BILL --
ON HOLD.
ON CALL -- AND AND AND I ITEM
NUMBER FIVE SB ONE SIXTY FIVE A
CENTER ATKINS SAYS A GROUP
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT
MEMBERS.
ARE TADO.
HER TITLE I'M MITCHELL HI
MITCHELL I THAT BILLS OUT.
NINE ZERO OKAY SO WITH THAT
LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN THE CEREMONY WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
I'M HERE AGAIN TODAY BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA REMAINS IN CRISIS.
A CRISIS THAT IS IMPACTED EACH
AND EVERYONE OF OUR DISTRICTS
AND THAT ARE SHOWN NO SIGNS OF
RELENTING.
THE EPIDEMIC OF SKYROCKETING
RATES OF OBESITY AND PREVENTABLE
TYPE TWO DIABETES CONTINUES TO
WREAK HAVOC.
ON THE HEALTH AND HAPPINESS OF
OUR CONSTITUENTS IN BURDENS OUR
STATE WITH BILLIONS IN HEALTH
CARE COSTS RELATED TO THE
TREATMENT OF THESE CHRONIC
PREVENTABLE DISEASES.
OVER THE LAST DECADE AN
AVALANCHE OF PUBLIC HEALTH
RESEARCH HAS DEFINITIVELY
CONCLUDED THAT THE MAIN DRIVER
BEHIND THE GROWTH OF THESE
PREVENTABLE HEALTH CONDITIONS.
IS THE INCREASED CONSUMPTION OF
SUGAR SWEETENED BEVERAGES.
SUGAR DRINKS ARE THE SINGLE
LARGEST SOURCE OF ADDED SUGARS
IN THE AMERICAN DIET.
IN ARE A MAJOR SOURCE OF EXCESS
CALORIES THAT OFTEN PROVIDE NO
NUTRITIONAL VALUE.
STUDIES SHOW THAT DRINKING JUST
ONE SUGARY DRINK A DAY INCREASES
IN ADULTS LIKELIHOOD OF BEING
OVER WEIGHT BY 27% AND A CHILD'S
BY 55%.
LAST YEAR WHEN THIS COMMITTEE
PASSED A SIMILAR VERSION OF THIS
BILL.
THE OPPOSITION ARGUED THAT
CONSUMER EDUCATION WHAT'S THE
BEST STRATEGY TO PREVENT OVER
CONSUMPTION OF SUGARY DRINKS.
I WHOLEHEARTEDLY AGREE.
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT SENATE
BILL THREE FORTY SEVEN DOES THIS
BILL INFORMS CHOICE.
THIS BILL WILL EMPOWER CONSUMERS
TO MAKE INFORMED CHOICES ABOUT
THE BEVERAGES THEY PURCHASE BY
REQUIRING A SCIENCE BASED HEALTH
WARNING LABEL TO BE PLACED ON
SUGARY BEVERAGES.
THAT ARE SOLD IN CALIFORNIA IN
THE CONTAINS SEVENTY FIVE
CALORIES OR MORE PER TWELVE
FLUID OUNCES OF SUGAR.
WARNING LABELS ARE PROVEN AND
EFFECTIVE MEANS OF INFLUENCING
CONSUMER BEHAVIOR NEVER BEEN
USED SUCCESSFULLY.
ON TOBACCO AND ALCOHOL PRODUCTS
FOR DECADES.
A RECENT STUDY BY THE RED CENTER
WHICH IS REFERENCED IN THE
COMMITTEES ANALYSIS FOUND THAT
DECEPTIVELY BILLING DIRECTLY
IMPACTED A PARENT'SPERCEPTION
OF BEVERAGES.
LEADING MANY TO INCORRECTLY
BELIEVE THAT SUGARY DRINKS
LABELED AS FRUIT DRINKS AND
SPORTS TEAS WERE HEALTHIER
OPTIONS FOR THEIR CHILDREN.
WARNING LABELS ARE AN IMPORTANT
PART OF A BROAD PUBLIC HEALTH
CAMPAIGN TO COUNTER THESE
DECEPTIVE MARKETING STRATEGIES
AND HELP CONSUMERS MAKE AN
INFORMED CHOICE ABOUT THE KNOWN
ADVERSE HEALTH IMPACTS.
OF SUGARY DRINKS. ONE IN THREE
CHILDREN BORN AFTER THE YEAR TWO
THOUSAND IS PREDICTED TO DEVELOP
TYPE TWO DIABETES DURING HIS OR
HER LIFETIME.
AND THAT NUMBER JUMPS TO ONE
INTO FOR LATINO AND AFRICAN
AMERICAN CHILDREN.
ASKS THAT YOU JOIN ME IN THE
ENTIRE MEDICAL AND PUBLIC HEALTH
COMMUNITY AND TAKING A BOLD STEP.
TOWARD PREVENTING THAT STATISTIC
FROM BECOMING TRUE IN CALIFORNIA.
SENATE BILL THREE FORTY SEVEN
WILL PROMOTE INFORMED CONSUMER
CHOICE AND WILL LEAD TO BETTER
HEALTH OUTCOMES FOR THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA.
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
IN MISTER CHAIR I'D LIKE TO
PRESENT. TO WITNESSES -- IN
SUPPORT.
DOCTOR CROW FOR WITH SENIORS THE
SENIOR DIRECTOR POLICY OF PUBLIC
HEALTH ADVOCATES IN TONY KALI
PAIRING LIFESTYLE COACH FOR
DIABETES PREVENTION PROGRAM
THANK YOU I THANK YOU WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS DOCTOR FLOWS ON CO FOR AND I
AM THE SENIOR DIRECTOR OF POLICY
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATES.
TOGETHER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BLACK HEALTH NETWORK IN THE
LATINO COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA WE ARE PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR SB THREE FORTY SEVEN TO
PLACE HEALTH WARNING LABELS ON
SUGARY DRINKS.
THE FINANCE ABOUT THE LINK
BETWEEN SUGARY DRINKS AND HEALTH
OUTCOMES IS INCONTROVERTIBLE SO
THE INDUSTRY HAS CENTER THEIR
OPPOSITION AROUND SEVERAL EASILY
REPEATABLE ARGUMENTS WHICH I
WILL.
ARGUMENT NUMBER ONE WARNING
LABELS DO NOT WORK SIMPLY STATED
THIS IS FALSE ACCORDING TO A
STUDY PUBLISHED IN PEDIATRICS IN
FEBRUARY TWENTY SIXTEEN WARNING
LABELS ARE THREE TIMES.
MORE EFFECTIVE THAN THE BEVERAGE
INDUSTRIES CLEAR ON CALORIE
LABELS IN HELPING PARENTS CHOOSE
A DRINK WITHOUT ADDED SUGAR.
WARNING LABELS ALSO HELP
CUSTOMERS DISTINGUISH BETWEEN
PRODUCTS THAT ARE A 100% FRUIT
JUICE AND FRUIT FLAVORED DRINKS
WITH ADDED SUGAR WHICH ARE OFTEN
DIFFICULT TO DISTINGUISH. FOR
THIS REASON THREE QUARTERS OF
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS SUPPORT
WARNING LABELS WITH EVEN HIGHER
SUPPORT AMONG BLACK AND LATINO
RESIDENTS.
ARGUMENT NUMBER TWO IS THAT
WARNING LABELS KILL JOBS.
THIS BILL DOESN'T CHANGE THE
COST OF PRODUCTS OR RESTRICT
THEIR SALE IN ANYWAY BUT NO
LEGISLATION WILL STOP PEOPLE
FROM BEING THIRSTY.
DATA FROM BERKELEY SHOWS THE
AFTER THEIR THEIR SUGARY DRINK
TAX WAS ENACTED NO IT JOBS WERE
LOST BECAUSE PEOPLE STILL BOUGHT
DRINKS THEY JUST SHIFTED TO
LOWER CALORIE DRINKS.
THE SAME PATTERN CAN BE EXPECTED
FOR WARNING LABELS ADDITIONALLY
THE PENALTIES FOR VIOLATING THIS
NEW ARE MINIMAL A FIRST
VIOLATION IN KERR'S NO FEE AND
SIMPLY A WARNING.
AND SUBSEQUENT VIOLATIONS ARE
FIFTY TO FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
THE CALLING THIS BILL A JOB
KILLER IS A BASELESS ASSERTION.
ARGUMENT NUMBER THREE THE SAN
FRANCISCO WARNING LABELS
OVERTURNED.
THE PANEL DID RULING IN --
AGAINST THE SAN FRANCISCO
WARNING LABEL BUT ONLY BECAUSE
THEY FELT THAT THE 20% FIVE
REQUIREMENT WAS LARGER THAN
NECESSARY.
SEPARATELY JUDGES OPINED ABOUT
THE WORDING OF THE LABEL. TO BE
CLEAR THE RULING EXPRESSLY DID
NOT ADDRESS WHETHER SMALLER
WARNING LABELS ARE SIMILARLY
OBJECTIONABLE OR IF THE TEXT OF
THE WARNING IS PURELY FACTUAL IN
UNCONTROVERSIAL.
SB THREE FORTY SEVEN ADDRESSES
THE RULING AND THE JUDGE'S
OPINION THAT IT DOES NOT SPECIFY
A MINIMUM SIZE FOR THE LABEL
ONLY A MINIMUM SIZE FOR THE
FIGHT TO ENSURE LEGIBILITY.
AND ALSO WE USE THAT THE JUDGES
RECOMMEND RECOMMENDED PHRASES OF
TYPE TWO DIABETES AND MAY
CONTRIBUTE.
AN ARGUMENT NUMBER FOUR THE FDA
SAYS THAT SUGAR IS SAFE.
THE FDA SAYS THAT SUGAR IS SAFE
EXCEPT WHEN CONSUMED IN EXCESS
AMOUNTS SB THREE FORTY SEVEN
TARGETS HIGH CALORIE DRINKS
THOSE WITH ADDED SUGAR AND MORE
THAN SEVENTY FIVE CALORIES PER
TWELVE OUNCE.
THE EXCESS AMOUNTS THAT ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH AN INCREASED
RISK OF DISEASE.
AN OP ED THE AMERICAN BEVERAGE
ASSOCIATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
GROCERS ASSOCIATION HAVE STATED
AND I QUOTE WE SHOULD WORK
TOGETHER GOVERNMENT INDUSTRY AND
THE PUBLIC HEALTH COMMUNITY TO
EDUCATE CONSUMERS AND EMPOWER
THEM TO MAKE CHOICES THAT ARE
BEST FOR THEM AND THEIR FAMILIES.
SB THREE FORTY SEVEN IS THE
POLICY ANSWER TO THIS PLATITUDE.
GIVE CONSUMERS THE INFORMATION
SO THEY CAN MAKE AN INFORMED
DECISION ON WHAT TO DRINK.
THERE IS A DISCONNECT BETWEEN
THEIR TALKING POINTS AND
CONTINUED OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL AND OTHER BILLS THAT HELP
CONSUMERS MAKE HEALTHY CHOICES
LAST YEAR THE NEGOTIATED A
TWELVE YEAR STATEWIDE
PROHIBITION ON LOCAL TAXES.
IF THEY REFUSE TO PAY FOR THE
DISEASES THEY COST AT THE VERY
LEAST WE SHOULD MAKE THEM TELL
CONSUMERS THE TRUTH.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT WHOSE
INTEREST WE VALUE MOST CONSUMERS
HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW THIS
INFORMATION THEY WANT TO KNOW
THIS INFORMATION AND THE
INDUSTRY DOESN'T HAVE A FACTUAL
OR CONSISTENT ARGUMENT AGAINST
SUPPLYING THIS INFORMATION. FOR
THESE REASONS I ENCOURAGE YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SHE LETS YOU ABOUT TWO
MINUTES AND TEN SECONDS.
WELL LET ME IS IT ON BECAUSE
YOUR LET ME JUST THANK THE
SENATE BECAUSE YOU SORT PORTED
MY WORK IN THE PAST.
WITH YES THE COLLEGE OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMEN'S HEALTH LEGACY.
AND IN TWENTY FIFTEEN YOU VOTED
A RESOLUTION TO SUPPORT OUR
EDUCATING THE COMMUNITY ABOUT
SOME OF THE RISK FACTORS THAT
AFFECTING OUR PEOPLE.
SETTLE ON MY NAME IS TONY KALI
PERRY AND I AM HERE TO SUPPORT
SB THREE FORTY SEVEN TO PUT
HEALTH WARNING LABELS ON SUGARY
DRINKS.
OBD EARLY THIS MORNING I WAS
TEACHING FIFTH GRADERS AND I
ASKED THEM WHAT DO THEY THINK
ABOUT IT YOU KNOW THERE I GO FOR
IT THE THEY REALLY ONCE YOU RE
DRINKS AND IT SHOWED ME.
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS THAT THEY
HAVE THIS HAPPENING SO THE
PARENTS CAN ACTUALLY HELP THEM
[inaudible]
SO -- I'M GONNA READ MY TALKING
POINTS I CAN STICK VERY CLOSE TO
THE MINUTES -- IN NOVEMBER I WAS
TRAINED AS A LIFESTYLE COACH FOR
THE DIABETES PREVENTION PROGRAM.
KNOWN AS DPP DPP IS A YEAR LONG
PREVENTION PROGRAM FOR PEOPLE
WHO HAVE.
PRE DIABETES HIGH BLOOD.
SUGAR THAT PUTS THEM AT RISK OF
DIABETES ALMOST HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIANS 446% HAVE PRE
DIABETES I'M ONE OF THEM I HAVE.
MY DIABETES RATING IS I THINK
IT'S SIX POINT ONE SIX POINT
SEVEN WHICH IS.
ODD TECHNICALLY A DIABETIC -- IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN BUDGET THE
BUDGET LEGISLATOR MADE THE PPO
FULLY FUNDED PROGRAM FOR MEDI
CAL.
DPP HELPS PARTICIPANTS MAKE
LIFESTYLE CHANGES TO ADDRESS
STRESS DIET AND EXERCISE.
THE GOAL OF THE PROGRAM IS AT
LEAST 5% WEIGHT LOSS AND ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES FOR EVERY ANYONE
TRYING TO REDUCE THE RISK OF
DIABETES OR MANAGE THEIR
DIABETES IS TO CORRECTLY
CHOOSING.
HEALTHY FOODS AND BEVERAGES
OPTIONS.
NUTRITION LABELS ARE DIFFICULT
TO READ AND UNDERSTAND FOR MOST
PEOPLE KNOWING WHICH PRODUCTS
HAVE ADDED SUGAR IS ESPECIALLY
HELPFUL IN IDENTIFYING LOWER
SUGAR PRODUCTS.
THAT ARE BETTER FOR HEALTH THE
WARNING LABELS WOULD.
IT IT.
LET ME THE WARNING LABELS WHAT
IT EASIER WELL I DON'T THINK
THAT'S QUITE RIGHT.
LET ME JUST SAY THIS IF THE
WARNING LABELS WITH THEIR PEOPLE
WOULD CHOOSE HIGH HELP YOUR
TOUCH -- OPTIONS.
BEING ABLE TO TEACH PEOPLE
ATTENDING THE DPP SESSIONS TO
LOOK.
FOR THE ICON IN LIMIT DRINKS
THAT HAVE IT WOULD BE A GREAT
TOOL.
MANY DATE PP PARTICIPANTS
STRUGGLE TO LOSE WEIGHT.
BECAUSE THEY FOCUS ON EATING
FEWER CALORIES BUT DON'T REALIZE
HOW MANY CALORIES AND HOW MUCH
SUGAR IN THEIR DRINKS.
SB THREE FOUR SEVEN WILL HELP
ALL CALIFORNIANS KNOW WHICH
DRINKS HAVE ADDED SUGAR.
AND IT ESPECIALLY HELPFUL FOR
PEOPLE WITH DIABETES AND PRE
DIABETES TO LIMIT THEIR LARGEST
SOURCE OF DIETARY SUGAR DRINKS.
SERVICE RISEN WRAP UP.
I THINK I CAN DO IT IN THREE
WORDS.
ARE FOR THESE REASONS I'D ASK
FOR YOU TO VOTE IN FAVOR OF SB --
THREE FORTY SEVEN OKAY THANK YOU
GOT IT.
PURPOSE OF FAIRNESS IF THE
OPPOSITION NEEDS OF OUR TIME
WHAT TO GIVE THE SAME OUTSIDE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OTHER WITNESSES SUPPORT BACK
BACK FROM THAT C. ARMSTRONG ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION AND FROM
SUPPORT.
CAT TO WORK WITH THE HEALTH
OFFICER'S ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THE RECORD WELL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MARKETS GOT THE WHOLE THE
CALIFORNIA PEN AT THE CALVET
WORKING SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I MEAN AGAIN.
CALIFORNIA BLACK HEALTH NETWORK
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
EVAN QUARTER ON BEHALF THE CMA
IN SUPPORT KEEP.
JESSICA RAN HAVE ACCESS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
JAMIE MORGAN WITH THE AMERICAN
HEART ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
VIDEO BOARD REPRESENTING BOTH
THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS AS WELL AS CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL NURSES WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SHARE GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN DIABETES ASSOCIATION
AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HE WON JONG ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ALLIANCE OF
YMCAS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CUT THE MUSTARD ON BEHALF OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
A BIGGER MESS WITH THE LEADING A
COALITION FOR HEALTHY CALIFORNIA
ALSO COSPONSORED STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU -- MICHAEL RIGHT AGAIN
ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS SANTA CLARA COUNTY
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. TO MADDEN
RIPS IN THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
CARDIOLOGY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
RIGHT.
AS A NO THE PEOPLE TO WAKE PHONE --
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
IF YOU CAN ALLOW THEM.
TO SOLO ALLOW YOU UP TO SIX AND
A HALF MINUTES ALTHOUGH AGAIN
YOU DON'T HAVE TO USE ALL THE
TIME IF YOU DON'T WISH TO JUST
[inaudible]
BUT WELCOME.
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR IN THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CARELL COOK
AND I REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE OPPOSED
TO SB.
THREE FORTY SEVEN CMT REPRESENTS
FOUR HUNDRED MANUFACTURING
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA SECTOR
THAT GENERATES MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY BILLION DOLLARS
EVERY YEAR TO CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY AND EMPLOYS MORE THAN
ONE POINT THREE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS.
CALIFORNIA'S BEVERAGE
MANUFACTURING INDUSTRY EMPLOYS
OVER TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND OF
THOSE EMPLOYEES AND PRODUCES
TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS.
TOWARD THE STATE'S ECONOMY SEEM
TO SUPPORT SCIENCE BASED
REGULATIONS THAT MAKE SENSE AND
DO NOT PUT CALIFORNIA'S
MANUFACTURING INDUSTRY AT A
DISADVANTAGE.
REGRETFULLY SB THREE FORTY SEVEN
DOES NOT MEET THAT STANDARD
BECAUSE IT IS A STATE SPECIFIC
LABELING LAW FOR A SUBSET OF
FOOD AND BEVERAGE PRODUCTS AND
IT PUTS CALIFORNIA'S AT A
DISADVANTAGE IN FURTHER EXPOSE
THOSE MANUFACTURERS.
THEIR DISTRIBUTORS AND RETAILERS
TO LIABILITY -- FIRST IT SHOULD
BE NOTED THAT BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS ARE ALREADY REGULATED
BY THE FDA CONTAIN FACTUAL
NUTRITION DETAILS TO PROPERLY
INFORM CONSUMER CHOICE SUGAR
CONTENTIS CLEAR.
AND LESS CONFUSING THAN THE
SCHEME THAT THIS LABEL WOULD
CREATE -- BUT STATE SPECIFIC
LABEL IN ADDITION TO CREATING
THIS CONFUSION FOR THE CONSUMER
BECAUSE ADDITIONAL BURDENS FOR
MANUFACTURERS.
WE'LL BE CLEAR ABOUT THE THE WAY
THAT THIS IMPACTS JOBS AND
THAT'S NOT IN THE OVERALL
CONSUMPTION BUT THE WAY IT
AFFECTS THE WAY THAT WE PRODUCE --
BEVERAGES AND AND OUR PRODUCTION.
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURES AND I
JUST PRODUCING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA MARKET WE'RE
PRODUCING.
FOR A MULTI STATE MARKET AS WELL
AS A GLOBAL MARKET AND WHAT
HAPPENS IS WHEN WE HAVE TO
PRODUCE -- SPECIFICALLY FOR A A
LABEL THAT SPECIFIC TO
CALIFORNIA OR CALIFORNIA
FACILITIES -- WILL BE THE
PRODUCTION WAS SHIFTED TO
CALIFORNIA AND IT BECOMES LESS
EFFICIENT TO PRODUCE FOR FOR
OTHER STATES AND SO THE
PRODUCTION THAT WOULD BE BASED
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
IS THEN MOVED TO NEVADA NEW
MEXICO TEXAS -- SOMEPLACE ELSE I
CAN SERVE THE SAME MARKET AND SO
WHEN OUR PRODUCTION AND OUR
FACILITIES GOES DOWN THAT'S WHEN
WE CUT JOBS AND SO THAT'S HOW
THIS ENDS UP.
HURTING A D. V. GOOD MIDDLE
CLASS JOBS THAT WE CREATE.
THERE IS ALSO AN ADDITIONAL
PUNITIVE ELEMENT FOR
MANUFACTURERS WHO DISTRIBUTORS
SELL -- YOU HAVE THEIR BUS SUGAR
SWEETENED BEVERAGES DISTRIBUTED
OR SOLD IN CALIFORNIA THEY MAY
NOT END UP KNOWING WHERE THE
PRODUCT GOES -- BUT THEY STILL
FACE THE SAME LIABILITY -- FOR
THESE REASONS SEEM TAY'S OPPOSE
SB THREE FORTY SEVEN URGES A NO
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ARE MATT CERTAIN I'M OF
THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION -- WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THE BILL CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
SENATOR MUNNINGS CONTINUED
DEDICATION TO THE TO THE
UNDERLYING ISSUE -- HERE -- BUT
FOR US THIS IS GREAT UNIQUE
IMPACTS WITHIN THE FOUR WALLS OF
A RESTAURANT -- THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION HAS BEEN
A LEADER FOR YEARS IN THIS
BUILDING ON NUTRITION WHEN IT
COMES TO RESTAURANTS WE ENGAGED
AND AGREED TO TO MENU LABELING
PROVISIONS YEARS AGO THAT
BROUGHT NUTRITIONAL INFORMATION
ON TO OUR MENUS.
WE'VE PARTNERED ON A NUMBER OF
OTHER DIFFERENT THINGS IN THIS
BUILDING INCLUDING SB ELEVEN
NINETY TWO WAS SENATOR MINING
LAST YEAR.
WHERE WE VERY?
DIFFICULT WE MOVED OUR
MEMBERSHIP INTO A NEUTRAL
TERRITORY WITH REGARD TO THE
AUTOMATIC DRINK THAT WE ARE
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE WITH REGARD
TO CHILDREN'S MEALS AND SUGAR
SWEETENED BEVERAGES.
WE WENT NEUTRAL ON THAT WE
WORKED VERY HARD WE'RE A LITTLE
DISAPPOINTED THAT AFTER.
THAT PARTNERSHIP HERE WE ARE
WITH WITH THIS BILL AGAIN SO I
WOULD LIKE TO JUST HIGHLIGHT
SOME ISSUES OF HOW THIS COMES
INTO THE FOUR WALLS OF A
RESTAURANT.
TYPICALLY IN THIS DISCUSSION THE
RESTAURANT ISSUES TAKE ASIDE
SIDE SEAT IN ART DON'T GET A LOT
OF FOCUS SO I'D LIKE TO JUST
WALK YOU THROUGH EXACTLY WHAT
HOW WE BELIEVE THIS WORKS.
THIS BILL REQUIRES THESE
WARNINGS AT THE POINT OF SALE.
TECHNICALLY IT'S THE POINT OF
PURCHASE IN THE BILL IT'S THE
SAME THING.
SO FOR US POINT OF SALE IS
CONSTANTLY MOVING ESPECIALLY
WITH TECHNOLOGY THESE DAYS IT'S
EVOLVING ALL OVER MANY OF YOU
KNOW FROM ORDERING FOOD.
WHETHER YOU'RE IN A RESTAURANT
OR OUT OF A RESTAURANT THE
ORDERING IS COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
THAN IT USED TO BE AND SO
WHETHER YOU'RE A FAST CASUAL
RESTAURANT.
A FULL SERVICE SIT DOWN
RESTAURANT WERE QUICK SERVICE
RESTAURANT THE POINT OF SALE IS
DIFFERENT AND EVEN WITHIN THE
SAME RESTAURANTS THE POINT OF
SALE CAN BE DIFFERENT. FOR
DIFFERENT INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
MAKING DIFFERENT TRANSACTIONS.
AND SO WE'RE LEFT WONDERING YOU
KNOW WHERE IS THE POINT OF SALE
WE'RE CONSTANTLY SING THE POINT
OF SALE CHANGE IN RESTAURANTS.
SO IS IT ON THE APPLICATION WHEN
YOU ORDER IS IT ON THE WEBSITE
IS IT THE TRADITIONAL CASH
REGISTER IS IT THE WAIT STAFF
AND A FULL SERVICE RESTAURANT
THAT MUST WARN YOU IS IT ON THE
BILL.
AT THE END OF A MEAL IN A FULL
SERVICE RESTAURANT IS IT ON THE
RECEIPT.
IS IT ON THE MENU IS IT ON THE
MENU BOARD THE LIST GOES ON AND
IT CREATES A COMPLIANCE
NIGHTMARE FOR US IT ALSO RAISES
CONCERNS ABOUT PUTTING POSTINGS.
EVERYWHERE TO COMPLY WITH THE
BILL AND THEN YOU HAVE TO ASK
YOURSELF WHAT IS THE VALUE OF
THAT ARE YOU DESENSITIZING
PEOPLE -- IN SIMILAR WAYS THAT
WE'VE SEEN IN THE PREVIOUS
GOVERNOR HAD MENTIONED ABOUT
PROP SIXTY FIVE SIGNS.
THOSE WE ALSO POST IN
RESTAURANTS -- AND AND SO WE
DON'T WANT THIS TO BECOME A NEW
PROP SIXTY FIVE BURDEN FOR US
BUT I THINK MORE SUPER SUPER
DESCRIPTIVE.
THE LANGUAGE IS DESCRIPTIVE THE
COLOR OF THE BACKGROUND IS
DESCRIPTIVE -- AND THEN THE
SCARY SYMBOL THAT'S INVOLVED IS
DESCRIPTIVE AND FOR US WE
BELIEVE THAT THE POINT OF SALE
SITUATION WOULD REQUIRE US TO
PUT IT ALL OVER THE PLACE -- FOR
THOSE AND OTHER REASONS WE ARE
OPPOSED TO WE WOULD ENCOURAGE
YOU KNOW VOTE.
WHICH CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOHN
LATTIMER MATH CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION WE HAVE
SOME MORE IN STORE ISSUES AT THE
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION POINTED
OUT.
WE'RE ALSO CERTAINLY ALIGN WITH
OUR MANUFACTURER PARTNERS BUT WE
TO OUR MANUFACTURE WITH A LOT OF
PRIVATE LABEL BRANDS WE HAVE
SOME OF THE SAME LABELING ISSUES
OF THE MANUFACTURERS WELL. FOR
THOSE REASONS IN THE REASONS
STATED WERE OPPOSITION.
OKAY OTHER WITNESSES OPPOSITION
BACKED BY PHONE PLEASE MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS MAP BROUGHT ON
BEHALF THE TEAMSTERS IN
OPPOSITION.
MORE TOP ON BEHALF OF ORANGE
COUNTY BUSINESS COUNCIL IN
OPPOSITION.
CAROLINE BEALE HUNTER ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA FUELS
INCONVENIENCE LINES IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
ELLERY NEAR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
REFERENCE OF REGULAR HONOR ON
BEHALF OF THE CAN MANUFACTURES
INSTITUTE IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
JOHN YOU AND ON BEHALF THE
GROCERY MANUFACTURERS IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
DENNIS I'LL BE ON AND WE HAVE
THE ALLMAN ALLIANCE IN
OPPOSITION AS WELL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON KATE BELLAMY HALF
THE CALIFORNIA AUTOMATIC VENDORS
COUNCIL WERE OPPOSED BECAUSE
JENNIFER LABEL ON THE OUTSIDE OF
ALL OF OUR VENDING MACHINES.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT -- SINGLE KNOWN AS OF
MICROPHONE QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SENATOR MITCHELL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AIR -- ONE QUICK QUESTION THEN
OF A BROADER STATEMENT SO THAT
THE RESTAURANT.
ASSOCIATION JUST -- TO ME -- AND
SO.
DO YOU INTEND TO ADDRESS OUR
ISSUES IN YOUR CLOSING OR HOW
YOU GONNA MANAGE AT LET ME JUST
BUT OKAY RIGHT NOW THIS BECAUSE
IF I GO TO A RESTAURANT MY ORDER --
ITS BEVERAGE IN ITS THIRD TO ME
IN A GLASS LEGITIMATE CONCERN I
THINK.
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT THE
ASSOCIATION MAYBE OBFUSCATED A
LITTLE BIT -- WHAT WOULD BE
ENTAILED?
SAID WE DO HAVE I ACKNOWLEDGE
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF FOOD SERVICE
SO IN FAST FOOD OFTEN YOU SERVE
YOURSELF AT A ANSWERING MACHINE.
ONE LABEL ONE TIME YOU'RE
COVERED -- IF IT'S TABLE SERVICE
IT'S IN THE MENU.
AT THE BEVERAGE SAID LIKE THE
LIKE WHAT YOUR CALORIES NOW
[inaudible]
SO.
WE'RE GLAD TO WORK WITH THEM ON
NARROWING HER OR SPECIFYING.
THAT WE'VE ALL THIS IS NOT NEW
TERRITORY -- IT'S BEEN DONE WITH
CALORIE WARNINGS -- AND I THINK
FOR A LOT OF THE FAST FOOD
PLACES. ONE LABEL ONCE ON THAT
MACHINE NOW THEY MAKE THE CASE
WILL PEOPLE ARE GONNA BE NUMB TO
IT LIKE PROP SIXTY FIVE WARNING
SO -- I'M FIRST TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THIS ISN'T THE SOLUTION BUT FROM
YOU HEARD FROM THE SUPPORT OF
WITNESSES IT'S PART OF A BROAD
PUBLIC HEALTH STRATEGY.
OF GIVING PARENTS ESPECIALLY THE
TOOLS TO MAKE INFORMED CHOICES
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT.
THANK YOU AND GETTING TO YOUR
POINT ABOUT IT'S NOT THE
STRATEGY -- FIVE CO AUTHOR AND
SUPPORTED YOU IN THIS BILL AND
YET EVERY YEAR I BRING YOU
WHATEVER LATEST OUR ARTICLE I
HAVE FOUND ON THE FACT THAT
SUGAR IS THE DEVIL.
FROM AND YOU KNOW AND I WONDER --
IT IF THE IN THAT THIS HAS BEEN
AN UP HILL BATTLE.
AND THE VALIDITY OF US
EXPLAINING THIS POLITICAL
CAPITAL.
ON THIS STRATEGY WHERE WE ARE
REALLY IGNORING.
ALL THE OTHER PLACES WE FIND
SUGAR -- YOU KNOW AND IN MY
ISSUE WITH YOU HAS BEEN IN
JUICES THAT THAT WE ALL CAN LINE
UP AND GET MAD AT YOU KNOW THE
SODA INDUSTRY BUT YOU KNOW APPLE
JUICE AND THE OTHER PLACES WHERE
SUGAR ARE AT AT EQUAL LEVELS IF
NOT MORE.
THE BILL GOES ON AND ON THE
JUICES NOW BUT BUT NATURAL JUICE
BUT ON SUGAR ADDED JUICE.
THE LABEL IS NOT BASED ON THE
PRODUCT NAME IT'S BASED ON THE
CONTENT ADDED ADDED SUGAR.
AND SO YOU KNOW WE REALLY HOPING
THAT AT SOME POINT -- GIVING
YOUR TRUE INTENT WHICH IS THE
IMPACT -- INCIDENCE OF OBESITY
AND DIABETES AND REALLY
BEGINNING TO HAVE AN HONEST WITH
OURSELVES EVERYBODY ELSE
CONVERSATION ABOUT ALL THE
PLACES ADDED SUGAR AND SUGAR IS.
BUT I APPRECIATE THAT YOU'RE
ABOUT TO TELL ME THAT THIS IS
THE NUMBER ONE PLACE ABOVE WILL
BLOCK.
BUT BUTTON WE WORK WITH IT
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE WE ARE NOT IN
A PLACE WE ARE ADVANCING THIS
CONVERSATION -- IN A MEANINGFUL
WAY TO REALLY HAVE A MEANINGFUL
IMPACT ON THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO AND I'M.
I APPRECIATE AND IN WITH YOU BUT
I REALLY HOPE THAT AT SOME POINT
WE'RE ABLE TO DANCE IS
CONVERSATION ALL -- IN A TRUE
HONEST -- WAY. ONE THING I
APPRECIATE ABOUT YOU SENATOR IS.
YOUR HONESTY.
IN YOUR DIRECTNESS.
IN.
AND WE'RE IN AGREEMENT.
I'M THE FIRST TO SAY.
PREVENTABLE DIABETES YOUTH
OBESITY IS MULTI FACTORIAL THIS
BUT THERE'S A REASON WHY ALL THE
PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATES AND WHY
THE DOCTORS AND THE SCIENTISTS.
IN IN THIS RECENT AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS WHY ARE
THEY ALL FOCUSING ON SUGAR
SWEETENED BEVERAGES AND THERE'S
AN ANSWER TO THAT.
THERE ARE SUGAR AND OTHER FOOD
PRODUCTS WE WANT TO REDUCE SUGAR
INTAKE.
ONLY A FOOD PRODUCT A DIFFERENT
PASS WITH PERMISSION OF THE
CHAIR MISSION OF THE CHAIR TO
USE THAT DEMONSTRATED.
THANK YOU.
THIS IS A TWENTY FLUID OUNCE
BOTTLE.
AND IT CONTAINS THE EQUIVALENT
OF SIXTEEN TEASPOONS OF SUGAR.
SO IT ASK YOU OR THE FOOD
INDUSTRY OR THE MEDICAL
PROFESSION. TO FIND ME A FOOD
PRODUCT THAT PACKS THAT MUCH
CONCENTRATED SUGAR.
INTO A PRODUCT WITH NO OTHER
NUTRITIONAL VALUE.
IF A CHILD DRINKS TWO OF THESE A
DAY THEY'RE INCREASING THEIR
RISK FOR DIABETES ACQUISITION.
BY 26%.
SO WE CAN LOOK AT OTHER FOODS
THEY HAVE SUGAR WE ALSO KNOW
FROM THE DOCTORS NOT THE
POLITICIANS.
THAT THE LIQUID DELIVERY.
GO STRAIGHT TO THE PANCREAS IN
THE LIVER CONVERTS THE SUGAR TO
FAT IN A MANNER THAT FOOD
PRODUCTS DON'T.
SO THERE'S A SCIENTIFIC RESPONSE
NOT A POLITICAL RESPONSE BUT I'M
THE FIRST ONE TO SIGN UP TO WORK
WITH YOU.
IF WE WANNA LABEL OTHER PRODUCTS
THAT HAVE DANGEROUS.
SUGARS OR OTHER ADDITIVES --
MUCH OF THIS.
MADAM SENATORAND MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS.
WE HEARD A LOT OF TESTIMONY ON
THE MARKETING OF TOBACCO
PRODUCTS.
YOU COULD SWITCH THE WORD
TOBACCO FOR SUGAR SWEETENED
BEVERAGES IN TERMS OF TARGETING
MINORITY COMMUNITIES CHILDREN AT
RISK MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES.
WHY ARE THEY SPENDING ALL THEIR
MONEY THERE AND SUBSIDIZING THE
SALE BUY DISCOUNTED PRICING?
THIS.
IS A LIFE AND DEATH ISSUE AND WE
HEAR THE CONCERNS OF THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY. FOR
PROTECTING PROFITS AND MARKET
SHARE.
MY BILL IS TO PROTECT THE
CHILDREN.
AND LET ME SAY SENATOR MINDING
MY RESPONSES IN THE POLITICAL
RESPONSE EITHER IT IS A
COMMUNITY BASED RESPONSE WHERE I
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE ARE CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
TARGETING ACROSS THE BOARD --
FROM SO THIS TO POOR TO TO TO
FOOD DESERT'S -- TO GET OLD FAST
FOOD OPTIONS AND SO GIVE MY ONLY
POINT IS.
I HEAR YOU I GET IT BUT IT IN IN
ALL HONESTY WE'VE GOT TO EXPAND
THE CONVERSATION TO REALLY
INCLUDE ALL OF THE BARRIERS THAT
PREVENT THESE COMMUNITIES FROM
LIVING HEALTHIER LIFESTYLES.
AND SO THAT WAS JUST THE POINT I
WANT TO MAKE SO I CAN STOP THAT.
BOMBARDING YOU WITH THE ARTICLES
I READ THE SAID THAT WE NEED TO
ADDRESS A BROADER CONVERSATION
AROUND SUGAR SALT THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU A CENTER.
SHE DOES IT SENATOR ALSO I THINK
I SAW YOU FIRST AND THEN WALK
OUT WITH CENTER RUBIO.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
PRESENTATION OF THE OF THE BILL --
AND I AM SUPPORTIVE I I DO WANT
TO POINT OUT AS BEEN POINTED OUT
TO ME THAT THERE IS A CONCERN OF
THE POSSIBILITY OF THE IMPACT
THAT IT COULD HAVE ON JOBS -- WE
NEVER WANT TO TRADE ONE FOR THE
OTHER I KNOW THAT'S WHAT YOU
BELIEVE WHEN YOU STAND FOR SO I
DO WANT TO WORK WITH YOU -- TO
SEE WHAT THE CONCERNS ARE -- HOW
SERIOUSLY CONCERNS ARE AND I I
DO WANT TO RIDICULOUSLY
ACKNOWLEDGE THE TEAMSTERS UNION --
FOR DOING THEIR JOB WHICH IS TO
PROTECT JOBS ON ESPECIALLY IF
THEY'RE GOOD UNION JOBS -- BUT I
WILL SUPPORT THE BILL AND THEN
YOU AND I KEEP TALKING ABOUT
THIS AND MEETING WITH -- THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE THE TEAMSTERS --
IF THERE IS A SERIOUS CONCERN
THANK YOU AND I APPRECIATE THAT
AND IF I COULD JUST RESPOND
BRIEFLY.
I'VE HAD HEALTHY RESPECTFUL
DIALOGUE WITH MY BROTHERS AND
SISTERS IN THE TEAMSTERS -- I
HAVE SEEN NO EVIDENCE TO SUGGEST
HOW A WARNING LABEL IMPACTS JOBS
WE'VE SEEN FROM THE BROADER
PUBLIC HALTH EFFORTS.
A DIVERSIFICATION OF PRODUCTS
AND THAT'S WHERE THE LABELS EVEN
MORE IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE BIG
MANUFACTURES.
THERE'S A DECLINE IN BUYING.
THE CLEAR SODA PRODUCTS.
AND THEY'RE BEING MOVED INTO
SPORTS TEAMS -- ENERGY DRINKS IT
CETERA WHICH WOULD ALSO GET THE
LABEL [inaudible]
THE MANUFACTURES.
THEY'RE STILL SELLING THEIR
PRODUCTS THEY NEED DRIVERS TO
DRIVE THOSE TRUCKS TO DELIVER
THE PRODUCTS NOTHING IN THIS
BILL TAKES THE PRODUCT OFF THE
SHELF.
NOTHING IN THIS BILL HAS ANY
DIRECT CORRELATION TO REDUCTION
IN JOBS.
IF ANYTHING IT'S GOING TO CREATE
SOME MORE JOBS IN THE
MANUFACTURING PLANTS AS THEY
ROTATE THEIR BEVERAGE PRODUCTS
THROUGH IN.
IN NOW INCLUDE A LABEL THEY'VE
ARGUED THAT THAT WOULD BE A
BURDEN. TO HAVE TO LABEL THE
PRODUCT -- IF YOU NOTICE IN THE
HOLIDAYS THEY LABEL THE KANSEN
THE BOTTLES WITH.
A LEASE NAVIDAD LABELS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT THEY THEY
DIVERSIFY THEIR LABELS BASED ON
ADVERTISING THEY CAN OF FIX A
SINGLE LABEL THAT'S PERMANENT.
WITHOUT LOSING JOBS [inaudible]
RUBIO.
THANK YOU.
WELL I HAD THE SAME CONCERN AS
MY COLLEAGUE -- SENATOR HOLLY
MITCHELL I THINK FOR ME IT'S A
BROADER CONVERSATION ABOUT --
LONGEVITY IN TERMS OF HEALTHIER
LIFESTYLES AND I CAN SAY WITH
CERTAINTY.
NOT THAT I SUPPORT NECESSARY THE
INDUSTRY I ADVISE ACCOUNTS
MEMBER ABOUT TEN YEARS AGO
ACTUALLY BEHIND SURREY DRINKS
FROM.
FROM VENDING MACHINES BUT THE
CONVERSATION FOR ME IS.
EXACTLY LIKE -- HOLLY SAID A
BROADER CONVERSATION ABOUT.
EVERYTHING ELSE AND I DON'T
BELIEVE NECESSARY THAT.
DIABETES IS JUST SOLELY BASED ON
THIS PODUCT AND JUSTICE AND TO
PREPARE FOR THIS I ACTUALLY
WALKED DOWN THE AISLES OF A
SUPERMARKET.
AND I WAS TAKING PICTURES OF
EVERY SINGLE LABEL AND AND I
THINK OUT THERE IS A SENSE OF
HOLES FALL TO IT. TO ASSUME THAT
THIS IN PARTICULAR IS GOING TO
DETER OUR OUR PARENTS FROM FROM
NOT PICKING UP THAT ITEM AND I
SAY THIS BECAUSE AS A VICE
PRINCIPAL AT A SCHOOL I REMEMBER
THAT WE BàN SUGARY DRINKS WE
DON'T HAVE ON CAMPUS BUT YET.
I CAN STOP KIDS FROM COMING --
WITH THEIR LUNCH WAS A FMILY
SIZED BAG OF POTATO CHIPS AND I
WOULD CONFISCATE THEM AND THEY
WOULD STILL SHOW UP IN.
THIS WENT ON FOR MONTHS AND MY
POINT IS NO MATTER HOW MANY
TIMES I TOOK COME. TO GET AWAY
AND DIE AND AGAIN I HAVE NOTHING
TO DO WITH THE STREET TRAINS.
THAT WAS THEIR LUNCHEON SO TO ME
IT'S A BROADER CONVERSATION
ABOUT EDUCATION AND AND THERE
HAS TO BE A LITTLE BIT MORE TO
THAT SO WHAT I MEAN I THINK I
HEARD YOU SAY EARLIER ABOUT TOP.
THE SERVICE INDUSTRY YOU KNOW A
LABEL ON ON THIS JUST ONE LABEL
NOW BUT IT JUST SEEMS LIKE IT
KEEPS COMING AND COMING FOR THE
WITH THE MENU AND THEN THE
CALORIES AND THEN.
SO I WANT TO TAKE A STEP BACK
AND LOOK AT THE BIG PICTURE HOW
DO WE ADDRESS THE CITY DIABETES.
IN A BROADER CONVERSATION TO
INCLUDE EVERYTHING THAT CAUSES
THE DISEASE SO FOR ME.
I'M NOT NECESSARY THERE AND THE
SAFETY OF CHILDREN MATTERS TO ME
MORE THAN ANYTHING ELSE.
I'VE BEEN A YOU KNOW AN EDUCATOR
FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS SO THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO ME CONCERN
THE FACT THAT I ALSO COME FROM A
LOW INCOME FAMILY INNER CITY
COMMUNITY.
WHERE ARE YOU KNOW A LOT OF
CHILDREN DON'T HAVE FOOD TO EAT
AND?
AND AGAIN THEY WALK RUN WITH
SODAS AND POTATO CHIPS I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT'S REALLY -- A
QUALITY DECISION FOR ME IN TERMS
OF FREE FEELING CONFIDENT THAT
WERE SOLVING THE PROBLEM.
AND I'M NOT THERE YET AND I JUST
YOU KNOW WE HAD THIS
CONVERSATION I DON'T WANT TO BE
HONEST WITH YOU.
BUT I REALLY DO THANK YOU FOR
FOR TRYING TO DO THIS YEAH AND I
AND I WILL CONTINUE O HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH CAN I LOOK FOR
TO IT AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
CANDOR AND IN OUR CONVERSATIONS.
IF I COULD MISTER CHAIR CREST DR
CO FOR TO JUST RESPOND TO THE
PART OF THE QUESTION ABOUT.
WHY FOCUSING ON SODA AND NOT
EVERYTHING ELSE?
YES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR RUBIO
WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
THOUGHTFULNESS ABOUT THIS ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE HAVE
DEMONSTRATED OVER AND OVER AGAIN
IS THAT THIS IS NOT THERE ONE
SINGLE ANSWER SO YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT I THINK YOU AND
SENATOR MITCHELL OR OR HITTING A
POINT.
THIS IS PART OF A BROADER RANGE
OF STRATEGIES TO BE ABLE TO TRY
TO HELP PEOPLE TO HAVE THE TOOLS
AVAILABLE TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
DECISIONS AND THAT'S WHY THAT
PEDIATRIC STUDY WAS SO IMPORTANT
WHEN IT CAME OUT.
BECAUSE IT COMPARED NO LABEL TO
HAVING TO CLEAR ON CALORIES
LABEL TO HAVING THE WARNING
LABEL AND WHAT THEY FOUND WAS
THAT YES SOME PARENTS STILL
PURCHASE SUGARY DRINKS THAT'S
ALWAYS GOING TO HAPPEN THE KIDS
ARE GOING TO CRAVE SUGAR OUR
BODIES CRAVE SUGAR SALT AND FAT.
THAT S OUR BIOLOGICAL REALITY
BUT THE DIFFERENCE THERE IS THAT
THE PARENTS AND WERE NO LONGER
SAYING -- I THOUGHT THAT WAS
RIGHT LIKE THE BEST EXAMPLE THAT
I CAN GIVE YOU IS THAT WHEN WE
SEND OUT OUR FAX SHE IS A
RESEARCHER AT ONE OF THE YOU SEE
THAT I WILL NOT NAME WHO DOES
SUGAR RESEARCH.
WHO RESPONDED BACK TO ME AND
SAID YOU KNOW YOU SHOULD INCLUDE
THE 1100% FRUIT JUICE BECAUSE
THOSE THERE'S DIFFERENT FINANCE
ON THAT AND I SAID ACTUALLY
THAT'S NOT THOUGH I HEAR PERCENT
FRUIT JUICE?
THE LABEL IS JUST REALLY
DECEPTIVE THAT'S WHY WE NEED OF
WARNING LABEL.
THIS IS THE PHD WHO STUDY SUGAR
ON A REGULAR BASIS WHO COULD NOT
DISTINGUISH OUR THE THE ORANGE
DRINK JUICE DRINK FROM AN ACTUAL
1100%.
ORANGE JUICE PRODUCT THAT'S
TERRIFYING BECAUSE SHE HAS A PHD
IN STUDY THIS ON A REGULAR BASIS
AND AT FIRST GLANCE COULD NOT
TELL THE DIFFERENCE HOW DO WE
EXPECT OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHO
WANT TO DO BETTER.
WHO BEEN DIAGNOSE 46% OF OUR
POPULATION HAS PRE DIABETES?
AND HAVE BEEN TOLD BY A DOCTOR
YOU HAVE A CONDITION THAT
INCREASES YOUR LIKELIHOOD OF
HAVING DIABETES IN YOUR LIFE AND
THEY'RE LIKE OKAY I'M I'M GOING
TO GET ON TOP OF IT NOW IT'S
IT'S A LITTLE LATE IF NOT
PRIMARY PREVENTION BUT I'M GONNA
GET ON TOP OF IT.
NOW AND THEN YOU'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO THAT AND
YOU CAN'T TELL THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN CERTAIN PRODUCTS IS THAT
YOU'RE SAYING WILL NOT GOING TO
CONSUME THE SODAS BUT THIS THIS
ARMS YOU DRINK THAT'S JUST RIGHT
ITS FRUIT THAT'S NATURAL.
AND SO I THINK WITH THE FINANCES
SHOWING US THAT THIS IS ONE
STRATEGY AND COULD BE A VERY
IMPORTANT STRATEGY WHEN PEOPLE
ARE TRYING TO MANAGE THEIR
HEALTH AND TRYING TO MAKE BETTER
DECISIONS AND THE LAST THING WE%
LIKE TO SEE IS.
SOMEBODY RYING AND FAILING
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T HAVE THE
INFORMATION OUR HEALTH LITERACY
IS INCREDIBLY LOW AND SO THAT'S
PART OF THE REASON WHY THE ICON
IS THERE SO THAT YOU DON'T EVEN
HAVE TO KNOW TO READ WE CAN
STILL MESSAGE THIS AND THERE CAN
BE A PUBLIC EDUCATION CAMPAIGN.
AROUND WHAT THAT ICON MEANS AND
WHY BECAUSE MANY PEOPLE REALLY
ARE UNCLEAR THAT ONE DRINK A DAY
ONE JUST ONE INCREASES YOUR
LIKELIHOOD OF DIABETES BY 27%
[inaudible]
THAT'S TERRIFYING.
THANK YOU THANK YOU -- MAKE
ANOTHER STATEMENT IF I MAY AB
BRIEFLY AND THEN OF THAT BECAUSE
WE HAVE OTHER PEOPLE IN LINE SO.
SERVE CONTINUATION OF YOUR VERY
BRIEFLY QUICKLY AND AGAIN I
DON'T DOUBT DISCOUNT ANYTHING
YOU'RE SAYING YOU'RE IT'S VALID
AND IT'S VERY IMPORTANT.
BUT I ALSO DID A LITTLE BIT MORE
TAKING A RESURGENT AND I FOUND
THAT WITHIN THE SAME PERIOD OF
TIME.
I BELIEVE DIABETES INCREASE 30%
BUT YET TRICKERY CONSUMPTION I'M
SORRY SIR HE DRINKS CONSUMPTION
DECREASED ABOUT 10%.
AND SO THERE'S A DISPARITY
BETWEEN THE INCREASE IN DIABETES
AND AND THE USE OF SURGERY
DURING SO I'M JUST TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THAT I GOING TO SAY
YES.
YEAH ALL INFORMED AND SO I DON'T
DISCOUNT YOUR STATE AND THERE IS
ALWAYS GOING TO BE A TIME LAG
JUST PUTTING ON A MINUTE BUT IN
YALA JUST BY TRAINING THERE'S
ALWAYS GOING TO BE A TIME LAG
BETWEEN.
THE TIME THAT YOU START
SOMETHING AND WHEN YOU SEE THE
FOR THE WHEN YOU SEE THE DECLINE
ALSO SOMETIMES IT DEPENDS ON HOW
SUGARY DRINKS OR TO FIND BECAUSE
WE HAVE SEEN A DECLINE IN THE
SUGARY DRINKS THAT HAVE BEEN
REGULATED IN SCHOOLS AND THINGS.
BUT ONE OF THE CAR ABOUT THAT WE
INCLUDED WERE THINGS LIKE
GATORADE IN OTHER SPORTS AND
ENERGY DRINKS AND THEY HAVE AS
MUCH OF MORE IF NOT MORE SUGAR
THAN SOME OF THE PRODUCTS THAT
WERE BANNED FROM SCHOOLS.
AND SO WE SAW A MAJOR INCREASE
ESPECIALLY IN CHILDREN TWO TO
FIVE AND CONSUMING BILLS SO WHEN
WE SAY SUGARY DRINKS IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT WHEN WE START LOOKING
AT RESEARCH TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'VE.
COMPLETELY INCLUDED THE ENTIRE
BROAD CATEGORY BECAUSE WE
SOMETIMES THAN A SHIFT FROM ONE
TYPE OF SUGARY DRINKS TO ANOTHER
TYPE OF SUGARY DRINK.
ALL RIGHT CENTER LEYVA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SENATOR
MONNING I REALLY REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR PASSION FOR THIS
ISSUE I ALSO APPRECIATE THAT YOU
ARE WORKING WITH THE TEAMSTERS
BECAUSE WE DO KNOW THAT THEY
REPRESENT A LOT OF THESE FOLKS
AND THAT THEY ARE GOOD UNION
JOBS.
AND I HAVE TO SAY -- FOR SOME MY
COLLEAGUES THAT ARE NEW HERE I
DID NOT SUPPORT YOUR BILL THE
LAST TIME AROUND WHAT CHANGED MY
MIND WAS WHEN I WAS SHOPPING AT
MY LOCAL GROCERY STORE.
AND YOU HAVE THE SODA AISLE AND
EVERYBODY KIND OF KNOWS IT SO
DOES A PROBLEM.
BUT THEN ONE I'LL OVER THE
ENTIRE FILE ON BOTH SIDES WAS
VITAMIN WATER WAS GATORADE WAS --
ICED TEA FLAVORED ICE TEA.
AND WHEN YOU CHECK ALL OF THOSE
DRINKS THEY ALL HAVE MORE SUGAR
SOMETIMES THAN SODA.
AND IT GOT ME TO THINKING ABOUT
A BILL WE JUST VOTED ON HERE
SURE -- A LITTLE WHILE AGO.
THE INDUSTRY SEEMS AS TOBACCO IS
MOVING FROM CIGARETTES TO VAPING
IT SEEMS THAT THE INDUSTRY IS
MOVING FROM SODA. TO THESE
DRINKS.
YES YES THE MOVING TO THESE
DRINKS THAT WE THINK ARE HEALTHY
AND ARE GOOD FOR US VITAMIN
WATERS HORRIBLE WHEN MY GIRLS
WERE YOUNGER AND WANT TO DRINK
AND I'M LIKE NOW -- SO I I AM
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL.
I DO AGREE IN EDUCATION WE HAVE
TO EDUCATE MORE WHEN I WAS
PREGNANT WITH OUR TWINS -- MY
JUST DASCHLE DIABETES WAS OFF
THE CHARTS BUT MY AWESOME DOCTOR
INSTEAD OF PUTTING ME ON INSULIN
SAID LET'S SEE WHAT YOU'RE
EATING SO HE MADE ME RECORD ALL
OF WHAT ALL OF MY FOOD FOR A
WEEK.
WELL WHO KNEW A MINUTE BIG
FORGIVENESS BECAUSE I WAS ONLY
TWENTY FOUR YEARS OLD.
AND WHO KNEW I WOULD I USED TO
DRINK A SIX PACK OF DR PEPPER
DAY.
I KNOW TERRIBLE RIGHT AND THEN
WHEN I GOT PREGNANT I WANT TO DO
RIGHT BY THESE LITTLE PEOPLE
INSIDE ME SO I SWITCHED TO FRUIT
JUICE AND I WAS DRINKING THIS
HUGE THING OF FRUIT JUICE EVERY
DAY.
AND THE DOCTOR SAID IF YOU CUT
THAT OUT AND SWITCHED TO WATER
WE WON'T HAVE TO PUT YOU ON
INSULIN AND GUESS WHAT IT WORKED
LIKE A CHARM.
BUT I DID NOT KNOW UNTIL I WAS
EDUCATED SO WE NEED TO EDUCATE
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE ARE NOT SO
YOUNG PEOPLE AND I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER A SENATOR
MONNING I JUST I WANNA JUST TO
ALWAYS COMPLIMENT YOU BECAUSE
YOU'VE BEEN A STALLWORTH --
ADVOCATE FOR REDUCING SHOT IT'LL
BE IS TO BE CITY I HAVEN'T
SUPPORTED -- THESE THESE SURGERY
LABOR LAYING HER TAXING BILLS
THAT YOU'VE DONE IT DOESN'T MEAN
I DON'T RESPECT WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO -- I JUST BELIEVE
THAT -- WE NEED TO HAVE A MORE --
BROAD -- VIEW POINT ON WHAT
CAUSES CHILDHOOD OBESITY
CERTAINLY -- CONSUMPTION OF
SUGAR IS IS ONE COMPONENT -- BUT
DRINKING SUGARY -- LIQUIDS IS
NOT A NEW PHENOMENON I MEAN I'D
LOVE TO SURE YOU
DRINKS WHEN I WAS GROWING UP --
MY PARENTS WERE LOW INCOME THEY
COULDN'T AFFORD TO BUY MILK
CITIES TO BUY WINE COUNTRY
CONCENTRATE NOW IS OUR MILK
UNFORTUNATELY.
THAT'S HOW ANYTHING'S WORK -- WE
HAD COKE -- WE HAD.
SEE WE HAD SEVEN UP -- BUT ONE
THING THAT -- WE HAD WHEN I WAS
GROWING UP THAT WE JUST DON'T
SEE TODAY IS -- WE DID HAVE A
SEDENTARY LIFESTYLE WHEN I WAS
GROWING UP WE HAD ACTIVE
RECREATION IN OUR SCHOOLS.
YOU KNOW RE DRESSED OUT YOU KNOW
WE WE DID WE DID TRACK WE DID
BASKETBALL WE DID FOOTBALL.
I PLAYED.
WARNER FOOTBALL I PLAYED --
BASEBALL I OF I AM IN HIGH
SCHOOL I PLAYED VARSITY FOOTBALL
VARSITY TENNIS A. B. YOU'RE
ALWAYS ACTIVE.
TODAY WITH OUR COMPUTERS AND
COMPUTER GAMES OUR KIDS ARE
SEDENTARY ENOUGH NOT BURNING THE
CALORIES IN A CONSUMING CALORIES
THE NET RESULT IS EVER GONNA
HAVE A CHILDHOOD OBESITY.
AND AN ADULT OBESITY PROBLEM --
SO -- I HOPE THAT THERE'S A WAY
WE CAN CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION.
AND AND RETURNED OP ACTIVE
RECREATION INTO OUR SCHOOL
SYSTEM OUR PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM
TO GET THESE KIDS -- TO BURNS
CALORIES AND TO GIVE THEM BETTER
CARDIOVASCULAR HEALTH WHICH
EXERCISE CERTAINLY WILL
CONTRIBUTE TO THAT.
ONLY QUESTION I'M GOING TO HAVE
FOR YOU SIR AND AGAIN ABOUT THE
WHAT WILL COURT WITH GREAT
RESPECT FOR WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO -- THE CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO -- DID LABELING AND
THEY WERE SUED AND THE JUDGES
FOUND THAT -- THERE MIGHT HAVE
BEEN SOME FIRST AMENDMENT ISSUES
AND IF THERE WAS A PROBLEM WITH
THE AMOUNT OF SPACE -- I GUESS
THAT THE THE LABELS TAKING UP.
BUT JUDGE -- COULD -- WROTE THIS
WARNING DOES NOT PROVIDE PURELY
FACTUAL NON CONTROVERSIAL
INFORMATION ABOUT THE TERMS
UNDER WHICH SERVICES WILL BE
AVAILABLE AMONG OTHER THINGS THE
WARNING IS CONTRARY TO THE
STATEMENT BY THE FDA THAT.
ADDED SUGARS ARE GENERALLY
RECOGNIZED AS SAFE I WAS
WONDERING IF IF THE LEGISLATURE
DOES PASS THIS -- WHAT IS THE
AND YOUR LAWYER -- WHAT IS THE
PRESIDENT'S OF THIS DECISION
WILL MAKE ON WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO ACCOMPLISH HERE IN THE STATE
GREAT QUESTION I'M FAMILIAR WITH
THAT CASE IN THAT DECISION?
THAT ELATED TO ADVERTISING ON
BILLBOARDS AND BUSES NOT PRODUCT
LABELING IT WAS ADVERTISING OF A
PRODUCT.
THE COURT OF APPEALS AS YOU JUST
READ FROM.
THOUGHT THAT THE WARNING LABEL
TOOK UP TO LARGEST SPACE
INTERFERING WITH THE FIRST
AMENDMENT FREE SPEECH RIGHT OF
THE ADVERTISER.
MORE IN ANOTHER CATEGORY OF A
PRODUCT SAFETY WARNING LABEL ON
THE PRODUCT THAT THE PERSON'S
ABOUT TO CONSUME.
WE ALSO DON'T TAKE UP. 20% OF
THE SPACE WE THINK WARRANT
DEFENDABLE TERRITORY ON THAT BUT
I APPRECIATE -- DOCTOR CO FOR ME
WANT TO ADD TO THAT SHE'S BEEN
INVOLVED WITH THAT CASE THANKS
FOR THE CLARIFICATION ABSOLUTELY
YES THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
SO THE THERE WAS A JUDGE ON THE
JDGE'S OPINION ON IT AND WHAT
THEY TALKED ABOUT WAS WHETHER OR
NOT SOME OF THE WORDING.
IN THEIR BILL -- WOULD PASS BE I
THINK A CAUGHT PURELY FACTUAL ON
ON A CONTROVERSIAL TEST AND
THERE WERE THINGS THAT SHE
DIFFERENT THAN OURS THE BASE BUT
USE THE NEAR TERM DIABETES OUR
LABEL SAYS TYPE TWO DIABETES
THAT'S ONE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THE INCLUDED
BECAUSE WE TALK ABOUT TYPE ONE
IT'S AN AUTO.
IMMUNE DISEASE AND IT'S NOT
CAUSED BY YOU KNOW LIFESTYLE
FACTORS SO THAT'S THAT'S ONE
DISTINCTION FROM THEIR BILL IN
HOURS THE OTHER IS THAT OUR BILL
SIMILAR TO TOBACCO AND ALCOHOL
WARNINGS.
THIS MAY CONTRIBUTE AS OPPOSED
TO CONTRIBUTE BECAUSE THAT IS
THAT IS THE REPRESENTATIVE OF
THE BODY OF EVIDENCE THAT WE
HAVE SO THOSE ARE TWO OF THE
THINGS THAT THE JUDGES -- JUST
SAID COULD POTENTIALLY CAUSE THE
PURELY FACTUAL AND
NCONTROVERSIAL -- TO COME UP
AND POSSIBLY BE QUESTIONED AND
SO THOSE ARE NOT CONSIDERATIONS
FOR OUR BILL SIMILAR -- TO WITH
SENATOR MINING SAID IN TERMS OF
THE SIZE DIFFERENCE AND JUST
OVERALL WERE UNDER A DIFFERENT
SET OF RULES BECAUSE THIS
PRODUCT VERSES I'M GENERAL
ADVERTISING.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE THOSE
PERFECTLY [inaudible]
OKAY.
RIGHT TO THE SCENE OF THE
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
I DID HAVE A FEW OF MY OWN --
AND I AGAIN CEREMONY ON THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I KNOW THIS IS SOMETHING
YOU'VE WORKED VERY HARD ON BUT
BECAUSE YOUR PASSION TO BE SURE
WE PROTECT.
PEOPLE CALIFORNIA FROM -- THE
NEGATIVE EFFECTS OF OF OF THESE
BEVERAGES.
PERHAPS HAVE A QUESTION FOR YOU
DOCTOR I THINK I KNOW WHAT THE
ANSWERS BUT YOU CAN ACT --
CORRECT ME ARE PERHAPS YOU CAN
JUST ANSWER IT AND WE'LL SEE
WHETHER YOU AGREE -- SO.
WHEN THE BIG CONCERNS OF COURSES
DIABETES AND -- IN GENERAL OF
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND IS THAT YOU
KNOW OF BEING OBESE IS A RISK
FACTOR FOR TYPE TWO DIABETES.
AND WE WANT TO TRY REDUCE TO BE
SAYING THAT I APPRECIATE YOUR
THOUGHTFUL DISCUSSION ABOUT WELL
THERE'S IT'S AT GNATS
MULTIFACTORIAL.
ANSWER ANY TYPE TWO DIABETES
MULTIFACTORIAL BUT I I GUESS
WHAT I WANT MAYBE YOU CAN EXPECT
THAT TELL ME WHAT THE RESEARCH
SHOWS IN TERMS OF TYPE TWO
DIABETES ITSELF NOW OBESITY IS A
RISK FACTOR IN ITSELF BUT WHAT
IS THE UNIQUE ROLE SUGAR
SWEETENED BEVERAGES PLAY.
AT THE IN TERMS OF PARTICULARLY
AROUND DIABETES AND METABOLIC
SYNDROME -- IS IT IS IT IS IT
MERELY BECAUSE IT CAUSES OBESITY
IN THAT FIGURES TYPE TO OR DOES
IT HAVE A PARTICULARLY.
AFFECT BEYOND JUST OBESITY IN
ITSELF YES EVEN WHEN THEY CRUISE
CONTROL -- FOR OBESITY THERE
STILL IS AN INDEPENDENT IMPACT
AND THEN IT THE PART -- THOUGHT
TO BE BECAUSE OF THE WAY IN
WHICH THE SUGARY DRINKS ARE
ABSORBED IN THEIR ABSORB MUCH
FASTER THAN CONSUMING THE
CONSUMING THE SUGAR AND FOOD.
BUT THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS
THAT WE HAVEN'T ACTUALLY DONE
CLINICAL RESEARCH LOOKING AT
SUGAR IN FOOD AND COMPARING IT
TO LIQUID SUGAR WE FOCUS A LOT
OF OUR ATTENTION AND SO WHEN
WHEN THE QUESTION COMES UP OF
SHOULD BE BE YOU TO LABELING
OTHER PRODUCTS AND OTHER.
THINGS LIKE THAT YOU KNOW AS A
SCIENCE BASED ORGANIZATION OUR
ANSWER WOULD BE.
MAYBE IN THE FUTURE ONCE WE
STUDY IT BUT WE WOULDN'T WANT TO
DO SOMETHING THAT WE DON'T THE
FINANCE TO BACK UP AND RIGHT NOW
WE HAVE THE SCIENCE TO BACK THIS
UP -- AND SO THAT'S WHY YOU
START THERE I WOULD I WOULD
NEVER WANT TO LABEL IT FOR A
PRODUCT RIGHT LIKE I COULD I
WOULD HAVE TO COME UP HERE TO
POST MY OWN BILL IF WE WERE
STARTING THE LABEL OTHER THINGS.
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE THE DATA
TO REALLY SHOW THAT HAS THE SAME
IMPACT WE HAVE SOME THEORIES AND
SOME INFERENCES WE DON'T HAVE
THOSE DATA BUT THE SUGAR THE
SUGARY DRINKS WE SEE INDEPENDENT
OF THE OBESITY.
BBC AS AN ADDITIVE FACTOR -- AND
SO IT'S MOUNT MULTI FACTOR ON
THAT WAY AND IT THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR MAKING THAT POINT
BECAUSE THAT'S CERTAINLY WHAT I
ALSO HEAR PHONE I'VE TALKED TO
IS A PEDIATRICIAN TALKING SO MY
COLLEAGUES WHO ARE.
PH AGAIN COLLEGES WHO ARE
STUDYING THIS ISSUE SO I
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND AND
APPRECIATE -- PEOPLE TO ABOUT
WELLS SUGARS THE PROBLEM SHOULD
THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT
THINGS THAT'S TRUE.
SUGAR GETS ADDED TO A LOT OF
DIFFERENT THINGS -- BUT SUGAR
THAT'S BEING CONSUMED IN LIQUID
FORM.
HAS AN EFFECT BEYOND SIMPLY JUST
THE WHAT'S MORE CALORIES AND NOW
PEOPLE ARE GETTING.
HAVE YOU HEARD TO GETTING MORE
OF THESE AND THAT'S WHAT'S
TRIGGERING IT THERE'S AN AN
ADDITIONAL FACT RELATED.
TO HOW FAST AND HOW HOW QUICKLY
IT STIMULATES THE CANCELING
SYSTEM THAT THE REACTION I DON'T
GET TO TECHNICAL HERE BUT ANY
ANYTHING. TO ME THAT IS WHY --
THIS PARTICULAR BILL AND THIS
PARTICULAR APPROACH IS SOMETHING
WE SHOULD DEFINITELY BE
CONSIDERING AND I APPRECIATE --
CEREMONY YOU YOU YOU POINT OUT
THAT JUST CAME OUT -- THE JOINT
STATEMENT FROM AMERICAN CAT
PEDIATRICS AND AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION -- WHICH A REVIEW
THE RESEARCH AND AND AND AND I
THINK THAT -- CERTAINLY YES IT
IS WE NEED TO DO OTHER THINGS WE
NEED TO LOOK AT BUILT
ENVIRONMENTS WE NEED TO DO
EXERCISE -- YOU KNOW WE NEED TO
LOOK OVER OVERALL CALORIC INTAKE --
WHICH THEN CAN TRIGGER OF THE
CITY -- SO BUT I THINK WE CAN'T.
IGNORE THE PARTICULAR ROLE OF
CONSUMPTION OF SUGAR IN THIS
PARTICULAR FORM I WOULD POINT
OUT THAT DAY -- THAT -- I
BELIEVE IF YOU DRINK ONE CAN OF
ONE STANDARD CAN OF SODA OR SOME
EQUIVALENT OF THAT EACH DAY --
THAT.
IS EQUAL TO GAINING FIVE POUNDS
IF YOU DO THIS EVERY DAY FOR A
YEAR THAT'S FIVE POUNDS OF THINK
ABOUT TEENAGER HOODS DOING
DRINKING ONE CAN OF SODA.
BETWEEN AGE THIRTEEN TWO H..
EIGHTEEN RIGHT AND THEN AND THEN
THE YOU CAN ACTUALLY ACTUALLY
STOP AT AGE EIGHTEEN RIGHT SO
THAT'S FIVE POUNDS EXTERNAL
MAYBE THEY COULD EXERCISE THAT
OFF BUT YOU JUST ADD THAT IN THE
MEASURE THEY DRINK TOO NOW IT'S
TEN POUNDS A YEAR RIGHT.
SO THAT'S FIFTY EXTRA POUNDS
SOMEONE WOULD HAVE GAINED THAT
THEY COULD HAVE AVOIDED BUT THEN
A SCAN IS THE APPOINTED AS YOU
POINTED OUT IT'S BEYOND JUST
SIMPLY THE ADDITION OF THE
WEIGHT ITSELF.
SO -- SO I THINK YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY -- WE WANT TO BE SURE
PEOPLE HAVE THE INFORMATION SO
PARENTS CAN MAKE THE CHOICES --
AYE YE I ALSO THINK A AND I I
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN ABOUT --
THAT PEOPLE HAVE WELL WHAT
HAPPENS IF PEOPLE STOP DRINKING
NAME WELL MY GUESS IS PEOPLE ARE
STILL THIRSTY AND ARE STILL
LOOKING.
FOR DRINKS THAT THEY WANT TO
DRINK -- ACTUALLY THE FORMER
PRESIDENT OF COCA COLA SAID THAT
HIS BIGGEST COMPETITIONS ATER --
YOU RECKON AND EFFECTIVE MOVED
INTO THE WATER SPACE THEN THEY
MOVED IN TREAT I THINK I'VE SEEN
AS A COUPLE CALL A BRAND.
SO -- AND I'M NOT ADVERTISING OR
ANYBODY HERE -- BUT I I THINK
THAT CERTAINLY WE WANT TO HELP
THE BEVERAGE INDUSTRY TO
ACTUALLY -- BE ABLE TO TO TO
MAKE SALES ONE TO SELL THINGS
THAT PEOPLE CAN DRINK BUT WE
ALSO WANT TO BE SURE.
THAT -- HOPEFULLY AND I AN
INCIDENT THE INDUSTRY HOPEFULLY
IS ALSO THINKING ABOUT WHAT CAN
WE DIRECT PEOPLE TOWARD THAT IS
GOING TO BE HEALTHIER.
AND WE SHOULD CERTAINLY INFORM
CONSUMERS ABOUT THAT -- SO --
THAT IF THERE'S NO OTHER
QUESTIONS IS OUR MOTION ON THE
BILL AND THE PERSON TO FILL
CENTER MONEY WHICH LIKE THE
CLOTHES.
WELL.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
THOUGHTFUL CONSIDERATION --
INFORMED AND RESPECTFUL
CONVERSATION.
YOU ALLUDED TO THE RECENT REPORT
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION
THERE'S A REASON THEY ARE
FOCUSING ON SUGAR SWEETENED
BEVERAGES.
I'M THE FIRST TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
MULTI FACTORIAL ISSUES OF
SEDENTARY LIFESTYLE.
BUT TO BURN THE CALORIES IN ONE
TWENTY FLUID OUNCE BOTTLE --
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BRING THAT
OFTEN IN GYM CLASS A YEAR AFTER
RUN A HALF MARATHON -- MARATHON
AND WE HAVE.
WHEN I WAS YOUNGER AND I'LL SHOW
MY AGE?
THE BOTTLES WERE EIGHT OUNCES
THEN TEN OUNCES AND TWELVE
OUNCES THIS TWENTY FLUID OUNCE
BOTTLE IS WHAT IS NOW THE
STANDARD SIZE IN THE VENDING
MACHINE WITH THE EQUIVALENT OF
SIXTEEN TEASPOONS OF SUGAR --
THIS IS FOR OUR CHILDREN AND
DRINKING AND PARENTS ARE BUYING
THE TWO LITER BOTTLES BECAUSE
THEY'RE IN A MARKET.
AND THE COSTS LESS THAN AN
EQUIVALENT AMOUNT OF WATER OR
MILK SO IF YOU'RE ON A FIXED
INCOME.
IF YOU'RE LIVING IN POVERTY AND
IF YOU'RE TRYING TO STOCK YOUR
KITCHEN PEOPLE ARE BUYING TWO
LITER BOTTLES THAT ARE
SUBSIDIZED NOW IN TERMS OF THE
SALES PRICE.
BY THE MANUFACTURE.
LIKE THE TOBACCO PRODUCT TO GET
FAMILIES HOOKED INDEPENDENT AND
THEN THE PRICE GETS RAISED.
SO BECOME SOUNDS STAPLE OF THE
DIET.
BREAKFAST LUNCH AND DINNER NOT A
WEEKEND TREAT.
I COULD GO ON IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME I AM A THANK YOU ALL FOR
YEAR -- INTEREST AND ATTENTION
AND LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH YOU ALL.
SHOULD WE HAVE THE VOTES TODAY
IN AND URGE YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU OKAY THANK YOU SO -- THIS
BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
LEYVA THE MOTIONS TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS A SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
PAN HI AND I STONE.
STONE NO DRAWS SO HI DRAWS --
AYE GROVE FOR TARO.
LEYVA LEYVA AYE MITCHELL.
MONNING AYE AYE RUBIO.
YEAH THE BILL HAS UP FOR VOTES.
AT THE MOMENT.
I WILL OKAY YOU COME ALL RIGHT
SAYS.
LET'S CONTINUE ROLLING IN.
SO AFTER.
OKAY WELL THAT'S A LOT MITCHELL
I RUBIO.
WITH THE CONSENT CALENDAR OKAY
HOLD ON WE HAVE CENTER BRADFORD
BEFORE WE DO ENCOUNTER YES.
HE'S BEEN VERY PATIENTS ARE --
OKAY SO THAT BILL AND OKAY SO
THAT THE SENATE.
OKAY SO THAT THE BILL IS OUT
FIVE TO ONE THANK YOU.
CENTER BRADFORD THANK YOU AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
THANK YOU -- SO THAT'S JUST TO
BE CLEAR THIS IS ITEM NUMBER SIX
SB. THREE TWENTY TWO TO THIS.
AND IT'S PRETTY MUCH STRAIGHT
FOR MEASURE SB THREE TWENTY TWO
WHICH WOULD PROTECTION NURSES
AND HEALTHCARE WORKERS ABILITY
TO SPEAK PRIVATELY WITH A STATE
INSPECTOR FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT.
OF PUBLIC HEALTH DURING AN
INSPECTION CURRENTLY IN
CALIFORNIA LABOR CODE EMPLOYEES
ARE ALLOWED TO DISCUSS SAFETY
AND HEALTH VIOLATIONS WITH A CAL
OSHA.
INSPECTOR PRIVATELY DURING THE
COURSE OF AN INCH INSPECTION OR
INVESTIGATION.
AND SIMILAR TO CAL OSHA THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH ALSO
DEPLOYS.
A PERSONNEL TO CONDUCT OUR
REQUIRED INSPECTIONS OF HEALTH
FACILITIES ON LIKE -- WITH THE
CAL OSHA -- HE'S WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
CANNOT HOW THESE OFFLINE
CONVERSATIONS.
TO LOSE SOME THEIR CONCERNS THE
MERE PRESENCE OF HOSPITAL
MANAGEMENT DURING -- CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
INSPECTIONS CAN DISSUADE NURSES
AND OTHER HEALTH EMPLOYEE FROM
FILLING SAVED TO SPEAK FREELY
ABOUT SAFETY CONCERNS THIS IS A
MEASURE THAT -- HAS NO
OPPOSITION THESE POLICIES ARE
SIMPLY CONTRADICTING CALLS
UNNECESSARY DANGERS CONFUSION
DURING STATE RUN INSPECTIONS AT
THE WORKPLACE AND HERE WITH ME
THE DAY WE HAVE TAYLOR JACKSON
FROM CAL FOR NURSES ASSOCIATION.
WHO -- HE IS IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL ENTERS ANY QUESTIONS TO BE
MORE APT ASSN I RESPECT AS
PRIVATE I THANK YOU IT MAY
NOTICE HE SAID NO FORM
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- AS THE SENATOR SAID
MY NAME IS SHEILA JACKSON I'M
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION WHO IS THE
SPONSOR OF SB THREE TWENTY TWO
IT IS MORE EFFICIENT FOR WORKERS
AND SATE DEPARTMENTS OF
CONCERNS CAN BE RAISED DURING
THE PROCESS OF AN INSPECTION.
RATHER THAN AN ANONYMOUS
COMPLAINT CURRENTLY A WORKER CAN
CALL DPH AN IMPORTANT ISSUE
WHICH OFTEN RESULTS IN A
SURPRISE HOSPITAL INSPECTION OR
UNDER SENATOR RADFORD'S BILL
THEY CAN REPORT THE SAFETY
CONCERNS CONFIDENTIALLY WHEN A
DPH INSPECTORS ALREADY ON SITE
FOR AN INSPECTION.
THIS BILL DOES NOT CREATE NEW
WHISTLEBLOWER PROTECTIONS
HEALTHCARE WORKERS ARE ALREADY
PROTECTED UNDER THE LAW FROM
RETALIATION FOR REPORTING
PATIENT SAFETY CONCERNS OR
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUES.
IT THEREFORE MAKES SENSE TO
FURTHER FACILITATE PROTECTING
THESE WORKERS BY ALLOWING THEM
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
PRIVATELY WITH AN INSPECTOR FROM
DPH ALL RIGHT WHICH HAS SENATOR
BRADFORD SAID THEY ALREADY HAVE
WITH THE STATE INSPECTOR FROM
CAL OSHA.
LET'S LET NURSES DO WHAT THEY DO
BEST BE PATIENT ADVOCATES SEE
NAY RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBER SERRA FLOCKS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION WE KNOW THAT RANK AND
FILE WORKERS NO THEIR WORK
PLACES BETTER THAN ANYONE ELSE
THEY'RE THE ONES WHO KNOW THE
INS AND OUTS HEALTH AND SAFETY
VIOLATIONS.
MANAGEMENT OR AS WE CALL IT THE
pON THEM BEING HONEST AND SO THIS
IS JUST A COMMONSENSE BILL WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
I THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
MR TURN MEMBERS MARK MENDOZA
WITH THIS YEAR YOU CALIFORNIA
AND STRONG SUPPORT ESPECIALLY
WHEN ENFORCING TITLE TWENTY TWO
REGULATIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- ANY OPPOSITION.
THE CARD THANK YOU -- AND
QUESTIONS OF COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
AND NOW OKAY DEALS BEEN MOVED BY
SIR LEYVA -- AS THE RECORD WHICH
LIKE CLOTHES I HAVE A FIVE
MINUTE CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK.
YOU CAN A LOS YOUR VOTES THERE
OKAY -- OKAY SO MOVED BY CENTER
LEAVE THE THE MOTIONS TO PAST
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
AN AN ICE STONE.
TORONTO I DRAWS -- I'D GROW --
TADO [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MITCHELL.
MONNING AYE MONNING AYE RUBIO.
THE AYE.
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS.
THE BILL HAS SIX VOTES -- WILL
HOLD THE ROLE -- FOR APPS
MEMBERS -- NEXT UP -- CONSENT
CALENDARS A MOVE FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
OKAY A TO CENTER -- LEAVE US
SENATE EXTENT CALENDAR SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ONLY ONE ITEM THAT'S
AS BEFORE FORTY THANK YOU.
PAN FIVE AND I STONE.
DRAWS SO I DRAWS -- I'D GROW
FURTADO. FOR TOTAL AYE LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE MITCHELL AYE MITCHELL
AYE MONNING MONNING AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO HI.
OKAY THAT -- CONSENT CALENDAR
HAS SEVEN VOTES -- ME BACK.
OKAY ALL RIGHT SO HE IS AT SEVEN
THAT'S ALRIGHT LET'S -- LET'S GO
THROUGH I SEE DO WE HAVE.
THE STUBBLE CENTER FOR ACTION.
AND TO SOME MISSING.
OKAY SO IT'S GO THROUGH THE K. --
SO ITEM -- NUMBER -- FOUR SB --
THIRTY NINE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
OF ABSENT MEMBERS DORADO I WAS --
I LEYVA LEYVA I OKAY THAT BILLS
OUT -- NINE ZERO TEXAS.
LET'S SEE HOW THAT'S BRADFORD
LAST THREE ABOUT THE TENTH.
AT TEN CALENDAR.
YES -- OKAY YES OF PLEASE KEEP
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ABSENT
MEMBERS ON ITEM NUMBER SIX SB --
THREE TWENTY TWO SEPARATE THESE
CALL THE ROLL STONE HI STONE I
GROWTH MITCHELL.
MITCHELL I THEY SAID THAT BILLS
OUT -- EIGHT ZERO WILL -- THAT'S
CALLED THE CONSENT CALENDAR ONLY
ONE ITEM SB -- FOUR FORTY SIX
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT
MEMBERS STONE STONE I GROWTH.
AND THAT THAT SAID KILLERS OUT --
EIGHT ZERO OKAY.
OKAY I THINK THAT'S RIGHT.
AND ITEM NUMBER -- SEVEN JUST
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
THROW.
HER TADO RUBIO.
OKAY THAT BILLS OUT FIVE ONE
THANK YOU.
I WITH THAT THAT CONCLUDES THE
VICTIM OF THAT THAT CONCLUDES
THE AGENDA OF THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH -- THIS IS
HEARING IS NOW ADJOURNED